skull with scissors and then collapsing
the skull
uh this is gruesome and i i don't like
having to quote this but the it is
relevant to the topic we're covering
here justice kennedy described it this
way in chilling terms when he
in his descent when he describes the
fact that when scissors
are inserted into the back of the head
the fetus's body wholly outside the
woman's body and alive
reacts as though startled and then goes
limp
justice scalia in his great eloquence um
uh
expressed um
uh lamented the ruling but also
expressed optimism for the fact that
future courts would get it right
saying quote i'm optimistic enough to
believe that one day stenberg vs carhart
will be assigned to its rightful place
in the history of this court's
jurisprudence beside koromatsu and dred
scott this method of killing a human
child
one cannot even accurately say an
entirely unborn human child
prescribed by this statute is so
horrible that the most clinical
description of it evokes a shutter of
revolution
we
then saw a few years later the supreme
court of the united states issue a
different ruling the supreme court
issued a different ruling in a case
called gonzalez v carhart gonzalez v
carhart upheld a different statute this
one was federal rather than state
but it was a different federal stat
a federal statute that
also prohibited uh partial birth
abortion
judge jackson can you distinguish these
cases for me what was the difference
between
uh gonzalez v carhartt where the partial
birth abortion ban in question
was upheld whereas in stenberg b carhart
it was invalidated
thank you senator i don't have the
opinions in front of me i think um
i think it
had to do with
um
the method of extraction the fact
finding related to
um
the procedure
i in one case the district court
had made some findings in and the court
felt bound by them and another
uh there was
considerations beyond those that
were previously
um relied upon
so there were distinctions that the
court
looked at and considered in the cases
but i'm
yes
let's talk about court packing for a
minute yes
one of the reasons court packing
concerns me one of the many reasons
is because
it's not prohibited in the first
instance it's not prohibited by the
constitution there's nothing in the
constitution that says that congress uh
may not change the size of the supreme
court there's no limitation on that
we have uh for 152 years stuck with the
number nine it it has worked
uh and the absence of an argument saying
that that number is two
is too uh uh
low that the court is too small
from a workforce standpoint we need to
expand it it's difficult to imagine uh
why it would be a good idea to change it
particularly because if you increase the
size of the court
in in one fell sloop swoop and you you
uh do that for
partisan political purposes allowing one
president the current president
to have a disproportionate impact on the
court and to change its rulings that
that portion of the court docket that
tends to be more politically contentious
it can
turn the court into
a political football of sorts
given the the fact that our supreme
court justices
uh uh serve for life um
once you do that
it it becomes something of a one-way
ratchet always expanding never
contracting before long you could see an
increasingly larger court with the court
expanding each time a different party
secures the coveted circumstance of a
majority of the house majority in the
senate and controlled by the same party
of the white house
and so this is why it concerns me
i understand that
why it is that uh the canons of judicial
ethics don't allow you to comment
on matters that might come before you
this is one that could not come before
you as a justice this is a
non-justiceable political question it's
committed to the two political branches
of government there's not even a
constitutional challenge that could lie
to it even though it's it would
undermine the separation of powers in
the constitution as i see it
it's it's not unconstitutional so it
couldn't and it would never come before
you
uh
last night when you were asked a
question by my colleague uh senator
kennedy
on this you acknowledged that you have
an opinion did i understand that right
you have an opinion on court packing
senator i have a lot of opinions i have
opinions on
i'm a human being and i have an opinion
on a lot of things the reason why
in my view
it
is not appropriate for me to comment is
because of my
fidelity
to the judicial role i understand
that it's a political question and that
is precisely why
i think that i am uncomfortable speaking
to it no i understand that and i out of
respect
respect the impulse i i respect the the
overall um
issue and i think it's it's better for
article three judges and justices
ordinarily to not wade into the
political thicket this one i do think is
different because number one as i say
can never come before you number two
it does
have an impact on
what you would be doing and you also as
an article three judge
someone who served for nearly nine years
as a federal judge you've developed
experience and intuition and a thorough
understanding of our federal court
system and that's why i think your
perspective on it would be valuable
the reason it concerns me so much is
that even when court packing doesn't
succeed legislatively
it can leave an impact the last time
this was attempted was in 1937 president
franklin d roosevelt was upset at the
supreme court on a number of of bases
he didn't like uh the uh
then 32 year old president of lochner
versus new york where the
five conservatives
on the supreme court engaged in an act
of judicial activism reading something
into the constitution that wasn't really
there some people disagree with me on
this but i it wasn't there
and they imposed that but the bigger
reason was he didn't like the court's
interpretation of the commerce clause
it was that interpretation of the
commerce clause the one we discussed
yesterday you know
uh prior to 1937
you you had uh
the supreme court agreeing as far as the
channels and instrumentalities of
interstate commerce that we talked about
yesterday you had the court more or less
in agreement over time as to the impact
of the dormant commerce clause but as to
the substantial effects test that didn't
exist yet
it required something much closer to
an interstate commercial transaction
uh in order for commerce congress's
commerce clause authority to kick in
there were the uh the so-called four
horsemen of the apocalypse as fdr
affectionately called them uh four
conservatives who were consistently
pushing
for limits on congress's authority
and then you had other justices who
would sometimes join with them usually
that included justice owen roberts who
had stood with them in maintaining
narrower authority
for congress under the commerce clause
all that change went on april 12 1937
two weeks to the day when the
the case often associated with the
so-called switch in time that changed
nine a west coast hotel versus parish
or where they undid the lochner
precedent
april 12 1937 the supreme court decided
a case nlrb versus jones and laflin
steel that forever changed and magnified
expanded the commerce clause
in a way that had it been through a
constitutional amendment it would be
among the most significant impactful
constitutional amendments ever adopted
and yet it's rarely discussed
this this case resulted from
one vote one
person on the supreme court who changed
his vote associate justice owen roberts
it's widely believed that i believe it
based on what i've researched on it he
was influenced heavily by fdr's court
packing plan
he didn't want to be on a court that was
packed he didn't want
he he convinced himself that he
made that switch
in order to save the court as
it was
and that has changed everything it's
it's led to a much bigger more expensive
more intrude intrusive federal
government we can disagree
as to the policy merits of that but it
did change the constitution that's why i
worry about that so i i hope i
understand you don't want to answer it i
hope that uh between now and the end of
the day you'll see fit to tell us what
your opinion is i do think it's it's
worth worth discussing
let's talk for a minute uh i've got just
the moments left
i want to get back to your your your
sentencing approach
um
now
when you
approach these child pornography cases
what you're describing
uh in many circumstances is an overall
concern that you've got with the
sentencing guidelines and particularly
that portion of the sentencing
guidelines
uh that deals with uh child pornography
cases this showed up in the um in the
transcripts of some of your sentencing
hearings including the the uh
uh
the transcript of your sentencing
hearing in the in the hawkins case
i turned to that uh to page 38 uh lines
17 to 24 of that transcript and here's
something you say in that hawkins case
uh and i believe this was the 18 year
old defendant that you sentenced to to
three months in prison when the lower
end of the guidelines range would have
been 97 i think the higher end would
have been in the 120s or something like
that
you said and in your case this is you
speaking to mr hawkins in your case in
particular i don't feel that it is
appropriate
necessarily to increase the penalty on
the basis of your use of a computer
or the number of images
or prepubescent victims as the
guidelines require because these
circumstances exist in many cases
if not most
and don't signal an especially heinous
or egregious child pornography offense
i've got a couple of questions about
that were those
you start out that paragraph sounding
like you're you're making a
determination as to him but then the
observations you make in that paragraph
seem to apply
broadly is that is that right
so
senator um
i don't have the transcript of mr
hawkins case i recall that i found that
case
um like all child pornography cases
to be
difficult really difficult
and his case
i recall was
in many ways an outlier
in terms of the various considerations
that congress required me to take into
account but there were prepubescent
victims that were at stake i don't
remember how many i don't remember the
circumstances of his actual
uh crime
what what i will say is that
consistent with supreme court case law
and congress's statute in this area
judges have to take into account
a number of factors and
the guidelines which are no longer
um i won't say not mandatory you have to
calculate the guidelines they're no
longer binding
and the supreme court has said that
under the statutory scheme judges have
discretion but okay but my i'm almost
almost out of touch i want to make the
point yes hawkins as i recall and as as
senator hallway discussed yesterday he
specifically asked for images of 11 to
17 year olds so i i i don't understand
how that can be a an instance
where that shouldn't matter
and whether
the fact that he
did it with a computer
hardly at tones for what he was doing
hardly offsets the fact that he was
seeking
and obtained prepubescent child
pornography images nor does the fact
that the the images become easier over
time to transmit and receive and store
because of computers
i actually think it cuts in precisely
the opposite
direction that you describe it makes it
more severe
not less i they see this as an
aggravating factor and that that is of
great concern to me i see i've exceeded
my time thank you
you may respond
senator as in every
child pornography case
that i sentenced
i considered
all of the evidence all of the relevant
factors
it is um
not the same exercise
to look at a transcript
to
think about guidelines to
um
not have in front of you the individuals
the victims the pictures the
circumstances that trial judges have to
review in these cases or any cases i
understand senator that
there are some questions about records
etc
courts have
all of the evidence
and courts have all of the
recommendations of various parties and
courts
have under
congress's authority the responsibility
of using our judgment to make
determinations that
are sufficient but not greater than
necessary to comply with the purposes or
promote the purposes of punishment
taking into account
things like unwarranted sentencing
disparities and it may seem it may seem
like an easy exercise it may seem in
retrospect when you look back
at a few pieces of data that courts have
not
done what it is that they're supposed to
do but what i can assure you
is that i took every one of these cases
seriously
in my duty and responsibility as a judge
and i'd made my determinations in light
of
the seriousness of the offense the
nature and circumstances of the offense
the history and characteristics of the
defendant the need for the sentence
imposed to promote various purposes of
punishment and all of the other factors
that congress prescribes okay but you
keep resetting that standard and get you
specifically excluded
from consideration the fact that he had
requested and obtained
images prepubescent child pornography
images senator i didn't i didn't exclude
it i didn't exclude it what i did
was i looked at the guidelines which is
what
the supreme court requires and i may i
was making policy determinations as the
supreme court says that judges are to do
look at age 38 of your transcript it
looks to me like you excluded it and and
uh your your actions sentencing him to
three months
for one of the most heinous offenses
imaginable keep in mind because these
are transmitted electronically they're
there for years they re-victimize these
victims senator the rest of their lives
we're asking everyone to try to stick
with the 20 minutes please
next is senator klobuchar but before
recognizing her i'd like to ask consent
to enter into the record
a support letter for judge jackson from
48 former federal prosecutors in south
florida without objection senator
klobuchar thank you very much chairman
durbin welcome back judge jackson
uh yesterday you and i discussed the
court's increasing reliance on issuing
unsigned orders on its shadow docket
and less than an hour ago
the court once again used a shadow
docket
to throw out wisconsin's redistricting
maps
and because this decision just came out
i don't expect you to have immediately
reviewed it
but
i just want to make this point that in
her dissent
justice sotomayor joined by justice
kagan called the court's move
unprecedented
she noted that in an emergency posture
the court summarily overturns a
wisconsin supreme court decision
resolving a conflict over the state's
redistricting a decision that was
rendered after a five-month process
involving all interested stakeholders
based on an obligation that is this are
her words hazy at best even though
summary reversals are generally reserved
for decisions in violation
of settled law
and again i don't expect you to be
familiar with this case but i do want to
point out that this underscores the
point that i made yesterday that the
court's increasing practice
of using the shadow docket to decide
cases that have grave consequences for
our democracy including the right to
vote that you and many other nominees
have said is fundamental is incredibly
troubling you had in the other case i
mentioned yesterday where justice
roberts dissented
the texas abortion bounty hunter case
that that should not have been done
on the shadow docket and while i'm not
going to ask you about this because you
couldn't possibly have read it just your
record of
writing decisions that are thorough and
listening to litigants in cases could
you just generally talk about the
importance of having full briefings on
the merits as well as public oral
arguments
if you believe in transparency
thank you senator as um
as a judge
in
my
work over the last decade
um i've seen that it is very important
at least
to me
in my
time as a judge up to date
um to hear arguments from all sides in a
case
the duty of a judge
in
is to make determinations and
um
under our system of adversarial
uh proceedings you make determinations
uh based on arguments
um and
and it's important to do so
i know that um with respect to the
emergency docket i
um
you haven't asked me the question about
it um
because i would say what i said before
which is i would benefit from being able
to speak with
uh the justices i understand that
there's a need to balance
um getting full briefing with emergency
circumstances and the court has long had
in its
um
in its procedures the ability to
uh to rule uh quickly on various cases
it's also
my understanding from my time clerking
on the court that the court
does
recognize the value of allowing things
to what we call percolate meaning
lower courts to hear issues and
my understanding is that at least in
some
of the recent cases the justices have um
have had oral argument related to some
emergency
matters but from my perspective as a
judge in the work that i've been doing
i know that it's important to hear from
the parties
another hallmark of your work has been
taking complex issues and making them
accessible to the public
so much so that i actually referred to
one of your opinions from a debate stage
in los angeles
saying as a wise judge said those were
my words i guess i was ahead of my time
uh the president is not king in america
the law is king i paraphrased it that
was a written opinion
that you wrote that was over 65 pages a
long uh relied extensively on supreme
court and circuit uh precedent
it was committee on the judiciary v
mcgann
and could you talk about really two
things the importance of
having the law written in terms that are
easy to understand by people and then
secondly your opinion was actually a
narrow one uh it required mr mcgann to
appear to testify
but that said he remained free to assert
any legally applicable privilege in
response to the questions asked so what
you did there i was a narrow opinion
what what role do you think that narrow
rulings play in helping to maintain the
legitimacy of the court why is it
important to have plain language in
orders
thank you senator um
well i'll start with the second first i
think
that um
you know as as we've been discussing
we have a rule of law in this country
which
um
requires a certain amount of
predictability and stability in the law
if there are big shifts
in terms of legal principles and
doctrines and whatnot
it could lead to
people
not understanding that judges are ruling
on legal principles it could lead to
undermining public confidence thinking
that judges are
injecting their own policy preferences
rather than following
the law
in in in terms of their rulings and so
um
to further
predictability stability there are many
uh doctrines in
um judicial practice
there's starry decisis which is the
principle that if something has already
been decided um
very similarly you
at least if it may be binding on you if
you're a lower court but at least you
have to contend with it
because that is the law that was that
existed before you got the case and you
don't want to make a big shift
um
and then there's also the principle that
um
you know the understanding that when you
are announcing
uh uh
rulings you are building on what exists
before and so not so you don't want to
make a big shift if you don't have to
because um if you can find a way to rule
incrementally in a more narrow way it
keeps the law uh stable is a part of
the proposition that i that i mentioned
before
um in mcgahn in particular it was um
it was a case in which there was a
precedent
directly on point from my district it
was not binding on me but the exact same
set of circumstances and arguments had
been presented to another judge in my
district i believe it was something like
10 years prior to my case and so we had
law
that governed the circumstance and i
looked at that determined it was
persuasive and that i should continue
the principles that had been laid down
by by in the prior case
also
in accordance with those principles um
the prior judge and i made the
determination that when the president
claims absolute immunity
the argument was that
the person who had been subpoenaed by
the legislature
a former employee of the white house
um
[Music]
could
could
say that they had
uh immunity of some
sort in other words it could have um
invoke executive privilege in response
to particular questions
but they couldn't say
i don't have to show up at all
and so the argument that was being made
was when the house of representatives
issues a subpoena and says show up on
this day at this time to answer
questions
does that person can that person just
ignore and and say i have immunity i
don't have to follow um
the law in in other words respond to the
subpoena or do i have to show up and sit
there and listen to the questions and if
there are things that i believe i can't
answer because they're privileged then
you invoke the privilege and the prior
case had said in this narrow way
you have to show up you don't
necessarily have to give the information
that's
determined on a question by question
basis but you have to show up
and that's
what i held in that case as well and it
and it's important to be clear in your
rulings so that people understand that
judges are are ruling consistent with
the law and not their own personal views
right and um
uh speaking of being clear and being
careful in your rulings um some of my
colleagues have i think given um
not a necessarily true
view of your whole record because when
it comes to your rulings being upheld
the numbers show that out of over
550 cases
um your district court cases you were
reversed less than three percent of the
time uh and in some of the instances you
were reversed
only to have your decision later upheld
um i noticed one case territory of guam
the united states
in which you were initially reversed but
then a unanimous supreme court reversed
that decision
then siding with you
in an opinion written by justice thomas
and aligned with your view do you want
to quickly talk about that case
um well that case is kind of legally
complicated it was a it was a circle
case which is um a superfund cleanup
kind of case where the
country of guam which had um which has a
a dump site on it
that was used uh by both the citizens of
guam and the united states
before the 1950s when the united states
was stationed there military operations
happened out of guam and there was a lot
of dumping into this site
and um
over time the site got contaminated and
guam was charged with
having to clean it up which is millions
and millions of dollars and there are
statutes very complicated statutes about
the circumstances under which you can
seek contribution
um under which a country like that can
ask for
the united states to pay some of that
cost or other countries to pay some of
that cost
and that was sort of the nature of the
dispute and i did a statutory
interpretation
about
whether or not guam's action could
proceed
the united states filed a motion to
dismiss
saying that all of the technical
requirements of the law weren't met and
that the
action had to be dismissed and i denied
the motion to dismiss after interpreting
the statute saying that the action could
continue
the dc circuit reversed my view had a
different reading of the statute
saying that the motion to dismiss should
have been
granted and dismissed the case
and then it was appealed to the supreme
court and as you say the supreme court
reinstated the action saying it could
proceed very good thank you
um
in 1972 in bransberg v hayes a 5-4 court
i did not recognize the reporter's
privilege in the context of criminal
grand jury testimony
and i spoke with you earlier
at length about times v sullivan and
first amendment issues so this will be
my last question on this since the
court's decision my state like many
other states enacted strong reporters
privileged laws to protect journalists
from having to divulge unpublished
materials confidential sources how would
you approach balancing the need to
protect journalists and the role they
play in informing the public against the
need for law enforcement officers
to gather information
i would apply
um the the precedence of the supreme
court in this area it would depend on
the circumstances
as as i mentioned
um
press freedoms is one of the
fundamental first amendment rights
um the court has uh a number of
precedents in terms of of
expressive freedom press
freedom and
um
in every case um there will be a
specific set of circumstances regarding
an alleged violation of the right
and the court would need to look at
the facts and circumstances the prior
precedent uh in order to determine
whether that particular regulation um uh
could be upheld okay thank you this is
my very last question chair before all
of us get to eat lunch
including you
um
and that is really the important role of
dissenting opinions justice ginsburg
once said this she said dissent speak to
a future age
it's not simply to say my colleagues are
wrong and i would do it this way
but the greatest dissents do become
court opinions and gradually over time
their views sometimes become the
dominant view
um when justice ginsburg's rabbi uh gave
a eulogy at her memorial service here in
the capitol
um and some of us were fortunate enough
to be there
they said
justice ginsburg's dissents were not
cries of defeat they were blueprints for
the future uh what do you think is the
purpose of a descent and
um you want to talk just a little bit
about that this idea that they can be
blueprints for the future
thank you senator um
on the supreme court um there are nine
justices and um
in every case they're all sitting
together to hear
the issues in a case and
[Music]
one hopes and and it often happens that
the justices
agree as to
issues in cases that i believe
that the vast majority of cases that the
justices here are actually not
um
there is no dissent that they that they
agree to the outcome
but there are cases in which after
uh deliberation and collaboration and uh
consideration the justices
may disagree about how
um how the case should be resolved and
there's a mechanism for
every justice to decide whether they're
going to join others
either
in the majority whether they're going to
write a separate opinion that might
agree with the majority but wants to
make a different point
or whether they they want to dissent and
sometimes more than one justice might
dissent or join a descent it's a way of
expressing
expressing one's own view that may
differ
from
uh from your colleagues and with respect
to the point um that you made
there are actually many
justices in history who have used
the dissent mechanism
to
discuss the law in ways that others find
over time to be more persuasive and so
i'm thinking of
i'm thinking of the first justice harlan
who
dissented famously in plessy versus
ferguson he dissented alone um all of
the other justices agreed um with the
proposition of
of separate but equal and he said no in
a dissent and his dissent
um generations later became
according to to justice thurgood
marshall became the blueprint for
justice marshall to make arguments that
led to brown versus the board
so there is the opportunity
for justices to
describe their views in ways
that become persuasive to others
in the future
thank you for um all you've given us the
last few days we look forward to working
with you thank you thank you thanks
senator klobuchar and we're going to
break now for a 30-minute lunch i would
i'd say to everyone when we return if we
stick to 20 minute rounds and don't
yield back time we'll be finishing in
something around four and a half hours
let's take a break
at seven o'clock so that doesn't include
a break but we'll consider that later on
thank you
all right everybody they stand in recess
this is day three of the confirmation
hearings for judge kitanji brown jackson
misnamed by ignorant right wingers over
the last 24 hours as
catania
kentaji
and lots of other names which we can get
to
if that's interesting to people that
will be
uh coming up no reports as to what is
for lunch today pizza is here but uh we
have subway tomorrow
warm food around noon yeah
uh okay so we're gonna keep an eye on um
on on all of that stuff
what a day welcome everybody yesterday a
14 hour stream it was crazy i got calls
from attorneys general
in mostly southern states saying
sir you can't do that
sir you can't do that
and i said um well we did it
we did it and we did it with a coupon
code and we just it was just everything
everything happened and it all happened
all at once so we're going to be looking
at a lot of different things here during
this break
uh thank you to jen here as well as zath
ross
and aj 4
as well as e
haines the first four people uh thanks
for the twitch prime subs today i really
do appreciate it um if you missed
yesterday
we had like a cr when we hit the 13th
hour of the stream we set up a coupon
called code it wasn't a coupon cold it
was actually a coupon warm warm food
around noon yeah no we set up a coupon
code way too long whoa senator kennedy
looking extremely disheveled did you
guys see that that was wild
um the coupon code way too long in honor
of the the stream going to the 13th hour
saved people crazy amounts of money and
about 100 people took advantage of it
but that was yesterday that is not today
folks wondering about the different
people misnaming
judge katanji brown jackson here's for
example troy york who called in
there is no doubt that
the joe biden nominee for the
supreme court
brown jackson there it is of course we
don't really care what troy york has to
say he's been leaving racist voicemails
for
five six seven eight years ten to 15
voicemails a week
we don't really care about that
um
why does the archive of yesterday's
stream cut off at just under 12 hours
yeah i guess there's a 12 hour limit for
archived youtube
um
streams does anybody know are the full
14 hours archived on twitch i don't know
if fitch has that same 12 hour limit
anybody know
nobody knows
we don't know okay you could check the
vod on twitch
over 14 hours it's archived okay good
yeah so i've heard katanji brown jackson
called
kentaji
catania
and kenyina
here is
let's see
here's tucker
tucker carlson
who referred to her as uh
contagi
go mines
one way to know one indication would be
her lsct scores right the lsat is not a
knowledge test
it measures logic and reasoning ability
and no one doubts it's an accurate
measure of those things which predicts
legal skills and that's why top law
firms law schools have long used that
test
so how did kintaji brown jackson do it
yeah how did kintaji do i guess we just
don't know
um okay so anyway there's tucker carlson
and it's just it's all horrifying it's
all completely and utterly completely
horrifying couple actually about a
hundred people were banned yesterday
during their
um
during the stream
uh some people want to be unbanned
let's see
so there was a user named debate boar
who sent quite literally
hundreds of chat messages yesterday and
no one message was like that bad
but it was just completely and totally
relentless
and sending paragraphs and paragraphs
so they were banned and now they're
saying they would want to be unbanned
i'm willing to unban them and i'll do
that but you can't you can't send a
hundred messages a minute you know it's
like no matter what you're saying that's
just obnoxious and we unfortunately or
fortunately depending on your
perspective we just can't tolerate that
okay so um so that is that let me get
some things up on the screen here that i
wanted to look at with everybody
um let's see what we've got here
um
charlie kirk weighed in on the
nomination and as as many of you know
this is this is one of the first people
we go to when we wonder
what should the direction of the
judiciary be in the united states i
think let's ask charlie kirk these very
simply stated questions
do not require overthinking
so i suppose another question here
though is where does this come from
well kbj
katangi brown jackson is what your
country looks like
on critical race theory
kbj is your country on crt
kbj
katangi brown jackson is an embodiment
of the tyranny that we currently live
under
she's an ideological unintelligent yet
confident fanatic who is so dismissive
that you might even ask the question of
what a woman is right it's hard to think
of someone more wrong about everything
this is my area of expertise
charlie kirk now on the thing of what is
a woman
it's actually a really old technique
to try to pull someone into a rhetorical
black hole
and as an example jessie lee peterson
asked me the same question when i was on
his program this is gonna be tough to
find but let's just see if we can find
it
because of the uh polling in the
house races
so did you believe an awful lot of
people a lot of decent people
love what is love
i i don't do dictionary definitions you
don't no so you do you know what love is
ah i think you know love when you see it
and
and what is it when you see it
you just know it you can't even put it
into words it's so ethereal
amazing yeah um
i gotta ask i know you need to make i
want you i know you're here for the uh
event this weekend oh wait maybe it was
earl maybe the question about what is a
man was right before that we see it with
the representatives the children are
going to cafes at restaurants and
airports and just carrying on right it's
turning off a lot of people a lot of
decent people i guess we'll see do you
really believe that it's happening i
don't think so not not i'm not seeing
that now i gotta ask you
what is a man i'm sorry what is a man
i do politics not dictionary are you a
man
i think so so anyway
it is absolutely correct not to engage
with those bad faith questions you know
dictionary definite it's just so boring
and it's it's an old technique
and there's no um
there's there's just no upside to
engaging in it and i'm glad that judge
katanji brown jackson did not engage in
it yesterday because it's a black hole
it's a rhetorical black hole
um and good for her thank you to grandpa
simpson
for signing up via twitch prime
you are a good sir i appreciate that
very very much um let's look at a couple
other clips let's see what we've got
here
um oh i guess uh before we went live
today i guess lindsey graham
threw another tantrum today let's take a
look at your view of how to deter
child pornography child pornography
banography
it's not my view i think you're doing it
wrong and every judge who does what
you're doing is making it easier for the
children to be exploited if you're on a
computer right now looking at a kid in a
sexually compromising situation and you
get caught i hope nobody gives you a
break because you use the computer
the conduct that's been described is
reprehensible and i think everyone in
this room agrees
and the fact of the matter is that i'm
co-sponsor of your bill the earned act
and i believe that we should be doing
our job here but part of our job we have
failed in responding to the changing
circumstances that face this crime what
has it been 15 or 16 years
she is currently not an outlier in
sentencing 70 percent of the federal
judges face the same dilemma and wonder
why congress has failed to act and when
it will act this is our fault pardon
partially it is senator to be honest
with you it is we have to upgrade these
guidelines and decide whether we're
going to stick with the supreme court
decision that they're not mandatory
senator feinstein thank you very much um
mr chairman and off he goes i would like
to come lindsay heading out
it's really something i mean just
tantrum after tantrum after tantrum
um
let's see what else we i don't wanna i
wanna skip over the charlie kirk thing
um
let's see what else we've got we already
did this
klobuchar we saw
um what other clips do we have
oh patrick leahy weighed in on the uh
temper tantrum from lindsay how do you
think today is going so far it was going
well until this last round of
questioning
i love that
it really got bad when uh lindsay got to
speak i love that it was it was going
well until now
that's an abrogation of everything
the senators stand for you had a
republican member who went way over the
time allotted to him
ignored the rules of the committee right
badgered the nominee
would not even let her answer the
questions
that
[Music]
i've never seen anything like that i've
been here 48 years
here we have a highly respected
and respectable nominee and to be
treated that way i don't know what the
motivation might be
what political motivation is
but to see the badgering of this woman
as she's trying to testify i thought was
outrageous absolutely and who could
not a single word out of place
from senator patrick leahy very very
much well said and just a vile behavior
by lindsay thanks to wayno and d4 for
the twitch prime subscriptions number
six and seven today i appreciate you
guys and welcome uh it's been stream
after stream and very very much
appreciate that
um
let's see
what else we've got here
um
i'm just going through my media list
here
in real time
lindsay with a message to the people
looking at explicit child sexual images
did it today
if you're listening to my voice today
and you're on a computer looking at
child pornography and you get caught i
hope you're in your sentences enhanced
because the the computer in the internet
is feeding the beast here right we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines i would actually say if people
are caught
reviewing explicit images of children
while listening to tapes of lindsey
graham
the machines should be taken into
custody
uh and maybe we should even consider
charges against lindsay i think all of
that should be on the table that's a
joke by the way guys okay everybody
relax everybody relax but certainly the
machines in question should be sued
that's for sure
uh
let's see what else we have here
don't care about corning right now
oh um so here's another example again of
where corn and i actually do want to
touch on this specific issue
cornyn tried grilling judge jackson
about viability of fetuses and as many
of you know her training is not in
obstetrics
what does viability mean when it comes
to an unborn child in your understanding
[Music]
senator i hesitate to speculate i
don't
i know that it is a point in time that
the court has identified in terms of
uh when
uh the standards that apply to
regulation of the right
justice brennan
at a later point in his career
on the supreme court admitted that
the viability line was an arbitrary
line
do you agree with i
agree with him
senator i'm not able to
comment on um
viability there's a a case see like this
is one of these things where if we all
got together in a room and by we i don't
mean people like john cornyn i just mean
people like
you know most of you in in my audience
and we would all get together and we
would say
of course this question of viability has
an arbitrary nature of course it does
often times we talk about
22 to 23 weeks is the absolute earliest
that a at that point i mean even
premature is an understatement but at 22
or 23 weeks
if everything goes perfectly you might
be able and i believe that this is still
accurate you might be able to see
a
a fetus survive
and then with every week beyond 23 weeks
the past the chances go up slightly and
then you have different standards for
when when is the heart formed versus
when can you detect we would all agree
with that okay and much the same way
if you set a speed limit at 35 miles per
hour
we would all agree there's no magic
about 35 on dry roads
80 percent of cars could go 45 but we're
going to set it to 35 because 20 of the
cars can't and then if it's rainy that
goes down and but but it's of course but
we all accept that you have to accept
that there is some arbitrariness to it
that doesn't make it so that abortion
should be illegal the problem is you
can't do it in a conversation with
someone like john cornyn because he's
just trying to sandbag you and set you
up
so she really has no choice
but to um
say listen i'm just not a biologist and
there's another question here as well
which is
for what purpose are we determining it
right if you say to these very
republicans who say oh
even at a week
we are talking about a person here and
then you go to them and you say okay
should the mom get the child tax credit
for a one week old fetus because if i
mean if if it's a person you should get
the tax credit right
they would almost certainly say no no no
well that's different
um
and if you were to say to them well
if you have a one week old fetus and
you're here illegally if it's a person
then really it's already a citizen right
because
of the law when they are born if it's a
person at one week it's a citizen at a
week in the fee they would say no no
well no that's different
so
all of these questions are always for
what purpose are we trying to determine
that
um
yeah anyway so uh
you she ends up with no you she really
has no choice but to just say i'm not a
biologist sorry you know and and it's
unfortunately there are real important
discussions that could be had about all
of these issues
you just can't really have them with
with people like john cornyn
thank you to margot cabot
and d4
for uh subscribing and gifting a
subscription those are numbers eight and
nine
um
let's see what else we have here
um
let's do one quick voicemail from
whitney hot off the presses
so um i was a little bit confused
because they were saying that um it
looks like the holocaust
um
and i really think that the class is a
middle eastern invasion
um number one because the person who
people who
um convinced hitler to
um leave the holocaust or
from the middle east did she say shitler
that was weird i don't know anyway okay
she seems confused here's stephen
crowder's coverage his clip about
yesterday's hearings was called
pedo-loving scotus nominee
can't explain why she's a woman
so that's one perspective
that's one perspective
oh god
uh
let's see here we did lindsay storming
off
here's just a little bit of like the
constant berating this was he was 10
minutes over his time was lindsay today
if she's confused about what happened
some people on the other side had an
accusation against judge cavanaugh that
during high school
he sexually assaulted somebody
and the rest is history that was known
to the people on the other side and
never revealed during the meetings they
had with judge cavanaugh it was
literally ambushed he was ambushed how
would you feel if we did that to you
senator i've appreciated the kindness
that each of you has shown me to
see me in
your offices to talk with me
about
my approach about my questions what if
it's during our 15-minute exchange it
was very pleasant you're very nice
person you have a lot to be proud of i
would never do that to you
if i had something why is he just
talking about other confirmation
hearings and also people who weren't
nominated information that sketchy at
best that somehow you've done something
wrong i promise you just from human
decency i would share it with you i
would not disclose it at the last minute
of the last day of the hearing and i've
already given it to a newspaper so the
whole country can read about it before
you ever said a word senator she's had
nothing to do with the caucus no but
asking her
about won't even happen how she may feel
about what y'all did y'all your time has
expired and i'm going to give her an
opportunity to finally complete an
answer
so
if i could
just answer the question
senator i don't have any comment on what
procedures
why won't she comment about what people
she doesn't know did to someone who
wasn't nominated
come on guys give me a break
um now now to be clear in some cases
lindsay's talking about people who
weren't nominated in some cases he's
talking about previous nominees neither
has anything to do with judge jackson
just nothing nothing nothing nothing
peter hamby dropping in a super chat and
says a haiku for you david
racing to prove points a critical
questionnaire
within right's theory thank you peter
for that beautiful poem
uh next super chat from pete david sir
if i cannot explain why i'm a man am i
even a man right if you can't explain
how an internal combustion engine works
is it really an internal combustion
engine
it's very questionable very very unclear
um
okay
let's look at a few other things here
uh let's see what else we've got so many
videos of lindsay storming off they're
at this point they're just they're
almost axiomatic
i already looked at this
[Music]
this may be it actually
for now
the uh explicit images thing
oh trump's reportedly judging a car show
um
at muralago
he uh recently has been djing
also
did he get a high and tight that's his
hair looks different strangely is that a
trump impersonator i guess i can't even
really tell
who knows it's it's kind of sad what's
been going on
um yeah i can't even do the uh
the lindsay stuff is just crazy it
really is bonkers
uh oh i guess he mentioned short george
soros i want to hear that did you know
they received large donations from the
arabella network and from george sources
open society foundation network george
sources i like that george source
um man these people are really really
crazy
really nuts
um
yeah we could say a lot a lot about this
triad rt
tucker and michael tracy but it's not
even worth it it's not even worth it's
not even worth getting involved
um
judge holly smeared katanji brown
jackson with a q a online let's see
brown jackson defending her sentencing
record just ahead the republican line of
attack republicans pointed to her
sentencing record in child pornography
cases and her work defending detainees
at guantanamo bay pushing back against
republicans who claim she's soft on
crime rejecting allegations she let
child porn offenders off the hook the
sentencing of people convicted of child
pornography was another contentious
issue on display as some republicans
charge that she is soft on crime pushing
back against gop attacks accusing her of
being lenient in sentencing child porn
offenders republicans voiced concerns
about her role as a public defender for
guantanamo bay detainees as well as her
sentencing record for child pornography
offenders questions from senator josh
hawley about sentencing for child
pornography republicans have tried to
paint jackson as soft on crime that as a
judge she's been lenient in sentencing
child pornography offenders senate
republicans have characterized judge
jackson as soft on crime and questioned
her past sentences in child pornography
cases republican senators tried to paint
her as being soft on crime anyway you
guys get it i think i think people
understand it um okay
uh papi asking any updates on ukraine
and russia using nuclear weapons they
have not used nuclear weapons at this
point that we are aware of
um
awesome point you raised about abortion
and questions regarding why fetuses are
not considered citizens really like
watching you and hearing what you have
to say keep it up david what a nice
message from lodmod i really appreciate
that
i really appreciate that
um
here's something this these are the
people that i would love to talk to
like some someone on youtube named kid
rengo just says that their comment is
pacman is reaching they've misspelled my
name which at this point it's like who
even you know that's that's that's a
guarantee what am i reaching about like
what it what exactly is this person
talking about it would be great to
actually speak to some of these people
and see what it is they're
like what are you even talking about you
know
um
[Music]
oh god we might have to ban debate boar
again i unbanned debate boar but we
might have to ban again it's it's just
very very annoying all right let's get
to a few more um voicemails here i do
want to make we have
1159 voicemails that we could listen to
and we're not going to do it
trump is very definitely not qualified
as for president a president does not
get foreign policy from kid rock with
the
classified information out on the table
you know we we covered the kid rock
story on today's podcast my bet is kid
rock is not the least qualified person
trump took advice from while he was
president
um
let's see what else i've got here
on the hearings if anything
hey david
this is dave in california
did you know
one of the female senators
that was questioning
judge jackson
yesterday
has a degree
in home
economics yes marcia blackburn has a
degree in home economics that's exactly
uh that's that is
that is accurate i i don't know that
there's too much for listen so this this
is one of these tough things because
we we don't just want lawyers on the
judiciary committee
so
it doesn't seem appropriate to say that
blackburn
can't question the judge
simply because she has a four-year
degree in homeek
at the same time blackburn was
completely unhinged now
for contrast correct me if i'm wrong
people in chat republican ben sasse also
is not a lawyer
but he was respectful and at least
seemed curious when he was asking her
questions and and was a completely
different sort of
circumstance
um so i don't you you can have or not
have a law degree and question a
potential supreme court justice in a way
that's respectful
uh and
substantive i i don't know i don't know
that i have too much more to say about
that
um
okay let's see what else
we have here
hey david um i'm a really big fan of
like
i left you about your message a couple
days ago
on your voicemail and like
i made some points
like i really wanted to be on the show
like
i'm a huge fan like
i might may have cussed a little bit
maybe that's the reason but like
i
i don't have access to anything but
youtube
so like if he didn't play my voice now
like i don't i didn't see it okay i
don't think i played your voicemail sir
yo pax total control 871 i know it's
been a while right
okay so your your communist agenda for
your i am not a communist
hey can anybody in the chat tell me
why do people keep calling in saying i'm
a communist even though i'm so obviously
not a communist can any can anybody tell
me
what why is it is it because i'm jewish
is it because i'm argentinian
is it because i'm progressive what is
the reason why why is there an obsession
with saying i'm a communist when it's so
obvious that i'm not
it's a problem in the water okay
nice yeah that's fair
they just call everybody a communist
okay that's fair
anyway let's listen to this scathing
critique clear
uh winter of severe will illness and
death that all fell flat on its face
your entire faith pandemic fell flat on
its face you never once uh yielded
anything that came close to pandemic
levels uh for two years you were fed
nothing more than recycled stock footage
okay and fear-mongering
proclamations
of what is either going on or what's
about to happen
uh none of which was followed up with
concrete proof
however today i'm calling you to
basically let you know that
your your fellow slithering jews are not
skulking away as uh so
30 seconds ago i said do they think i'm
a communist because i'm jewish
and it seems that that is indeed the
case uh wow
um
that so that is you know it's funny
because oftentimes i'll get messages
from people like david why are you even
bringing up that the person is
anti-semitic i don't even know
it was a genuine question is judaism
part of them thinking i'm a communist
and all of a sudden slithering jews it's
it's full on anti-semitism
and we will
block that number so this user who goes
by the name total control will never be
able to call again
um all right
ben says david parkman sir love the
content been watching since 2018. quick
question do you think you follow more
people on the left on twitter or on the
right your feed is mainly crazies
so here's the thing i don't follow any
all of those crazy messages i post to
twitter i don't follow any of those
people they follow me but i don't follow
them
uh
yeah
maria you're a communist because you
don't meet their retroplicant mold love
your work keep it up thank you maria i
very much appreciate that if you're just
joining us this is day three of supreme
court nominee katanji brown jackson's
confirmation hearings today each senator
gets 20 minutes of questions lindsay
went over by 10 minutes
lindsay took 30 minutes even though he
wasn't supposed to
go go figure
um the trajectory for today is that they
would be done around 7 p.m if they took
no more breaks
there will i'm guessing what they will
do is they won't do a dinner break
they'll probably take you know 20 or 30
minutes of breaks and be done around 7
30 or 8 o'clock that's my guess that's
my guess
if you're just joining us we are now
into our hold on 5 14
we are into the 20
listen to this number okay please listen
to this number
we are in the
we are now in
no okay we are in the 21st hour of live
streams in three days
23 21st hour of live streams in three
days
and i so appreciate everybody who's been
uh in the this is this is very very
important very very important and we are
we are watching it uh closely
and i want to thank everybody who has
gotten a twitch prime subscription hello
i want to thank everybody who has signed
up on our website and you can do that
right now at joinpacman.com the coupon
code is fix the court now i'm not
supposed to be promoting this this was
only supposed to be available yesterday
but it still works
you can also use the code way too long
for an even bigger discount because
these streams have been way too long and
i will thank everybody who uses either
of the coupon codes but in particular
people who use way too long
uh okay oh i already read that one
let's see if we can squeeze in a couple
more voicemails before
this resumes
i will step away for a bit when they
come back um working on tomorrow's
program and doing a lot of different
things
but uh well i i will be in and out
throughout
hi um
i'm just watching your little clip about
the trump is freaking out about your
rally
whatever and uh
you look sad
and i'm concerned
because i like you you're you're
adorable and you're so intelligent but
you just look sad and i hope you're okay
there's a reason
one of our coupon codes is sad trump
because everything trump related has has
become very very sad
thanks to z miller for the twitch prime
subscription z you're number 10 today i
appreciate that very very much
hi david this is good pastor i just want
you to know that i think a lot of your
show
and you speak the truth
and it's good that we have people like
you out there
thank you guys
that's my new favorite caller
i love the accent let me look up uh hold
on where is that area code from
that's louisville kentucky calling in
kathy
and
she has the show playing in the
background i don't know why when people
don't pause the show they call in and
you can hear the show playing in the
background
i just love that i love that let's
listen to that one once more
hi david this is
pastor i just want you to know that i
think a lot of your show
and you speak the truth
and it's good i can hear what i i'm
promoting the bonus show in the
background i can tell exactly what it is
that i'm um
that i'm that i'm promoting
hi david my name is nico meeker from
los angeles california
and i'm an avid watcher of you i
appreciate your show and your um input
um i think you add a lot to the
conversation and you do it in a really
eloquent way thank you so much wow i
like that as well a lot of positive
a lot of positive voicemails coming in
extremely rare
um
let's see what else we've got here oh
whitney called in again
so
um what i was thinking is like i don't
really know people so it's like how am i
supposed to know like where you came
from or what you look like and that kind
of stuff like i'm just to just accept
that like
jewish people look a certain way and
like
oh boy all right hey
is this david pumpkin
hey
am i calling the david pumpkin program
uh are you still gonna be talking about
masks and uh i can't think of the last
time i talked about masks
where is this colvin surge is it really
a surge favorite pumpkin
or are you just getting a memo to
promote it
anthony falchi is a criminal
um we haven't heard from eric from mass
for a little while but he did call in
yesterday
hey david it's eric from maps you should
put up another hit piece on the uh
laptop guy and say make fun of him how
he's blind like you are you know you
can't see and all that funny
you know what's funny to me
is how you're a nazi because you uh
jewish nazi yeah
have uh backed uh
brzezinski or whatever the [ __ ] his name
is
who's rozinski oh man eric eric from
mass is completely shot out of a cannon
today
very very strange stuff
extremely weaponized
uh
boy let me see if i i know we have
limited time that they're about to
resume here
but i want to get to a couple
of things
hey david pakman this is sam i won't
give you my last name because i'm a
former tier one operator for delta
um i was wondering what you think on the
idea of
having
some of these pod news places the
reputable ones
put out an alert on the september 18th
demonstrations that's supposed to take
place well i don't know anything about
that demonstration has anybody in the
chat heard about that september 18th
there's something happening
in illinois people are saying
i've not heard of that
that i'm not recording september 18th
that seems far i mean six months from
now
i don't know
i want to say thanks to marty mcfly
jen here
and buttsack for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 11 12 and 13. i
appreciate that
um let's see
if we can find something substantive hey
david pakman dave berkson here
hey i'm wondering why you're not giving
your opinion
on major league baseball allowing
ads on uniforms don't care about it
didn't hear about it that's why
uh just have no idea about it ads on
uniforms and baseball i don't know it's
been a long long time
uh
since i talked about uh baseball
you're using the lick with you
talk about granular details holy [ __ ]
now there was a time in my life where i
was okay with people getting that
academic
but given my advanced age and
considering the political climate we're
dealing in
do people really have
the kind of energy to devote to that
kind of analysis for talk show host who
is trying to reach the broadest number
of people possible do they really think
that grabbing your attention in that way
being that english is your second
language that that really [ __ ] makes
a difference
i could care less you mean you couldn't
care less you couldn't care less oh god
um
okay
jay harper says via super chat that guy
who called you david pumpkin sounds like
chuck grassley he did it was actually
troy york
big thank you to blueberry babe who has
just gifted a subscription on twitch
blueberry babe has to be getting up
there in the top gifters of all time
right let's see
somehow not that's weird that's weird
not even in the top 10 list i'm sure
you'll break into there soon i have been
very very strong donor for a while
uh okay
thank you very much
um see what else we've got hey david
it's juan here
so i'm
a man right i was born a man well
a child a little male child
we might call it but you were born a boy
oh
i have no issue with the whole
transgender this or that that doesn't
really bother me in any way but
what if i decided
to go into a woman's bathroom
with a wig on
they don't know my medical history they
don't know if i am or not transgender
wouldn't that be a problem
okay how many creeps would do that well
that's the whole point very few
very few and by the way you know more
and more places more and more places are
going into this setup where
it's just single bathrooms
so it just it's a non-issue and by the
way in much of europe i won't say all i
think it's less so in the scandinavian
countries but certainly in in i mean
listen
in uh
in spain
in portugal
in france
in italy
in brussels
for certain in estonia i'm now i'm
speaking with personal knowledge
most public bathrooms are
there's a sink area
and then they're singles
so
wear a wig
wear fake pubic hair wear whatever the
hell you want no one cares you're just
by yourself
okay
we're a pubic wig right i mean whatever
kind of wig you want to wear i don't
nobody cares
nobody cares and increasingly in the u.s
bathrooms are going in that direction as
well and it removes this as even being
an issue now sure you know you go to
places like uh i don't know
what's some big chain you go to buffalo
wild wings
and very often it's like this massive
palatial men's room and then separately
a massive palatial
women's room
uh okay but but that's the whole point
like
there's very few people looking to do
this
um
you think do you think most men
who are not transgender
think it's it's gonna go well to just
put a wig on and hang out in a women's
bathroom like it's just a it's absurd
it's absurd
um and by the way whether you're wearing
a wig or not
if you're behaving in a creepy way or
harassing people the police are going to
be called and it's not going to matter
what your gender identity is if you're
harassing people or or just hanging out
endlessly in the bathroom the police
will show up and be like what are you
doing here so it's a completely farcical
thing
let's listen to just a few more seconds
you can't say that it's illegal because
you're already saying that it's fine
yeah it's just this is very so this is
someone who either doesn't get out much
or uh i mean it's absurd
it's just completely completely absurd
thank you to the bedizzle
for the twitch
prime subscription your number
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines
and we will ban men
15 today number 15 today and i very much
appreciate that
um
okay
do i have anything else
interesting that last call was just so
infuriating
um
let's see
the older i get i realize how stupid
people are
isn't taurus
non-white
and he thinks he's going to join the
proud or he's joined the proud boys he's
supporting a racist ex-president grump
i mean come on be less stupid is who not
white who who did who did she say i
didn't understand that good people are
isn't taurus taurus
who's taurus does i don't understand
what that is
torres
hmm
okay
yeah i don't know
i don't know what's up with that
all right
[Music]
um
this is going to sound nuts
but
i was wondering if you could do or i
mean short shelf
thank you
church free will and all that yeah but i
was wondering if you would look into
church society's
influence on russia
because i found an interesting mistake
i don't understand how that like robot
voice thing happens it's a very strange
technical thing i don't know how it
happens but i i do like it
um thanks to ripash who is new member
number 16 today thank you thank you
thank you i appreciate that
uh very much um this is good we're
actually getting through a bunch of
different voicemails here this is
this is really excellent
so i was watching the news and
a lot of the french people were talking
about
wanting a
a putin macron so
lucian says been in a restaurant
bathroom in paris with a common sink
area a girl even told me my hair looks
nice as i was trying to arrange it
really scared me
yeah
yeah yeah the bathroom thing is just
it's so like i'm just bored by it
what are people doing you know when i
the last thing i'm thinking of when i go
places is like how much time can i spend
in the bathroom which bathroom can i go
to who might be in the bathroom what
sort of things might i be able to do in
there and could i bring laptops in and
just hang out in the bathroom and wear a
wig or not wear a wig or wear a dress or
whatever else it's just a weird thing to
even devote this much time to thinking
about bathrooms like i i
i kind of base my life out of around
spending as little time as possible in
public bathrooms and the idea that
everybody's just trying to figure out
like what are we doing elements of
bathrooms yeah it just doesn't it just
doesn't make any sense
none whatsoever
um
let's see if i have anything else here
for you
a lot of weird voicemails
hi david it's genie from melbourne
florida
i apologize i think this is the third
time i've called in a couple weeks
um three in a couple weeks is fine
jeannie i mean we have people calling
every hour sure how often did you check
this line but
i was just listening to
i think it's joy reid with the readout
i can't remember she's on msnbc or
folks breaking news breaking breaking
news former secretary of state madeleine
albright the first female secretary of
state has passed away at age 84
a very interesting woman cnn reporting
her death is confirmed in an email to
staff of the albright stonebridge group
she was a central figure in president
bill clinton's administration first
serving as u.s ambassador to the u.s
before becoming the nation's top
diplomat in his second term she
championed the expansion of nato pushed
for the alliance to intervene in the
balkans to stop genocide and ethnic
ethnic cleansing sought to reduce the
spread of nuclear weapons and championed
human rights and democracy across the
globe considered a neo-liberal
by many
um her politics aside
her secretary ship
extremely important and sort of
meaningful
um in the context of the
history of the united states hard to
deny that and we will have time
to
talk more about that but madeline
albright dead at 84 years old
we are standing by for the resumption of
day three of the confirmation hearings
of judge katanji brown jackson i want to
say thank you to an anonymous twitch
gifter who just gifted five
subscriptions putting us at 21
we have had no one sign up on the
website yet let's give away a free item
first person to sign up today at
joinpacman.com
at any price level gets a free item from
my online store
could be a twill hat could be a coffee
mug could be a t-shirt hoodie sweatshirt
whatever you want you can use the coupon
code fix the court
to save
fix the court because we must do it
and first yeah we'll kick it off first
person to sign up today gets a free item
we'll send it anywhere in the world
laudnat says or ladmot hey dave felt
like giving you 10 bucks to offset some
of the voicemail ridiculous
ridiculousness you're enduring right now
have a nice day dude thank you lot mod i
appreciate that very much um
let's see if we can squeeze in
maybe uh
one more
hey man uh just wondering about uh
adultery okay
christians
love to use leviticus 20
as
an excuse for their hatred for gays
yet they've never used leviticus 2010
which says the exact same thing about
adulterers
yeah they're they're complete and total
hypocrites
well i just wasted my
time that's a weird voicemail i just
wasted my time
here's the egg man
i now know the reason that my netflix
goes up a couple bucks every six months
is because of pat and you dave now i ask
you guys this how many
memberships to your show does lewis have
to buy
before you guys can afford your own
netflix membership
shalom oh okay yeah the eggman referring
to a bonus show story about how pat and
i are both still on our mommy's
netflix accounts that's a true story
that's an absolutely true story i want
to say thanks to comp lord for the
twitch prime subscription that is new
member number 22.
i also want to thank the first person to
sign up on my website today
getting herself
getting herself
a free item from the online store
it is anna pichurillo new member number
23 overall first on the website anna you
win a free item you can email info
davidpakman.com to collect on it also
want to say thank you to caleb w and
alex milly
or miley new members 24 and 25 today
thank you so so so much
um
very very uh flattered
by the support from all sorts of
different people here is dick durbin
waiting for the return of judge katanji
brown jackson we are almost ready to
resume
and uh let's see
should be just moments just moments
moments away
uh
david can you think of a coin
instead of saying during this war the
russians the russians the russians
uh
we didn't say germany we said germany
invaded during world war ii but it was
the nazis invasion
the nazis were invading
many russians don't agree so we're
grouping which brings rise to
discrimination so we need a coin of
phrase whatever with the political
ideology
the putin
trump war
we need to knew it get another phrase
besides the russians hmm
okay
okay all right well uh
i'll think about that
hey david what's up it's juan again
why do so many right wingers like
presidents and such
uh wear
blue suits and
red ties
why i don't know you you'd have to ask
them
hey david it's juan here again
do you know why i am registered
independent no
the reason is
i believe that being conservative or
liberal
seems to be
too risky
so this is someone who's confusing
political orientation and party
i am and i am independent meaning i'm
not a democrat and i'm not a republican
but i'm a progressive and unfortunately
we have such a a dearth of critical
thinking in our country
that juan is just confused i mean is it
you're independent because it's bad to
be liberal or conservative liberal and
conservative or political orientations
whereas independent relates to party
affiliation
and unfortunately juan with peace and
love and i know you call in all the time
like all all the time
um i would try to do like one phone call
that makes sense
this is the same guy who called in about
bathrooms exactly it's the same guy yeah
uh
that's what
that's what i would consider doing
hi david i'm wondering if since you were
born in south america
and you now live and work in north
america does that make you double
america oh my god we're gonna have to
end voicemails on that note that is a
bit too cringey for me to handle right
now
super chats continue coming in david sir
please figure out a way for supporters
to gift website memberships that would
be huge yeah you know i'm going to do
that so
i'm going to reach out to the developers
um
the tool
gift memberships i'm going to look into
that i'm going to look into that that's
that's a very it's a we really should do
it
but we're sort of limited by some of the
technical aspects
that
are in place
and so i'm going to try to make that
happen
i think it would be really great
all right um continuing to stand by here
for the resumption of the hearings let's
see if we have any other little short
clips to go through
um here is the cnn announcement of the
death of madeleine albright
we have some sad breaking news now
former secretary of state madeleine
albright has died at the age of 84.
she was the very first woman to hold
that position a strong diplomat uh known
to never mince words and and remembered
by many for those unique pins and
broaches that she would wear to send
subtle messages to yes she actually was
known for the now is it a broach or a
brooch i always i always wonder about
that
um
mike pillow announcing a new plan today
this live link up with these tech
technology people that you can actually
go and get it to individual states and
get injunctions to basically shut down
the machines to be used in the 2020
midterm election oh
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines elections and state
elections sir
yeah the 2022 that's correct steve and
in any elections it would be over uh
we're going to get preliminary
injunctions and it's with no machines
because they cannot do elections
accurately and they can and they can
accurately uh all right i'm going to
make a note of that that's probably
something
that i will talk about on tomorrow's
show let me just email that to myself
it's hard to tell who's crazier bannon
or pillow
it really is tough i actually am
currently torturing a toaster upstairs
and uh if it's the last thing i do
it's gonna tell me everything it knows
that you can be absolutely sure of
um let's see what else we've got here
a lot of lindsay stuff today for sure
many people focused on lindsay
um oh look at how stu oh wait a second
yeah trump look at how weird trump looks
today isn't that strange
i can't even figure out what's going on
something is something's different about
his appearance
weird
here's ted cruz
sitting and
being a vile person we were scheduled
for this to last until about 7pm but
they're already a half hour late coming
back so that would push us to 7 30.
and beyond that i mean who'd that's if
they take no additional breaks
i want to say thanks to el duque for the
twitch prime subscription you're number
26 today very much appreciate it
david is there any irony in evangelical
conservatives banning teaching about
race in school
when the bible deals heavily with the
plight of the jews of course
it's also um i don't know if we would
call it ironic or hypocritical they want
to ban books that have you know like a
sex scene
and yet like the bible's okay i mean
none of it makes sense you guys all know
that i know i don't have to tell you
it just makes it is a total and complete
hypocrisy
complete and utter hypocrisy i guess we
would say
unclear what the reason for the delay is
they were scheduled to be back 27
minutes ago and we we just don't know
anything about it
uh is there audio here
not everybody's even back yet we just
don't know what's going on yeah
chandler davis says i fear that if mike
pillow wins the class action lawsuit
against all machines that it will be
paid out in rupees i know yeah marjorie
taylor green's reference to the ruble
um
i share that concern chandler i think
that that's a very fair concern
i would be concerned about the exact
same thing
[Music]
hey david this is uh
from kuwait middle east and uh have a
following you have a great following and
i love your show
i love what you stand for and hopefully
we'll have more content on twitch
partners
have a good day right no we're keeping
it going we're absolutely keeping it
going
hi uh david paglin sir this is dave
murphy from ohio i just wanted to say
that you are
doing an excellent job sir please keep
up the good work we need more voices
like you speak uh speaking the truth
uh when it comes to
what's really going on in the media and
then in this country so i i appreciate
it just keep it up thank you very much i
really appreciate that
hi david it's andrew and i lived in
copenhagen in denmark for a period of
time and i've played and have
many friends in norway yeah
it's just a bathroom
in a cafe or a bar
nobody cares yeah
there's the bathroom use it
nice
i like that and then lastly a new
whitney voicemail hot off the presses
this one's only five minutes old
but really after like looking at stuff
for a while i think what it really comes
down to over there in russia is that
it's like somebody who's not here
adhering to their regulations
but that looks like them so it's like
well they're going to be guilty for
whatever mistakes that you make right a
bay photo saying i find the lack of
questioning on elections by republicans
kind of mysterious especially since
trump was hell-bent on using the courts
to rig the vote no here's what's going
on with that that's a good point
trump was desperate for the supreme
court to take care of all the fraud and
stuff like that the reason republicans
aren't asking anything about it is
because they know that it would not pull
well and it would make them look really
really bad because they know that most
americans don't believe the election was
stolen and they would see using the
court
as a way to steal the election as a bad
thing that's why
so yes about half of republicans believe
the election was stolen
but most americans don't republicans
know that it's a losing issue and that's
why they're not asking judge katanji
brown jackson about it it's just it's a
loser
it's a it's an absolute and total loser
of an issue
would do nothing good for them
it looks like we're maybe close to the
resumption of the hearing uh it's very
strange what's going on there there was
such urgency to be done soon
and at the same time they're half an
hour late coming back uh we hope it's
not because someone's not feeling well
or anything like that you know
oh there she is judge katanji brown
jackson returning followed by her
husband who's done a great job carrying
her uh mug
and we don't know what is in there we
don't know if it's water some kind of
flavored water or
hydrogenated water distilled water could
be tea coffee coke
anything we really don't know what it is
but he's been doing a really great job
carrying it
back judge
as you can see things uh
get off the rails here when they decide
they have a floor vote we'll do our best
to oh stick with the program and finish
this so that's the explanation proper
way
the next step is senator cruz of texas
oh god no no no no chairman judge good
afternoon good afternoon senator
under article 3 of the constitution uh
federal courts have jurisdiction over
only cases and controversies oh no uh
which means under the constitution it
has to be an actual dispute that federal
courts cannot simply
issue advisory opinions on on a question
they may have a view on
and one component of article 3
jurisdiction is the requirement of
standing that in order for a plaintiff
to have standing to bring a case
that that plaintiff at least generally
speaking must have a real and concrete
injury is is is that right
that is
correct um
so for example uh that that means that
that
even if i might have a disagreement with
some particular policy or some
particular law that that i can't bring a
case unless i am personally aggrieved by
that policy or that law
uh so for example your and my alma mater
harvard
uh is currently being sued for its
explicit and in my view egregious policy
of discriminating against asian
americans
even though i think that policy is
egregious
i as an individual plaintiff could not
bring a lawsuit challenging it because i
am not asian-american is that right
if you brought a lawsuit um the court
would have to evaluate whether you had
an actual injury in order to be able to
determine whether it had subject matter
jurisdiction to hear the suit but but if
i'm not in the class being discriminated
against then i don't have the ability to
bring the lawsuit is that right
i think you'd have to have an actual
injury certainly people i think who are
in the class could claim that they had
an injury for that purpose
so now you're you're on the board of
overseers of harvard if you're confirmed
do you intend to recuse from this
lawsuit
that is my plan senator okay um we
discussed yesterday how the standard for
race discrimination was strict scrutiny
uh the court has laid out a a different
standard for gender discrimination um
what is the constitutional standard that
applies to gender discrimination
gender discrimination
the court has held
intermediate scrutiny applies which is
that the government has to have uh an
important interest
and um
[Music]
the tailoring doesn't have to be as
narrow right
so yesterday uh under under questioning
from senator blackburn
uh you told her that that you couldn't
define
what a woman is
uh that you were not a biologist which
which i think you're the the only
supreme court nominee in history who's
been unable to answer
the question what is a woman
let me ask have they all been asked that
judge
how would you determine if a plaintiff
had
article 3 standing
to challenge a gender-based rule
regulation policy
without being able to determine what a
woman was
so senator i know that i'm a woman i
know that
you're not senator blackburn is a woman
and the woman who i
admire most in the world is in the room
today my mother
um it sounded as though well but the
question was let me ask under the modern
idiot
let her answer if
i decide right now that that i'm a woman
um
then
apparently i'm a woman does that mean
that i would have article 3 standing to
challenge a gender-based restriction
senator to the extent that you are
asking me about
who has the ability to bring lawsuits
based on gender those kinds of issues
are working their way through the courts
and i'm not able to comment on them okay
if if i can
change my gender if i can be a woman and
then an hour later if i decide i'm not a
woman anymore i guess i would lose
article 3 standing
tell me does that same principle apply
to other protected characteristics for
example i'm i'm an hispanic man could
could i decide i was an asian man would
i have the ability to be an asian man
and challenge harvard's oh my god i made
that decision oh my god
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and
um i'm asking you how you would assess
standing if i if i came in and said i
have decided eyes on the case he's an
asian man depends on the people
standing the way i assess other legal
issues which is to
listen to the arguments made by the
parties right consider the relevant
precedents uh and
the constitutional principles involved
determination perfect answer okay let's
go back to your favorite topic of this
hearing
uh which is the criminal law cases you
had as a district judge and in
particular the cases involving child
pornography
now that's his favorite the democratic
side of the diocese and also in the
press
have suggested that that the criticism
that has been raised uh has been somehow
cherry-picked that it's only some
specific examples so so i'm going to
give you an opportunity
to discuss each and every case you've
had
because looking at your cases and i've
now examined all of the child porn cases
you've had as a federal district judge
there is a very consistent pattern
so let's start and by the way i'm
excluding the cases so senator durbin
and senator coons focused on
the nickerson case the fife case the
nguyen case in the hilly case
i'm excluding those because those are
not child porn cases those are actual
sexual assault of a child which is
markedly different and i will concede
when you're dealing with sexual assault
you have been willing to impose stricter
penalties so let's
focus on actual child pornography cases
and let's go through each of them
because if it's right that we're
cherry-picking then you should be able
to to explain quite powerfully
now your justification is that you're
following the statute and as you know 18
usc section
3553
lays out the factors that that as a
district judge
you had to consider in sentencing and
let's start with the hess case united
states versus hess
now in that case a man sent six pictures
a pre of a prepubescent girl that he
claimed was his daughter
to an undercover law enforcement officer
listen to this
officers found over 600 images
of child pornography
including images of sexual acts being
performed on pre-pubescent children
the defendant pled guilty and i believe
in all of these cases the defendant pled
guilty so there's no question about
guilt they came in and pled guilty in
your courtroom
the charge carried a mandatory minimum
sentence of five years and a mandatory
maximum sentence of 20 years
the sentencing guidelines recommended
151 to 188 months sentence
the government as part of a plea a deal
agreed to argue for 60 months but didn't
agree that that would be the sentence
simply that they would advocate it
and you in turn
sentenced hess to
60 months so
under the terms of the statute why did
you choose to sentence tests to the
absolute lowest possible sentence you
were allowed to sentence under law
thank you senator i have
spoken at length throughout this hearing
about these cases i've said
what i'm going to say which is
i've taken every case seriously these
are could you say about this horrible
asking you specifically about test case
i've taken every case seriously so
you're not going to answer that these
are very horrible crimes as was that one
and as a mother
having to look at these pictures having
to follow
congress's directive
having to listen to recommendations like
the government in that case which
argued for 60 months
i
imposed the sentence
that i believed
was the sentence
that was required by law so i believe
you and i've actually i've read your
sentencing hearing in each one of these
cases for which we have transcripts and
there's several of which we don't have
transcripts
so in each of these cases you read from
the same script so in each of these
cases you say that the distribution of
child pornography is an extremely
serious federal crime
and you point out that the crime
involves people who are taking pictures
and videos of real children while the
children are being sexually abused
in hess you pointed out that he had
hundreds hundreds of images of children
in sexually compromised position
some of them and engaged in satan
masochistic acts all of this i'm reading
from you at on the bench
and most importantly the children in
these
pictures are not knowing and willing
participants in the degrading conduct
that was being depicted they were being
forced forced by someone off screen to
commit unspeakable acts of sexual
violence for the pleasure of the people
filming them
and for the gratification of people
everywhere and what concerns me is that
many of those people have absolutely no
shred of empathy
for what that conduct does for the
children who were being abused in this
way and you read this script in every
one of these cases so you talk about
that these are terrible terrible crimes
um
but you also and and in hess you said
i have to say that what i found
particularly disturbing about your
offense
was that quote you apparently concocted
a story about having photographed your
own daughter who you purportedly were
willing to take pictures of to trade
with other people
i know from your comments and from those
who know you that you are unlikely to
ever harm a child which i find
remarkable that you've got a child
predator in your court who says i'm
unlikely to harm a child and you say
well you told me that so so clearly
you're unlikely but you say but in the
context of the crime
you represented that you would
that in and of itself is astonishing so
you talk about it as astonishing
you nonetheless sentenced him to the
very lowest possible sentence allowed
under law and what's striking
is in these cases and half of them in
five
you sentence the defendant to the
absolute lowest sentence under law
let's look at another case let's look at
united states versus chasin
now chasin is a particularly
nasty case
in chasing the defendant was accused
accessed a drop box that contained 35
videos and 13 partially downloaded files
of prepubescent
minor females engaging in sexually
explicit conduct
uh at least three of the instances of
prepubescent female children were
engaged in sexual activity with adult
men
is this the same thing as yesterday
included the sexual abuse of children
including those as young as toddlers and
several of these cases that you had
involved the sexual abuse of toddlers
which is truly horrifying
in this instance chasin pleaded guilty
the guidelines recommended a sentence of
78 to 97 months
the prosecution argued that should be
what the sentence was
and you sentenced chasin to just 28
months
why did you sentence someone who had
child pornography of toddlers being
sexually abused
to 28 months 64 below what the
prosecutors asked for
thank you senator
you've picked out um i don't know seven
eight cases i've sentenced more than a
hundred people but not to child
pornography
in every case senator i look at
the evidence i look at the
recommendations of not just the
government because my duty as a judge
is to consider all of the arguments that
are made in a case
i look at the evidence
i talk to the defendants about
the harms that they have
engaged in
many of these defendants are people who
um okay judge with respect you're not
answering my question you're right you
talk to them about the harms let me read
you again from what you said at the
bench
you said in this someone should ask for
her to be allowed to complete answers
and any of the other senators could ask
for that received a below guidelines
sentence on the basis of a downward
variance as opposed to a departure
the average sentences ranged from 84 to
92 months so that's what you lay out as
the average
our democratic colleagues say well
other federal judges sentence below
the guidelines that is true a number of
federal judges do
our democratic colleagues have not
pointed to a single federal judge in the
country who 100 percent of the time
sentences
child porn defendants to markedly below
what the prosecution has recommended
unless you have a mandatory minimum and
no ability to do so
in this case you say
comparable defendants are sentenced to
84 to 92 months
sentencing guidelines by statute require
you to have similarly situated
defendants sentenced to similar
sentences but you don't sentence chase
into 84 to 92 months you sentenced him
to 28 months why senator i've said what
i'm going to say about these cases no
one case
can stand in for a judge's entire record
okay but i'm discussing everything
if you're not going to explain it
senator would you please let her there
you go no not if she's not gonna answer
myself you're just going to give a
speech
and and and you you are not taking my
time if you want a filibuster you're
you're welcome to do so but don't at
least give you an opportunity to speak
and you should give her an opportunity
to respond if she wants to answer the
question i asked her why she's allowed
her to answer i asked her why she
sentenced chase into 28 months when
comparable defendants in her own words
were sentenced to substantially higher
and she said she's not going to answer
did you i mean i would welcome your
answer senator i didn't say i'm not
going to answer okay i said my answer is
facts in this case chasing why did you
sentence him to just 28 months senator
you're looking at the record i don't
have the record here what i will say is
that in every case
i looked at the recommendations of not
only the government but also the
probation office
the defendant
the record
the evidence i took into account the
seriousness of the offense
and by the way you know one of the
striking things in chasing the
prosecutor comes in front of you
and says this is the prosecutor's
argument at this point and the
prosecutor says
i understand from my experience before
your honor
your honors objection policy objections
to the to the 2g 2.2 sentencing
guidelines and he goes on to say however
in this case in particular the
four-point specific offense
characteristic
is justified because it contains
sato-masochistic
images
of infants
and toddlers
i'm trying to understand how you see
someone that possesses images of infants
and toddlers
being sexually violated and you sentence
them to 64 percent below what the
prosecutors asking for they still got
years in prison i mean it's just this
this is just a weird line i don't know
cern that the guidelines are too high
you don't provide a justification as
required by statute
so i'm asking you to take the
opportunity to explain to this committee
and the american people why in a hundred
percent of the cases
you have people with vile crimes and you
have language saying they're vile crimes
but then you sentence them to very very
low sentences and and why do you
consistently 100 percent of the time
choose to do that
senator no one case can stand in for a
judge's entire sentencing record
i've sentenced more than 100 people you
have eight or nine cases
in that chart kate judge you said that
before the these are the eight or nine
child porn cases i will say to correct
the record i'll just say to the judge
there's no point in responding he's
going to interrupt thanks look i
appreciate the chairman trying to
filibuster and if you don't like your
witnesses answers you're welcome to
provide your own
she is declining to answer the question
and and chairman durbin if you want to
join her on this on the on the bench you
can
but chairman durbin uh my job is nation
durban i'm not interrupting your
questioning i'm asking you to give her a
chance to answer but she's consistently
said she's not going to answer i want to
clarify for the record by the way the
case i was discussing was cooper and not
chasen
uh but
chasen is
[Music]
uh the case that i was reading from your
transcript was cooper but chasen all
right let's get to chase and i pulled
the wrong tab
uh chasing is equally horrifying and you
say in chase and that's something
senator graham asked you
so the guidelines lay out different
enhancements and and you say repeatedly
and this is true in all your cases you
say you disagree with the guidelines you
think they're wrong
and the two guidelines you disagree with
is one there's an enhancement for use of
a computer and you say the world has
changed now all of these are on a
computer and i understand that i don't
agree with you but i understand that
that is a
understandable thing to say but the
second thing you say over and over again
is there's an enhancement for the number
of images
and you say repeatedly for example in in
chasing you say whatever the state of
the law and technology at the time of
the guidelines were first adapted
neither the use of the computer
nor the number of images
are especially aggravating factors today
now i find that bizarre and you say it
in every case you say the number of
images it's not an aggravating factor it
doesn't matter and you won't apply the
enhancement
do you really believe that that a
predator that has hundreds or thousands
of images
of hundreds or thousands of children
being sexually violated
has not committed an offense that that
is more serious than someone that has a
single picture of a single child a
single picture of a single child is
horrifying but hundreds of children that
have been violated do you really believe
that is not a moral i mean it's
interesting because like okay assuming
that none of them are pictures produced
by the defendant
i think there's a difference between one
and a thousand pictures but is there a
difference between two and twelve i i
just don't know i mean it's it's an
interesting question an enhancement just
not to the degree of the guidelines
you're right it's a it's a five-point
enhancement under the guidelines you
provide two yes so not zero
suggestions
are you suggesting the number of images
doesn't matter cause you say it in court
over and over again that the number of
images doesn't reflect that it's a more
serious crime do you really believe that
senator
as i said to
senator graham
the court is taking into account a
number of circumstances the commission
has done a report about the operation of
the guidelines which enhancements
actually reflect
uh different levels of culpability so
let me add let me ask you this judge
you've said the purpose of sentencing is
to distinguish and distinguish between
crimes that are not as serious
from from truly egregious crimes is is
that right no senator so what is the
purpose of sentencing if it's not to
distinguish from
less serious crimes from truly egregious
crimes it is to assign proportional
punishment it is to do justice in cases
where you have defendants who are
convicted of the same conduct but have
different differing levels of
culpability well i will point out
that you have a pattern it doesn't
matter how egregious the case is senator
hawley talked about the hawkins case
where you had an 18 year old with
pictures of boys as young as eight being
sexually assaulted and raped and you
sentenced him to just three months in
jail
and i will point out the stewart case
the last one on this list because we're
running out of time thank god the
stewart case you describe
that he had over 6
700 images and videos so that's a lot
six thousand seven hundred that's a lot
of kids being sexually assaulted
you have taken over a minute of my time
mr chairman
so
you've been given extra time you usually
ask for it you're giving it okay
i i know you want to interrupt i know
you don't like just trying to play by
the rules i i know you like to interrupt
but you've consumed a substantial
question of my time of my questioning
and i'm the questions are actually done
and you can if you want to testify
you're welcome to senator judge you play
with the same rules
in the stewart case shut his mic
you said from the bench she shouldn't
even answer thus although this is not
necessarily an atypical case your child
pornography possession crime
was egregious in the court's view okay
so this is a bad one if you're actually
sentencing defendants you said this was
egregious what did you set in stuart for
the guidelines said 97 121 months
prosecutor said 97 months you said it's
agreed just six thousand seven hundred
images
you come in with fifty seven i'm as
expected why senators
in the stewart case do you wanna address
that because you're claiming it's
cherry-picking in fact you're welcome to
explain any of these cases but let's
turban's got to take control
did you sentence him for half the amount
you're not recognized senator senator
you don't want her to answer that
question the time's up
mr chairman she may answer you wouldn't
allow her why she said in stewart
i'm senator by two minutes why she said
because you've interrupted me for two
minutes mr chairman will you allow her
to answer the question or do you not
want the american people to hear
why with someone she described it he
doesn't let her answer so what does it
matter senator where you get a little
bit chairman durbin will you allow her
to answer the question you want to allow
her name i i i will happily allow her to
the question is why thank you senator
stewart an egregious child pornography
possessor can't they
requested by the prosecutor please
senator
will you allow her to answer the
question chairman durbin senator coons
why are you not allowing her
on another side what a loser i've not
allowed her to answer the question i'm
not asking another question but allow
her to answer the question chairman
durbin thank you chairman why do you not
want the american people to know what
happened in the store case or any of
these cases chairman durbin i've never
seen
the chairman refuse to allow a witness
to answer a question
you can bang it as loud as you want i
can just tell you at some point you have
to follow the rules okay will you let
her answer the question you've you've
been interrupting and by the way with
senator graham it went ten minutes over
you've taken a big chunk of the time
will you allow her to escort him out
question
you've given her why are you afraid of
her she's welcome to answer it right now
will you let her
senator coons will you let so no you
don't want her to answer the question
senator coombs will you let her answer
the question
chairman durbin
apparently we're very afraid of the
american people hearing the answer to
that question here in the senate in this
committee today oh god middle of a
policy fight
it's my understanding that across this
nation
more than 70 percent of district court
judges who impose sentences in cases
such as the ones that have been so
vigorously debated here
depart downwards from the sentencing
guidelines from the requests of the
prosecutors and as you've explained
repeatedly and in detail that's because
a sentencing judge is required to weigh
a whole series of factors
how many opinions have you written all
right everybody i'm going to do a little
work on tomorrow's show and we're going
to keep going should go until about 7 8
pm eastern tonight
and in how many cases have you imposed
sentences
as a federal judge more than 100 cases
and across all of those we've just heard
very forcefully assertions made about
you and your character and your
capabilities your background narrowing
in on just a few
and i would simply put for those who are
watching and trying to understand what
all of this is about
that in an attempt to distract from
your broad support your deep record your
outstanding intellectual and legal
credentials
that we are taking what is a policy
dispute that should be decided by
members of the senate
if we want to change the sentencing
guidelines to make them mandatory rather
than advisory if we want to change the
structure within which a federal judge
imposes sentences we could do that
but to demand that you be held
accountable for this practice that is
nationwide and is years old
i view as an unfair misrepresentation of
your record
so if i could
let's go to something that you did as
the vice chair of the sentencing
commission an important vote that you
took in 2014
because in my view it shows how
fundamentally misguided are the attacks
that try to characterize you as someone
who at all costs will do what you can to
help criminal defendants
let me just lay out the context for a
moment
in 2010 congress
enacting a policy choice unanimously
passed the fair sentencing act a bill
that reduced the disparity in sentences
between
crack cocaine and powdered cocaine from
101 to 18 to 1. and the sentencing
commission unanimously concluded this
law meant those currently in prison on
crack offenses could seek to shorten
their sentences
four years later the commission further
concluded that individuals who provided
substantial assistance to the government
people who cooperated who helped out the
prosecution could use this law to
shorten their sentence retroactively
beyond any break they might have gotten
for their cooperation
but you disagreed
in your public remarks at the time you
explained that although given your prior
service as a federal public defender it
might seem logical you'd support this
direction you could not do so
because you concluded it was manifestly
inconsistent with the law
and would create unfair disparities
between those previously sentenced
cooperators in those sentences today
essentially if i understand your view
it was that the sentence of a cooperator
shouldn't be understood to be based on
the sentencing ranges modified by the
fair sentencing act but was best
understood as a fixed discount of the
mandatory minimum that a fair sentencing
act had not changed i know this is
technical
but i just wanted to make sure i'm
characterizing this correctly before
reaching a conclusion um do i understand
the context correctly in which you made
this decision
yes senator perfectly it it was
debate among the commission one of the
very few
in which we couldn't reach agreement uh
about
uh the retroactive application of the
fair sentencing act reduction
and so just to finish the framing the
sentencing commission which often
decides things unanimously was sharply
divided and here's who was on each side
you voted to deny relief to cooperators
to deny them a pathway towards reducing
their prison sentences and you were
joined by two conservatives well known
to us judge william pryor uh and now
judge dabney friedrich
um and the three of you were outvoted
by four commissioners which included
judge inohosa an individual nominated by
president reagan and described as a
hard-nosed no-nonsense judicial
conservative who was on the other side
of the argument from you
so you've got four commissioners
including an outstanding conservative
reagan nominee
and they thought the law could be
interpreted to give
a break on sentencing
and you were on the other side of that
argument
if as someone
has tried to paint you
you simply were determined to give every
break you could to criminal defendants
all you had to do was join the majority
and this would have passed but that's
not what you did
help me understand why not
thank you senator um
as you say this is a sort of technical
kind of in the weeds
discussion but the
top line is that
when i looked at the issues and i looked
at the law it was my opinion
that
the law did not provide for
the further reduction
that was being considered
so across an incredibly broad range of
sentences you've had to impose in cases
on which you've had to opine
i'm picking this one in part because
it's not getting any attention in this
confirmation process
but for folks who'd like some insight
into how you make decisions and how you
explain those decisions
there's a video it's publicly available
of your april 2014 of the public meeting
of the sentencing commission where you
laid out your position so i encourage
folks to just watch that
and they'll see a jurist who understands
that her commitment above all
is to determine what the law requires
and then follow it
in my view that's an individual who
belongs on the supreme court
by the way your position that the law
required that there not be further
breaks given in this context ultimately
won the day
my colleague from new jersey made a
point of mentioning a relevant case
united states versus booker yesterday i
have to say that in this case it was
decided in coons versus united states
with a k not a c
look we all have our judicial record for
which we work
um
but the supreme court ruled for exactly
the same reasons you did in this
argument that was made public so i i
just think your honor this is an example
of you
looking hard at the law
making a tough decision
ultimately being vindicated in that
decision
but taking a position
that is not
the caricature that's been proffered by
some of you
yesterday i i ran through a number of
the the letters and statements um that
debunked some of the
attacks that have been levied based on a
handful of sentencing decisions there
was the national review piece by a
conservative former prosecutor who calls
out the smear on your sentencing
practices in cases involving child
pornography the statement by the
fraternal order of police and the
international association of chiefs of
police endorsing your even-handed and
judicious approach to the law the
glowing letter from 24 prominent
conservative attorneys and the
resounding recommendation we heard in
person from judge griffith
um there's also been received here a
letter from a number of retired federal
judges including two republican nominees
rejecting this mischaracterization of
your sentencing record as i've said this
is a policy dispute that we should be
deciding not an appropriate basis on
which to mischaracterize your record or
your character we have letters from the
national coalition of domestic violence
in addition to these law enforcement
leaders from survivors advocates crime
victims
the breadth of your support from the
very communities my colleagues have
suggested you're making less safe
shows just how off-base these attacks
are
and in my view as a testament to your
qualities and qualifications so
we all agree all of us
that it's critical to protect our
children and prevent the kinds of
heinous crimes we've heard
about in some detail earlier today it's
why i'm introducing a bipartisan
reauthorization of the victims of child
abuse act something that we could act on
as a committee to do our job which is
set policy and pass laws
but i also frankly think we need to be
mindful
that we are asking of you
to get engaged in that policy dispute in
front of this committee which is not the
role of a judge something you well
understand
let me turn if i could to another reason
i think you're deeply qualified and that
you will bring something important to
the supreme court
brian stevenson one of america's leading
civil rights lawyers and
by happy coincidence a delaware native
um has spoken about how achieving
justice requires being proximate to the
people most impacted by the criminal
justice system and you've done that
as a public defender you've represented
individuals in the criminal justice
system
as a district court judge you have
looked individuals in the eye and told
them that for their crimes against
society they will spend years or decades
in prison
you have met with
fought for and advocated for victims
you've also studied the big picture
as an effective and engaged member of
the sentencing commission you've poured
over data reviewed thousands of letters
and thought hard about the appropriate
national approach to just punishment in
a more policy oriented role
you've also thought about the big
picture as a judge when considering the
precedent that your opinions set
i'd be interested briefly in how your
experience on the sentencing commission
shaped your approach as a district court
judge and how the interplay of all these
factors might shape or contribute to
your decisions as a supreme court
justice
thank you senator um
one of the things district judges
sentencing judges often say
when asked about
the task is that
sentencing is the hardest thing
that a judge has to do and it's in part
for the reasons that you
have articulated
that
it's one thing
to
understand the law to read it in a book
it's one thing to look at data in
numbers and
[Music]
and and make policy based on that it's
quite another
to have someone
in the courtroom whether as a victim of
crime or a defendant who's
perpetrated a crime
and have to decide
how to proceed and pronounce
sentence on that individual
the work that i did on the sentencing
commission which was prior to my
becoming a district judge
i think enabled me
to understand
unwarranted sentencing disparities
to understand some of the policy reasons
behind the guidelines and to
make the kinds of evaluations that the
law now requires since the guidelines
are no longer mandatory and i feel felt
um
i felt
better in a sense about
the task of calculating the guidelines
which is what courts have to do at the
beginning of a sentence they can be a
little complex
and having been on the sentencing
commission i think that helped and some
of these cases do make their way
to the supreme court so
so i think that i am prepared
to handle
um the cases that involve
sentencing um that that do go to the
court in preparing for this confirmation
i went back and read a lecture you gave
but it was later published in the
harvard law review
um about the balance the challenge of
sentencing about that moment i i had the
joy the blessing of clerking for a judge
on the third circuit i
my legal skills and talents did not
allow me the opportunity to clerk for
the supreme court as you did but and
also the district court and also the
circuit court uh but i clerked for a
judge who i first met when she was a
district court judge and imposing a
sentence
on on someone who was a crack dealer and
she did a remarkable job of speaking to
the victims speaking to the community
speaking to the prosecutor and the
defense attorney and then speaking
directly to the defendant and imposing a
very long sentence
and as i got to know her later i
recognized that you know as a member of
our community and as someone who saw the
importance of that moment that public
moment of helping the defendant
understand what they'd done so that they
might somehow change but also helping
the victims understand what had happened
that she took that very seriously
incredibly seriously
in the harvard law review publication of
your remarks you said that you're
persuaded by the theories of punishment
that except all human beings are
responsible moral agents and you view
punishment as a necessary consequence of
the defendant's decision to engage in
criminal behavior
you also went on to say that the
challenge is balancing the
acknowledgement all of us are more than
just the worst thing we've ever done but
there is a need to ensure the defendant
is adequately
addressed and punished
what i think you say in that lecture
what you've shown across the arc of your
public service
reveals someone who understands the
appropriate need for punishment in our
society but who is also striving to
follow the balance of recommendations
guidelines statute and the context and
facts
and i trust that as
members of this committee and the senate
as a whole and the general public
take the time which they should do
to give a fair reading
to the whole scope and arc and reach of
your service that they'll see you as
someone
who cares deeply about our constitution
and the rights that make us free as you
said in your opening statement
your career in the law your service on
the bench your thoughtful responses to
questions put to you the way you've
maintained your composure all impressed
me
as i mentioned
um i i don't think labels um such as a
judicial philosophy are always that
meaningful or dispositive
i think in your case a deep admiration
for the constitution and an
understanding that the role of a judge
is a limited one are critical
and qualifying
you opened yesterday by referencing how
your parents were educated in racially
segregated schools in florida
but how you
just one generation later were raised in
integrated schools and had far greater
opportunities to put your evident
god-given talents to work and service to
our nation
you cited this one generation change as
an example of the greatness of america
of course the supreme court played a
central role
in more correctly interpreting the
constitution and applying it in a manner
that allowed this reversal of unjust law
to occur
i think the experiences of your own
family and your connection to the
experiences of trailblazers who came
before you on whose shoulders you stand
has meaningfully shaped what kind of a
justice you will be
i think you know in your bones how
important our constitution and the rule
of law is
and i think as someone who served on the
sentencing commission a public defender
and the trial court appellate court
judge
you have the ability to see across the
whole scope and reach of how the law
impacts families communities and our
nation
last in some ways i think
most importantly i've learned that as a
person and a judge you have humility
judge griffith who came before this
committee to introduce you and scores of
others we've heard from i've just
referenced have lauded your practice of
judicial restraint
and you've said a core component of your
philosophies your understanding that the
judge's role is a limited one
well i think restraint is a core part of
your approach to decision making partly
because
you are a judge who is humble enough to
know that the constitution and the laws
passed by congress say what the law is
the judge has a limited role in deciding
questions of law based on facts
presented
penn law professor lisa fairfax your
other introducer your dear friend
explained that since college at harvard
and then through law school you've been
a mentor and a role model she praised
her warmth and intelligence your
devotion to friends and family but she
also mentioned your humility
she knew you were honored and humbled by
the significance of this moment not what
it means for you but what it means for
our nation
i remember thinking about this on monday
and i had a chance to talk to your
brother kitaj
um and he mentioned that he knew you
were destined for this moment your whole
life
i am sure he would say you've been
exceptional since you were student body
president at palmetto high school
i suspect your wonderful family
upbringing is partly responsible for
this facet of your character
i suspect your faith has played a role
in sustaining you as mine does and so
does many others in this room
i've often found instruction and comfort
in the verse what does the lord require
of you but to do justice
love mercy
and walk humbly with your gut
i'm not going to ask you to reflect on
that verse your honor but i i wouldn't
be surprised if it's one of your
favorites that sustains you
um let me close by returning to what
judge griffith said
uh when he told us in his heartfelt
introduction of you on monday
and something you've also shown in the
uh hours uh you've been grilled by this
body
he had already written a letter to this
committee delivering his endorsement he
took the extra step to
then amplify it in person
and he did so because of confidence in
you and because he was delivering a
message to us as a committee
that supreme court confirmations should
be more than just exercises and partisan
tribalism
he said there should be nothing unusual
about a judge who just happened to be
appointed by a republican president and
who holds conservative legal views
coming forward to support a nominee
with your impeccable qualifications and
character
especially a nominee whose legal
opinions whose actions and decisions as
a judge he was in a position to review
for years given that you were a district
court judge and he was a circuit court
judge
look our confirmation hearings for
justices have sadly been devolving over
many years
into longer and longer exercises of
partisan politics punctuated by just
brief glimpses and occasional thoughtful
examinations of a nominee's judicial
decision making and views on the
constitution which should properly be
our main focus
i have to believe this sad state of
affairs troubles my colleagues of both
sides and all who watch this
but as i reflect on these hearings i'm
hopeful that your
gracious thoughtful
exchanges with some members will be
remembered as just one more service
you've rendered to our nation
and i hope some watching these syrians
will be reminded um that even though we
disagree with the policy preferences
or opinions of a nominee we should all
recognize when a nominee is
fundamentally qualified
deeply committed to the constitution
rule of law and a person of great
character
judge griffith reminded us at the outset
of this week and i quote
as justice scalia taught us
for so long an indispensable feature of
the republic the constitution created is
an independent judiciary of judges
who've taken an oath not to a president
or party but to the american people and
to god that they will be
impartial
i couldn't agree more with judge
griffith you have demonstrated your
unwavering commitment to that oath and
your impartiality your abundant
qualifications it'll be my honor to
support your confirmation for associate
justice
with that mr chair i yield
thank you senator coons the senator from
nebraska senator sas thanks chairman
durbin um judge welcome back uh i'd like
to associate myself with parts of what
chris said there in his closing um i
would differ with him about
whether or not getting to precision on
judicial philosophy matters but you know
that you know i've been wrestling about
it for a couple of weeks um but i'd like
to affirm chris's point about the beauty
of the hymn to america you told and
through the eyes of your parents and
that the changes um the the growth uh in
the country over the course of the last
two generations and the wall street
journal
had an editorial this morning that said
pretty much the same thing as chris just
said which is that the
the hymn to america that you gave in
your opening on monday afternoon and
some of your comments yesterday were
inspiring and beautiful so i associate
myself with senator coons on that um i'd
like to talk a little bit about your
time as a judge and particularly how you
see development and growth and change
over that time so take us back nine
years and then maybe five years ago and
then today how is your approach uh to
being a judge changed from year one to
year five to today
thank you senator um
i do think there was a little bit of
growth i hope there was a little bit of
growth um
certainly in year one and year five i
was still a district judge and both of
those years differed dramatically from
my work
as an appellate judge which is where i'm
currently stationed
in every job in year one you're new
you're trying to figure things out i
don't know that i had quite pinned down
at the very beginning uh exactly how i
would approach
uh cases but by the time i got to year
five i think i had a really good sense
of this judging thing
and was able
to
demonstrate in my opinions the
many many opinions that i've written
the way in which i go about making
my decisions
i was able to demonstrate uh clearly i
think
that
the particular parties
in the case the issues in the case what
it's about from a standpoint of personal
preference is not an issue i'm setting
those things aside
i am
ruling from a position of neutrality and
trying
to determine uh in every case what the
law requires i am looking at
only the facts and the law in the case
i'm evaluating the arguments of the
parties and
if it's statutory interpretation i'm
trying to ascertain what congress has
intended
i
am committed
i think my record shows
to the understanding that that is the
role and the only appropriate role
for a judge
i'd like to talk a little bit about the
troubling pattern we see on law school
campuses and across higher education
more broadly especially in the last five
years
there's obviously a trend toward
shouting down
and canceling opinions that are outside
the left-leaning mainstream uh calls for
firing professors canceling professors
shouting down and sometimes threatening
speakers who bring divergent
diverse opinions
calls to discipline fellow students
these tactics are increasingly
commonplace
particularly against conservative
speakers and professors and students but
also uh increasingly against traditional
liberals i'm a former college president
and one of the
sort of oddities uh that doesn't fit
inside the tribalism of how a lot of
times media covers things uh in d.c one
of the oddities for me is how often i
have liberal professors reaching out to
me
saying that their experience on campus
is becoming much less interesting
that the divide on american political
campuses is less and less
conservative policy leaning versus
liberal or progressive policy leaning
but more and more liberal versus
illiberal
and
i think these campaigns are obviously
deeply problematic they shut down debate
rather than teaching students how to
engage ideas that they might not have
encountered before which is also a
pretty decent definition of education uh
if you already knew everything before
you ever encountered a new idea you
wouldn't need to write checks or take
time off of
productive life so
there's obviously a tendency and
response for students to self-censor
rather than learn from each other and
this robs students of the chance to
engage with ideas from across the
political spectrum but in particular in
law schools
it robs students of the opportunity to
learn how to consider an alternate
position and argue a different uh point
of view than they might have had so
given that you're a debate champion in
earlier days as well i'd like to ask if
you agree that law students should be
engaging with ideas from across the
political spectrum even those they
disagree with rather than trying to shun
those different ideas
thank you senator um
let me just say
in part because these issues are things
that could implicate
matters that come before the courts i
will just say that as a general matter
law school like
many schools is a place where
ideas and perspectives are considered
and in the law
as i've said
it's important for the judge who's
making the decision to have
different
arguments
and so one of the things
that traditionally happens in law
schools is that
you are trained
in law
to
um
make arguments that are at times not
even the arguments that you personally
agree with because the understanding
is that in litigation in disputes that
come before the court
the court is going to want to hear from
different viewpoints
so in that sense the essence of legal
instruction
is to have different arguments being
made because that models in great
part
what happens in a courtroom
i'm i really am not trying to ask any
kind of gotcha question here i suspect
we highly agree so i don't understand
the qualification you put at the
beginning there's no sort of second
order fork on my question it is better
to debate ideas that you disagree with
and shout them down isn't it
it is better in law schools to make sure
that there are ideas from all
perspectives and in order to have that
happen they can't be suppressed so you
you don't want students shouting down
other students or visiting professors
right i mean i i'm honestly i didn't
think there was any chance we would
differ on this so i'm not no i'm not i'm
not
i'm not suggesting that we differ what
i'm what i'm saying is that um
these issues about
uh speech on campus and the like or the
kinds of things that are issues that are
working their way
you know in different formats and
different ways through the courts and so
i'm just being careful in terms of my my
answers okay i'm i'm i'm trying to lead
you because i want to because i think
american civic health will be better off
you're going to be a hero you are
already a hero to lots and lots of kids
students maybe some bound for the law
but more broadly students across the
country and
i think it's in america's public
interest for them to hear you as an
advocate for the full vigorous
strong kid debate of different views and
so i i suspect you are an advocate for
vigorous and robust debate i don't see
how you might be constrained against
saying that because of future cases but
um i'm gonna just assume we're mostly
aligned on this
i i think that's a fair assumption thank
you um i do want to make uh before i
move on just because we've had um
a number of members of this committee
comment on cameras in the court um i've
made my position on this clear a lot of
times but if if i can
give a tiny bit of
friend of the court brief in advance
because i think it when you're on the
court and you all continue to debate
this issue um i think it should be a
decision for the supreme court to make
about whether or not there are cameras
in the courtroom uh not a decision for
the article one branch to make for
article 3.
but i think it's incredibly important
for us to recognize because i think i
differ from a lot of my colleagues on
this who are advocates for cameras in
the courtroom i get their position um
that transparency is a virtue
transparency is a good thing i also
believe that pen and pad
can facilitate a whole heck of a lot of
transparency just fine and it's healthy
for americans to recognize the second
and third and fourth order effects of
cameras a huge part of why this
institution doesn't work well is because
we have cameras everywhere um cameras
change human behavior we know this you
don't have the same kinds of
conversation over the dinner table with
your family when you're wrestling
through issues and apologizing for
something and saying i said this before
but maybe i should modify what i said i
was my tone was jerky my substance
didn't account for your position um
there's a whole bunch of things that
humans can do if they're not immediately
mindful of some distant camera audience
that they might be trying to create a
sound byte for
and uh instagram can be useful for some
small things but for intellectual
discourse it is not a friend um and i
think we should recognize that the
jackassery we often see around here um
is partly because of people mugging for
short-term uh camera opportunities and
it is definitely um a second and third
and fourth order effect that the court
should think through before it has
advocates in there who are not only
trying to persuade u9 justices um but
also trying to get on cable that night
uh or create a viral video so for what
it's worth i hope that the court doesn't
respond to
some well-meaning uh impulses from the
congress to to push for cameras in the
courtroom but also some some bullying
and there are there are ways that you
can get to a lot of transparency
audio recordings are increasingly
released uh from from the supreme court
in timely or fashion over the past few
decades um so for what it's worth i'm
glad that you on the court are making
that decision and i hope it isn't made
for you by the by the congress i want to
go back to the legitimacy of the supreme
court
that term has been uh used a few times
over the last three days
do you think the supreme court is
legitimate
i do senator
and so
some of the ways that the court has been
derided and called illegitimate by
members of this senate include over the
course of recent days and weeks quote
leans into extreme partisanship
leads into extremism twists the law
threatens basic liberties has been
hijacked by republicans these kinds of
attacks undermine the public's trust in
the court
we need the public
to believe in the legitimacy of its
government including all three branches
so i would ask you um do you agree with
these characterizations of the court
that have been levied in this room over
the last few days
senator i have nothing but respect for
um
my former judicial colleagues my current
judicial colleagues and
hopefully my future
judicial colleagues i do believe that we
need legitimacy
i've said that that's
the currency of the court and i look
forward uh if i'm confirmed to joining
the institution so do you think there
could be any opinion that would be
handed down this term that could
undermine the legitimacy of the court
senator i think the supreme court
makes its determinations and
all of them are precedents and they are
entitled to respect
i'd like to come back to our
conversation from yesterday you pointed
out a number of times that as both a
district and now a circuit court judge
you were constrained and bound by the
supreme court's holdings uh you
mentioned a couple of times that you
haven't had a chance to do
much constitutional interpretation for
yourself
i largely agree uh with the way you
framed most of that for the lower courts
but i think you would also agree with me
that the job of the supreme court
justice is different
than a district court judge and in
certain ways from a circuit judge as
well
when you serve on the supreme court
you'll have to interpret what the
constitution means and based on what you
told us about the constrained role on
the lower courts
lower court decisions would then not be
able to answer how you would approach
the new job you would have on that
highest court
and so that's why i thought our
conversation on judicial philosophy
yesterday was somewhat
helpful i'm not a lawyer but i think you
took a lot of us to law school yesterday
in ways that were helpful and in
particular
you walk walked us through some
different schools of constitutional and
statutory interpretation in ways that i
think we're good for the committee we're
good for the court and we're good for
the public more broadly so i guess i
would ask you
if you could take us to law school
one more time
and walk us through some of the
different approaches to substantive due
process and unenumerated rights
what are the different ideas on the
supreme court and in the broader legal
community
thank you senator i am um
not uh mostly familiar with the
supreme court's precedence in this area
it's
been a while now that the supreme court
has determined
that
the 14th amendment
which
guarantees
due process
includes a substantive component in
addition to
procedure the term due process one would
think is just
about the
procedures that the government has to
afford you before it
affects your life
liberty or property but the supreme
court has also said
that
that that
protection
extends to certain
uh personal
individual
rights um that relate to dignity and
autonomy
um
and
that are deeply rooted in our nation's
history and traditions or implicit
in the concept of ordered liberty
and the kinds of things the court has
recognized pursuant to that
line of jurisprudence are things like
um marriage
um interracial marriage
uh
the access to contraception
um a woman's right to terminate her
pregnancy abortion um
pursuant to
or subject to the the framework
established in um row and casey
um
travel
they're
the child rearing
the ability to
direct your truck your children
those are
some of the rights that have been uh
recognized pursuant to the 14th
amendment due due process clause i'm
less familiar with the sort of scholarly
debate outside of
the supreme court's rulings so will
there be new ones in the future
um
senator i am not able to forecast in
every case the supreme court is
um looking at a particular set of
circumstances consistent with the
article 3 requirement that the court
look only at cases and controversies so
it would depend on what cases came
before the court so
i think i think that gets at the the
challenge here that you and i have been
going back and forth on over the course
of a couple of weeks because
um
i get the modesty points about being on
the district court but it seems pretty
important to understand what the limits
might be
as a justice and so i think this morning
again you stated that your i think the
quote was that your judicial philosophy
is your methodology
but i think that a judicial philosophy
of some kind
is necessarily an input uh into your
judicial methodology and into every
justice's actual jurisprudence on the
court and that's why i think it's
important for us to unpack that because
the philosophies that you've outlined
for the committee again i think
yesterday's uh back and forth that you
and i had on briar v scalia um
is important and you wouldn't claim any
of those philosophies for yourself and
yet i think the philosophies ultimately
instruct judges
on the sources and the tools they
consult on how they discern intent on
whether the constitution is protecting
specific limited and defined principles
or more general values and whether
modern values can be used to infuse our
understanding of the constitution so
again when you narrated a bit of the
debate between justice breyer
i know you've got lots of
intellectual inputs in life but you've
credited him as a as a brilliant jurist
and role model before and the scalia
debates
you didn't really tell us who you
thought got the better of the argument
and so i think throughout these two days
you've focused a lot on what the supreme
court has said and i think that is
helpful and important um
but i've been also trying to get at what
you think the limits might be on what um
justice jackson would be constrained by
so i i feel like i believe we still
haven't heard your judicial philosophy
and i wish i'd made more progress with
you on that
but what we do know on a personal note
is that these committee
three days have been very long and i
want to thank you and got to have a nice
conversation with your parents earlier
your whole family uh for what you've
endured and for spending time with us
and obviously wish best wishes to you
and your family thank you judge thank
you
one more minute
thank you senator sass and senator
blumenthal is next
thanks mr chairman good afternoon
good afternoon jackson uh i know your
birthday
september 14th
yes sir you have the
happy coincidence of a birthday with
constance baker motley yes sir
uh who just happens to have been born in
new haven connecticut ah
and uh we're very proud that she is a
daughter of new haven and connecticut
and uh she is one of my heroes as well
as you
know about her
she
was the first
black woman appointed to the federal
bench
she is the first black woman to have
argued before
the united states supreme court in fact
her record before the court was 10 wins
and zero losses
she was
very predominantly responsible for brown
versus board of education thurgood
marshall got most the credit but
she did a lot of the work
probably sounds familiar to you
uh
so why don't you tell us and maybe tell
those folks particularly
uh
women and girls who are watching or
listening
why
you said at the outset of the
hearings here that
she was one of those
whose shoulders you stood upon as you
came here today
thank you senator um
well in addition to the fact
that we share a birthday which i
discovered when i was in law school and
thought what a happy coincidence in
terms of someone who i so admired and
um secretly at that point i was thinking
maybe i might
want to be a judge so it was a wonderful
uh wonderful coincidence
um
i so admired the fact that she was the
first
it's not it's not necessarily easy to be
the first but it
um
it is an opportunity to show other
people what is possible
when you're the first it means no one
has ever done it before like you
and there may be
um
hundreds thousands of people who might
have wanted that opportunity and thought
i can't do that because there's no one
there like me
and so being
a trailblazer whether it's
judge motley or
uh
justice marshall or justice o'connor
being a trailblazer um
is is really inspiring i think and um
and i was always um moved by judge
motley's experience and and think it may
even be part of why i moved um in this
direction
well it is inspiring
and i hope that your very inspiring
story
will make it possible for a lot of
others to
think it not secretly
but say it out loud
and
aspire to it
because it's what this country needs and
fortunately
president biden has recognized it in the
nominees that he's put before us and
we've tried to work with the great
leadership of senator durbin to
confirm
people of real merit the kind of
qualifications
in intellect and character
and depth and warmth that you bring to
us today
i want to talk a little bit about voting
rights
because part of the reason why those
dreams
now are realities is that
more people
have the right to vote at least until
recently
uh in fact there has been
[Music]
a lot of backsliding about
turning back the clock on voting rights
uh
the
gentleman sitting behind you
uh doug jones our former colleague whom
we
very much respect and admire
wrote a tribute to
uh vivian malone jones
who has a rich story as a civil rights
warrior
and who succeeded john lewis as head of
the voter
rights project
and he said in a speech that doug jones
wrote in tribute to her as she was
inducted boss humorously into the
alabama women's hall of fame
i'm quoting
we can best honor her by acknowledging
that while most doors are unlocked today
they are still heavy
and so hard to open
for so so many people
in alabama
and the rest of the nation
let us commit ourselves
to do our part to open these doors
as wide as possible so that everyone can
take the walk that vivian took
i'm gonna ask that
former senator jones
full speech be entered in the record mr
chairman
thank you
the simple fact of the matter is uh
judge jackson uh
congress passed the voting rights act in
1965
it
was a source of
real
power
to so many people who got the right to
vote for the first time in practical
terms because it struck down
more than one thousand discriminatory
election rules proposed by state and
local officials it opened
the ballot box
to millions and millions of americans
and it became regarded as the crown
jewel
of the civil rights movement
and then
just in the last few years the supreme
court has hacked away at it in
an exercise of judicial activism
that has been historic in magnitude
judges supplanting
their
views for
the policy preferences
and
official acts of legislatures
in opinions that were written and joined
by
only conservative justices
these decisions were about as far from
judicial restraint as they could
possibly be not even close
and they rewrote the rules of our most
cherished and most bipartisan
civil rights laws
you know the cases
shelby county
brnovich versus
the democratic national committee
in effect
their opinions including justice alito's
decision brnovich
are completely untethered
from the clear
statutory
text
and they impose a series of
so-called guide posts
on section 2 that create
unreasonably high hurdles to the
exercise of the voting rights act
i hope that
you will bring to the court
that
deliberate careful methodology that you
described earlier very convincingly
it is part of your judicial philosophy
in the sense that it's your approach to
cases
and it has been very persuasively and
clearly articulated
and i think if that kind of
deliberate and careful methodology had
prevailed
on the united states supreme court we
would still have the voting rights act
in full right now
and i hope that
we can once again
return to bipartisan support of those
rights
the most recent exercise of
uh
unfortunate decision making in the
voting rights area came just
hours ago when the supreme court struck
down
the decision of the wisconsin state
supreme court
in wisconsin legislature versus
wisconsin elections commission what is
striking is not only the result
but the fact that it was done as part of
the shadow docket
we've talked a lot about it here
and
what the people of america could should
know is
there's no oral argument
there's only minimal briefing
there are no full opinions of the court
in fact
i'm holding up a per curium
opinion
that is about 12 pages in length
from the court
which means you don't know who wrote it
and
there is a powerful descent
i recommend that
everyone read it
again use of the shadow docket has
become increasingly prevalent since
2017
and in effect the united states supreme
court is shirking its duty i hope you
will bring to the court
the kind of responsible
and
methodical approach to decision making
that will lead to
an avoidance of
the shadow docket
as well as a return to
the voting rights act and if i can just
offer one more
piece of advice on
the court's workload
uh
i have um
a chart
i know we're not going by the rules of
evidence here
but this chart
indicates the
signed decisions
of the united states supreme court
over
a good part of its history
and
i think
the pattern here is pretty clear
the court
issues fewer sign
opinions
in fact
it has
declined
precipitously since 1972
this little blip at the end here
is an increase from 53 to 57
but you can see it's only a fraction of
what the court used to do
in signed opinions even from the time
when i was a law clerk
it's diminished
profoundly
the supreme court needs to do its job
it needs to issue signed opinions not
the shadow docket it needs to take cases
and resolve
real fundamental important issues
and
taking your record
573 opinions
over nine years
i'm not a math major but that's about 64
opinions a year that's a lot more than
they do all nine of them
so
i hope you will bring the energy that
you have
demonstrated in this room the energy
and the work ethic
to
the united states supreme court because
clearly you have both
and i think the court
is very much in need of it
as it is some of the other great
qualities intellect character
that you have demonstrated here
uh
just a couple more points
if i may
um
you were
asked earlier about
dissents
um
i want to ask you about one
in particular
uh
the descent of your mentor
and your predecessor on the court
justice breyer
uh
i am told i think i've read
that there is one opinion that he is
proudest of
could you tell us
what you recall it being
if you know
senator i'm not able to answer that
question
well i think he said
that uh
the dissent that he is proudest of
was in parents involved in community
schools versus seattle school district
uh
i think he said it was the opinion that
he was
proudest of
uh and he cited it
in a harvard law school symposium about
his notable opinions
um
and he said this dissent was
most notable
uh
i will give you this citation
uh when we're done
um
and ask that it be entered into the
record mr chairman
without objection
uh
it's 77 pages long
and it's a dissent
uh
it's a dissent in the
parents involved case which
was a five justice plurality in
validating public school
integration plans
in seattle and louisville
the plans had been in place for decades
put in place by two local school boards
voluntarily trying to address
school segregation in public schools in
both of those
cities
and the justices conservative justice
striking down the school integration
plans
said in effect they couldn't
move forward with those integration
plans
uh
you may recall it is um
the
opinion
where
uh chief justice roberts said
very famously the way to stop
discrimination on the basis of race
is to stop discrimination
stop discriminating on the basis of race
justice breyer in descent
which reminded me of a lot of what
you've said here
this week
wrote quote i do not claim to know how
best
to stop harmful discrimination how best
to create a society that includes all
american
how best to overcome
our serious problems of increasing
de facto
segregation
but as a judge
i do know that the constitution does not
authorize judges to dictate solutions to
these
problems rather the constitution creates
a democratic political system
through which the people themselves
through their legislators
must find
must together find answers the court
should leave them to their work
i think that's the philosophy that
you've
articulated here today the judicial
philosophy
of
separate branches of government as you
so eloquently described our
constitutional scheme
our federalism
that really should have
led the court to respect the wisconsin
supreme court's decision and the
wisconsin
governor's decision
and to stay in its lane
as you have
put it so well
the fact is there has been a lot of
progress and we see it in this
hearing room
but there is a lot of work still to be
done and
there's a lot of reason
for folks to feel
even
some anger at what we've seen on voting
rights
and on
re-segregation
in some areas
so i am really
excited
as i've indicated and joyful
at
the
great landmark
and the historic accomplishment that
your nomination represents and reflects
and i hope as i've said that
not only will you make the court look
more like america but hopefully think
more
like america
and i want to thank you for
your
very hard work all of what you
personally
have done because you as a person have
done it
and history has given you this
opportunity your parents
have helped to make it possible
your family story is so powerful
but
you've really earned it
and
we're grateful to you for
providing all of us that role model
thank you mr trump um thank you senator
blumenthal senator holy thank you mr
chairman judge good to see you again
good to see you senator we don't uh have
a lot of time so let me just get
straight into it uh senator cruz was
asking you at the end of of his time and
questionings about united states versus
stewart this is the case where neil
stewart tried to cross state lines to
rape another person's nine-year-old
daughter he had 6 700 images and videos
of egregious and brutal child
pornography the government recommended
97 months all right everybody i think
josh hawley is going to get back to
talking about these same eight cases
i see i have a lot of people that need
to get banned on twitch and youtube i've
been planning a great show for you guys
for tomorrow i'm going to get to banning
and then we will listen
i can stand in for a judge's entire
record
i have
sentenced more than 100 people in a
variety of egregious circumstances
in every case
and especially cases
that involve
the kinds of acts that you're talking
about the kinds of evidence
that i had to deal with as a judge
in every case
i am balancing the factors that congress
has determined are appropriate and
required for a judge to make a
determination the data points that
senator cruz pointed to that you may
have in front of you
don't account for all of the information
that was before me as a judge
and
the authority
that you all
congress and your prior confirmation
when i was a district judge provided for
me to exercise
my judgment and i treated those cases in
every case
very seriously
and imposed a sentence that was
sufficient but not greater than
necessary to promote the purposes of
punishment would it surprise you to
learn that mr stewart is a recidivist it
was warrants issued again for his arrest
just three years after you sentenced him
would it surprise me yeah what is
surprising
you know senator um
[Music]
i'm a judge there is data in the
sentencing commission and elsewhere that
indicates that there are recidivism
serious recidivism issues
and so
among the
various people that i've sentenced i'm
not surprised that there are people who
reoffend and it is a terrible thing that
happens in our system yeah indeed it is
let me ask you about the hawkins case
you know i talked about this yesterday
you've been able to think about it
overnight this is a case where you had
an 18 year old
who possessed and distributed hundreds
of images of eight-year-olds and
nine-year-olds and ten-year-olds and you
gave him frankly a slap on the risens of
three months senator you regret it i
don't remember whether it was um
distribution or possession it was law do
you regret it in in the law
there are different
uh crimes that people committed you gave
him three months my question is do you
regret it or not senator
what
i regret
is that in a hearing
about
my qualifications to
be
a justice on the supreme court we've
spent a lot of time
focusing
on this
small subset of my sentences and i've
tried to explain you regret that we're
focusing on your cases i don't
understand no no no i'm i'm i'm talking
about the fact that you're talking about
child production
very serious cases i'm glad we agree on
that don't you some some some of which
some of which involve
conduct that i sentence people to 25 30
years three months in this case judge do
you regret it you haven't answered my
question all these guys are just
suck-ups to right-wing media doing
everything they can to get their clips
played by laura ingram tonight the
circumstances we discussed it for half
an hour yesterday there's a 55-page
transcript which i'm sure you've read
you lived it as you've emphasized to
this committee over and over you've
lived it right you said that you've been
through all of this you've looked at all
of the images you're the one who's had
to endure all of it you gave him a
three-month sentence i just wonder if
you regret it if you stand by it i mean
do you stand by that sentence senator in
every case i followed what congress
authorized me to do in looking
to the best of my ability at all of the
various factors
that
apply my instinct and this would be the
wrong thing to do would be to say
senator with all due respect as someone
who's not a judge you aren't even
equipped to understand that the concepts
of standing by or regretting a sentence
aren't the way judges think about these
types of things
no one case senator can stand in for i'm
not asking that i'm asking if you regret
this sentence in this case and it sounds
like the answer is no but i want to tell
you i regret it
i regret that you gave him only three
months let me read to you what you said
about these kinds of cases in fact to
this defendant you said make no mistake
mr hawkins the children you saw on those
pictures were not willing participants
in the conduct that you witnessed they
were being forced to commit unspeakable
acts of sexual violence for the pleasure
of the person who was filming and for
the gratification of sick people
everywhere people who apparently have no
shred of empathy for what thus must be
doing to the children who are being
abused in this way you go on some of the
children you saw in those pictures will
never never have an adult a normal adult
relationship
some of them will turn to drugs and
prostitution and other vices to try to
deal emotionally with the pain that
results from the torture that they have
experienced and even those who manage to
lead a somewhat normal adult life
say they live in constant fear of being
recognized
some people are even unable to leave
their houses because once those pictures
are on the internet they are there
forever and the victims can't do
anything without worrying that every
person that they meet has seen them in
their most vulnerable state at the most
horrible time in their lives that's your
words pages 34 and 35 the transcript
powerful words judge i just don't
understand why after saying this and
believing this you could give this guy
three months in prison when the
probation office that we've heard so
much about
recommended 18 months even the probation
office recommended 18 months
do you have anything to add
was there a question no senator
let me ask you about your policy of not
giving enhancements when there are
pre-pubescent children like there were
in the hawkins case who are eight nine
ten years old when there are
prepubescent children involved i don't
i'm just struggling to understand this
you said it in hawkins you said that you
weren't going to give him an enhancement
you weren't going to give make his
sentence any tougher despite the fact
that we had all of these terrible videos
that you and i talked about at length
yesterday this is page 38 of the
transcript just so we're all following
along you said in your case i don't feel
that it is appropriate necessarily to
increase the penalty on the basis of
your use of a computer we've talked
about that or the number of images or
prepubescent victims as the guidelines
require
because these circumstances exist in
many cases if not most and they don't
signal an especially heinous or
egregious child pornography offense you
said the same thing in the cooper case
just last year this was an individual
cooper who was 30 years old at the time
of his sentencing he pleaded guilty to
distributing child pornography he posted
between three and four dozen images of
child exploitation to tumblr where it
could be accessed you can tell that
she's now going into the approach of let
them talk
if there's no direct question don't even
give an answer they each get 20 minutes
it's almost over
she doesn't actually need their votes
and if they're not going to vote for her
she's not going to be able to say
anything to convince them this is the
right approach now tight of the content
of any child pornography but rather to
say that the content of those videos is
on the more egregious or extreme
spectrum
of the child pornography videos that are
encountered in these cases and yet when
you sentenced him
you said i'm quoting now from the
transcript in cooper i'm really
reluctant to get into the nature of the
porn and then later it's very difficult
to assess
how different mr cooper's images are
than those of other similarly situated
child pornography dependent defendants
rather such that i without going into
looking at them and i'm not an expert
you say so you say while i understand
the government's arguments mr miranda
the government's arguments in that
regard i don't find them persuasive from
the standpoint of characterizing this as
an especially egregious child
pornography
offense help me understand this judge
why is it that you what's your policy
disagreement with the guidelines
treating
images videos
pornographic images that have small
children infants seven eight
nine-year-olds why won't you give an
enhancement for those help me understand
that
thank you senator i'll make two
responses first that's not
my policy disagreement i don't know
why you've characterized that in that
way well wait a minute wait a minute you
you say right here in the cases i mean
this is
this is what i want to get i want to
make sure that we're talking about the
same thing here
this why do they did they interrupt amy
kovet barrett like this increase the
penalty on the basis of your use of a
computer or the number of images or
prepubescent victims and you say the
same thing in cooper senator
two
observations one
i am
sentencing in every case i have policy
disagreements with certain aspects of
the operation of the guidelines that i
lay out in every case as congress has
required and as the supreme court
permits in light of
my experience not only as a district
judge but also on the sentencing
commission which did a report
about the operation of the guidelines
second
you've read
extensively
from
the government's argument in this case
you've not provided information from the
probation office or the defense and
women i don't have the probation officer
no excuse me senator the probation
office
provides a
recommendation
there has been information gathered
about what a recommendation was given in
each one of these cases i don't have
that information here but what i'm
saying
is that in every case the judge is not
just hearing from the government
the the judge is not just
evaluating what the government says in
these cases in every criminal case
a judge has to take into account
all sorts of factors including arguments
being made
by the defendant
by the government by the proposal she's
kind of just explaining to holly how
sentencing works like there's two
recommendations one is usually stricter
than what they give and one is usually
lighter and it's usually somewhere in
between depending on the circumstances
arguments and the court evaluates
everything as congress has directed and
no one case can stand in for my entire
record of how i deal with criminal cases
or did when i was a district judge
i have law enforcement in my family i am
a mother who has
daughters
who
took these cases home with me at night
because
they are so graphic
in terms of the kinds of images that you
are describing they give you not only
the actual videos which you can ask to
see but they describe
in
the briefs
in detail
what these videos show so i am fully
aware
josh hawley is a great example of the
wheel is spinning like crazy but the
hamster's dead
to take into account
all of the various
aspects
of the crime as congress has required me
to do and i made a determination
seriously in each case what i'm trying
to understand is why is it that you say
multiple times that just because there
are pre-pubescent victims in cooper in
hawkins that that does not signal that
this is a heinous or egregious child
pornography offense and you're not going
to apply any sentencing enhancements
that the government's asking you for the
sentence gets to be less
because you say i'm not going to apply
the government asked for enhancements
related to prepubescent children related
to the nature of these images you say
i'm not going to apply it but i get what
you're telling me is i guess that you
you don't have a policy objection why
why didn't you apply the enhancements as
they were asked for senator i've
answered this question many times from
many senators who've asked me so i'll
stand on what i've already said
beautiful so you have nothing to add
about about
why these crimes why these images and
nothing in addition to her 40 answers
not signal an especially heinous or
egregious child pornography offense
that's hawkins
you say in cooper i understand the
government's argument but i don't find
them persuasive the fact that there were
pre-predestined children from the
standpoint of characterizing this as an
especially egregious child pornography
offense that's page 58
is there a question
let me ask you this you said senator
graham to senator graham earlier today
that you were trying to do what's
rational this is another good move
unless you're asked a question don't
just talk because there's a silence
people who have thousands of images
by using a computer
to the sentencing guidelines to the man
to the mandatory range i'm sorry it's
not mandatory to the no longer mandatory
range the discretionary range no senator
i said the guidelines system
is designed to be rational okay so let
me ask you this
why isn't it rational
to sentence people who have thousands of
images
on a computer
to more time
as opposed to somebody who has
one or two pictures in the mail
in other words the more images there are
why wouldn't you want to sentence that
person to more time rather than less why
isn't that rational
senator i've answered this question and
i'll stand on what i already answered
so
but your answer is what i mean refresh
my memory
senator i've answered this question i've
explained how the guidelines work and
i'll stand on my answer but the
guidelines are not mandatory i wish they
were but change the guidelines as a
member of congress then trying to
understand why you think it's rational
not to sentence
criminals based on the number of images
they have you say that this is a policy
disagreement that you have with the
guidelines this gets to the core of your
judicial philosophy
you served on the sentencing commission
where you recommended changes to the
guidelines based in part on this policy
disagreement so i think it's relevant
and indeed vital we understand what the
policy disagreement is that's what i'm
trying to get at here senator i've
previously explained what the policy
disagreement is and i will stand on my
answer
so you're not going to answer my
question no i've answered your question
in my answer you haven't answered my
question i'm sitting here asking you and
you're declining to answer
i've explained
how
uh the guidelines work i've explained
that
um
the guidelines is it different to access
porn via the internet versus through a
gramophone was different than it is
today i've explained
that congress has not
intervened to
revise or direct the commission around
how to deal with the changes in the
commission of this crime and so judges
all over the country are grappling with
uh how to apply this guideline under
these circumstances and there's
an extreme amount of disparity and in
each case
a judge has to look at
all of the factors not just the
guidelines not just what the government
asks for
but
the recommendations of the probation
office the arguments of the government
and the defense the nature and
circumstances of the offense the history
and characteristics of the defendant the
need for the sentence imposed to promote
the purposes of punishment which include
things like rehabilitation also in every
case
congress has authorized judges to impose
not only terms of imprisonment which are
a very important part of the
consequences for these crimes but
arranging judge did you ever receive
porn by facts tentative kinds of
measures
which courts impose in cases to prevent
these defendants from repeating these
egregious uh uh
this type of egregious conduct and i
talked uh to each defendant as you have
quoted explaining to them the harms that
their crimes caused and i imposed not
only a term of imprisonment but also all
of the other consequences of the offense
to include decades of supervision
restrictions on use of a computer and
the like
that's my answer i've answered it many
times do you have other questions for me
uh yeah i do
i do because i wanna i wanna try to
understand when you talk about the
guidelines being outdated and outmoded
i understand that they were
written the initial guidelines were
written at a time when computers were
not common everybody didn't have one
cert didn't have phones in
every pocket like we do now smartphones
so i understand that
i also understand that
the number of images
sexually exploitative images of children
on these devices has exploded and so i'm
trying to get at what senator coons
earlier characterized as a pretty
fundamental policy question which i
think is the correct characterization
here i'm trying to understand your view
on why it is
that while the images the number of
images available on these things has
exploded
that sentencing shouldn't track that you
see what i'm saying i mean you guys
think holly doesn't get it like holly's
insisting that her position is it never
matters whether someone has one a
thousand or a million explicit images
my understanding of what she has said is
that that alone doesn't tell you how
much prison time they deserve and there
are considerations like are they
producing it what other factors are
there what is the person's age it's that
that's my like it's just so simple she's
not saying
it's the same whether it's a million or
one it's just does he get it or is he
pretending now
is that you have a guideline that has
gradations in it
for the number of images okay that ends
up being when you look at this
something like the difference of
10 years i'm making i i don't know
exactly what it is but each
each two level enhancement is like
several years and the gradations are
like
zero to and again i don't have it in
front of me but it's like 0 to 50
pictures 50 to 100 pictures 100 to 150
pictures set up at a time in which the
mail
was the primary mode of possession and
distribution and so if somebody had 50
pictures they
according to congress
this is another fair point when you're
physically sending images it's different
than like i guess that's another fair
point which is if you're on a computer
and someone sends you a zip file with a
thousand or two thousand images
it's if you didn't produce any of them
it's essentially the same crime right i
mean it's you're receiving it in an
instant over a high-speed connection
that that i understand as well how are
we going to deal with the penalties and
do our jobs to impose sentences that are
sufficient but not greater than
necessary under these circumstances
thank you i'll just i'll just say in
closing that i appreciate that answer
and i understand that as a policy matter
i just think we disagree i think that
somebody the more images are there the
more punishment there should be and i
want to see this deterred and i just
think we've pretty fundamentally
disagreed i've enjoyed our exchanges
thank you for your candor and uh i
appreciate it i just disagree with you
on the law thank you mr chairman senator
hirono uh mr chairman
uh-oh mr chairman it's cancun
mr chairman i'm asking you to be
recognized to make a point to the
chairman no uh mr
i believe he recognized me may i proceed
mr chairman mr chairman i i waited my
turn on here and i've been on this
committee for 47 years i i think we
ought to fall in regular order mr
chairman the witness just said that we
cannot understand those cases without
the pre-sentence i don't want to go
through this again i have a letter that
i want to enter into the record that's
signed by ten senators on this committee
do you are you not even going to allow a
letter from 10 senators on this
committee any letter you can do it
this letter that is signed by 10
senators on the committee addressed to
you makes the point that the white house
gave you probation
information for democrats that was not
provided to the minority on this
committee and just now judge jackson
told senator hawley you cannot
understand these cases without reading
the probation reports ten senators on
this committee are asking the chairman
to provide those reports so we can do
what judge jackson just shared right
which is to assess those reports and
here it is
i know the junior senator from texas
likes to get on television but most of
us have been here a long time trying to
follow the rules yeah uh
and he could very easily hand you a
letter to go in the record
he's saying he's doing this to help
senator hawley senator hawley could have
put it in he didn't yeah but let's get
back to regular senator hawley didn't
write the letter mr german i asked his
consent that it be admitted to the
record what a loser
thank you are you denying consent thank
you mr chairman it's just out of order
aloha judge jackson aloha
i'm gonna try and spread some aloha into
this room
i'm taking a lead from uh my friend
senator uh sitting to my left hirono's
very good by the way color coordinated
today
so since 2018 i have been asking every
nominee that comes before the committees
on which i said the two questions
that i asked you at the start of my time
namely
whether or not they have a history of
sexual assault or harassment this is
something i started
in 2018 to make sure that harassment and
abuse
that women mainly have put up with since
as far as i'm concerned time immemorial
didn't continue to get swept under the
rug
i found these questions to be important
for nominees to the judiciary
as chief justice roberts stated in his
2017 year-end report on the federal
judiciary
events in recent months have illuminated
the depth of the problem of sexual
harassment in the workplace
and events in the past few weeks have
made clear
that it would be so great if she went
through every one of the allegations
against kavanaugh judge jackson have you
ever been accused of boofing are you
familiar with the devil's triangle
and staffers accused ninth circuit judge
alex kozinski of subjecting them to a
range of inappropriate sexual conduct
and comments
in september 2019 the 10th circuit
judicial council issued an order finding
that district court judge carlos mcgive
apologized if i mispronounced his last
name
and harassed multiple employees over a
period of years including by subjecting
them to sexually suggestive comments
inappropriate text messages and
excessive non-work related conduct in
february 2020 former law clerk to the
late 9th circuit judge stephen reinhardt
accused the judge of a months-long
harassment
campaign i mean it's there's a very good
uh uh post message that i'm stealing
from the twitch chat i'm gonna tweet
about it right now
both because of the power imbalance
between federal judges and their clerks
and employees who often rely on
connections and recommendations to
advance in their careers and because of
the lack of legal recourse available to
the judicial employees
many may not realize this but federal
judicial branch employees are not
protected by the foundational federal
statutes such as title vii
of the civil rights act of 1964 that
prohibit discrimination and retaliation
and that's why i introduced along with
chair durbin and senators white house
and murray the judicial accountability
act
which would ensure the more than 30 000
employees of the federal judiciary have
strong statutory rights and protections
against discrimination
sexual harassment retaliation and other
forms of workplace conduct i know you
can't comment on legislation so i won't
ask you whether you support the judicial
accountability act instead
i'd like to hear what you do
to make sure your chambers
is a safe inclusive place to work
thank you senator um
i'm going to briefly step away to keep
working on tomorrow's show i do want to
say that thanks to zippy boy priest
and mike boy raps putting us at 29 also
real quick thank you to ron gate as well
as dracula
and heather lin for the website
memberships putting us at 32 we will
continue expecting this to go to about 8
pm eastern employer
that i bring law clerks into my chambers
um i was a law clerk to three wonderful
federal judges who were role models for
me and
um
i tried to
act as a role model to my law clerks i
try to bring in people who
um
who
have
the respect of others people who come
with strong recommendations
people who i think will get along with
one another
um and certainly people who i think will
get along with me and we create
um a little group a working group
and i think that it's it's worked out
well
and i would uh think that you would make
sure that there are no instances
of inappropriate behavior sexual
harassment from any of your
clerks or employees that's absolutely
correct
during our courtesy meeting i enjoyed
learning more about your background and
family and of the nine sitting justices
of the supreme court only three
justices alito breyer and kagan were
educated in our public school system and
you would as far as i'm concerned make a
welcome addition to the court from that
standpoint
as a public school graduate myself
so public high schools educate people
from all backgrounds and most people go
to public schools most people don't go
get to go to private schools so your
classmates probably came from different
racial and ethnic backgrounds incomes
social statuses
academic abilities athletic abilities
among others
how if at all has your public school
experience shaped the person you are and
your approach to the law
thank you senator i was uh
very fortunate to go to
a public school in miami florida
i had a wide range of
classmates and it was a wonderful
opportunity to get to know people who
were different
than me
and
to
learn at the end of the day that they
were not so different
than than i am
um even if they came from different
backgrounds and
i've talked a lot about my debate team
um that was one of the
activities that i engaged in and spent a
lot of time
with my
colleagues on the debate team and with
with my wonderful
coach
and you learn how to support each other
how to speak across difference how to
how to communicate
with
different kinds of people and it was it
was a wonderful experience and and as
i've mentioned in in many ways different
than
the generation before
who
in florida
were
segregated by law
so i take it that not only did you have
i would say
a broad experience of encountering
people from all different walks of life
and backgrounds but there was still
a commonality that you had very much so
and and that is very much exemplified in
your approach to
your work
i also talked with you about the
importance of the creative part of our
lives
because i think lawyers tend to be a
very left brain and i know that you are
a very uh well-rounded person and so
asked you what do you do to
pay attention to the creative side of
your of your life
thank you for the question um
i
took up not
too long ago but took up
the fiber arts as they say
my mother is an expert
crochet
artist
she
makes beautiful
pieces of all kinds and
i always wanted to do that i always
wanted to and she tried to teach me when
i was younger and it didn't quite turn
out um but
as i
have
gone along in my career and wanting to
have some sort of a creative outlet and
especially in times of of high stress
um i started
pining for uh something to do to express
my creative
side and
i
bought a book on crochet i talked to my
mom i started making hats and scarves
and then i moved to knitting during one
of my confirmation um hearing uh
scenarios because i needed something to
keep my mind off of
uh keep my mind off of the stress so i i
i have a basement full of yarn if you if
you'd like to come over
i think that's another way that you're
connecting to the people who really
meant
mean a lot to you
the creative outlet is really important
to me because in a changing world i
think it is our ability to be creative
in our approaches
uh and how we think about things that
will enable us to deal with the rapid
changes that uh
happen every day in these days i uh view
you as a consensus
builder
and so i know that in your work with the
sentencing commission you
really worked hard to come up with some
95 of the time the in this very diverse
group there was consensus in your
recommendations how important do you
think consensus is on what i
characterized yesterday as a very
ideologically spit split supreme court
i think consensus is very important um
it was
one of the
things that i
most admired about having the
opportunity to to work
for justice breyer as a law clerk to
observe his
process
for reaching out to colleagues and
trying to collaborate in his
thought process about the outcomes of
cases and it's something that i tried to
emulate
when i was on the sentencing commission
which as you said is a very diverse
body
and
i saw in that context the importance
of
trying to reach common ground with
respect to your determinations
mr chairman thank you very much uh to
illustrate the kind of abroad support
that this nominee has i would like to
enter into the record
two letters one signed by a thousand
public defenders from all across the
country and another from
signed by 48 prosecutors from across the
country
judge jackson i have very much enjoyed
the projection of talking with you thank
you mr chairman
and uh it will be my privilege to
support your nomination
thank you senator
thank you very much senator
mr chairman
senator from yeah i want a letter here
signed by
uh members on my side of the iowa i'd
like to put the record without objection
i'd like to comment i had a chance to
review this letter for the first time
just a minute ago
uh there is
apparently a concern on your side mr
chairman
about whether you have on your side of
the aisle access to all the information
that we have on this side of the aisle
and all the information that's in the
possession of the white house
during a break earlier today i met with
the ranking members senator grassley his
staff
and with white house staff to discuss it
here's my understanding of what has
transpired
last wednesday evening the senator from
missouri
selected a handful of judge jackson's
more than one thousand district court
cases to claim that judge jackson quote
endangers our children close quote
on thursday the next day the white house
contacted judge jackson's chambers to
request the probation office
recommendation in each of the cases
i
underline probation office
that probation office provided a chart
reflecting these recommendations this is
the sum total of what was provided
they shared with the white house from
the chambers
when the senator from missouri continued
to raise questions
and request the probation office's
recommendation in these cases the
probation office provided this chart
reflecting those recommendations which
was shared with the white house when the
senator from missouri continued to raise
questions about judge jackson's
sentencing record my staff asked the
white house for information about the
probation office recommendations these
are just numbers for each one of the
cases that's all that is the white house
in my office didn't have this
information earlier because we didn't
know the senator from missouri was going
to make this claim in the first place
once the republican side requested the
same information my staff shared it
within minutes
so now your side senator has exactly
what the white house and the democratic
side has the same chart provided by the
probation office
and i might add that some of this had
been published in the press in
washington post and other places but it
consists in each case
of the case number name
the
probation office recommendation for
custody the sentence imposed custody
probation officer recommended
supervision and release and the
supervision and release imposed
all of that information has now been
shared equally
some information on the other side on
the republican side includes
frequent reference to transcripts which
we don't have on this side and the
reason being we didn't anticipate this
objection from the senator from missouri
and request that information
now the letter also goes a step beyond
which i think is a very important
decision for this committee to make
this request for pre-sentence reports
from each of these cases
now these pre-sentence reports are
typically filed under seal
they can contain highly sensitive
personal information
not just about the defendant but about
innocent third parties and victims
we've spent a lot of time here
reflecting on these terrible crimes
everyone has acknowledged how terrible
they are
and how damaging they can be to the
victims
we have heard story after story and i
don't question a single word that was
spoken
in sympathy for these same victims
i would not want it weighing on my
conscience that we are turning over
these pre-sentence reports to this
committee for the first time in history
and that information
out of this or because it was released
would somehow compromise or endanger any
victim as a result of it this
information was not requested before
it's never been requested by this
committee
and i think we ought to think long and
hard about whether or not we even
consider going into pre-sentence reports
so i'm going to take this matter up with
our side and i'm sure you will with your
side i have your letter requesting it as
far as this information you have exactly
what we have no more no less in terms of
pre-sentence reports this is a critical
policy question which ought to be
carefully weighed it goes way beyond i'm
sorry senator uh judge jackson it goes
way beyond your nomination and i want to
make certain that we don't take a step
here that endangers the lives or
well-being of innocent people
mr chairman
uh since you did just responded to the
letter that i wrote and was submitted on
behalf of of 10 senators
i will point out that in judge jack
jackson's answer to senator hawley
she said that he and this committee did
not have sufficient information to
assess her sentencing decisions
because we heard the arguments of the
prosecutors in the transcript but we did
not have the recommendation from the
probation office and what she testified
under oath is you can't understand
why she
issued her sentences without having
those probation reports you are right
that there can be sensitive victim
information in those reports and and
everyone on this side i'm confident
uh would agree to redacting out any
information that that would violate the
privacy
of a victim but judge jackson has told
us it is relevant to understanding those
cases and and that's why 10 of us
have requested we have those reports and
there's explicit statutory authority for
us to do so that is cited uh in the
letter we just submitted senator
i don't know where
other members of your caucus stand on
the basic question of this nomination
they can decide on their own and they
will and they should that is their
responsibility i think i know where
you're headed
and i would just suggest that
we ought to think long and hard my
friends about members of the judiciary
committee
endangering the lives of innocent people
to pursue this line of questioning we
spent two days
15 16 17 18 hours and a large part of it
on this issue
i don't believe these pre-sentencing
reports are going to change anyone's
disposition if they're going to vote on
this issue
and i i do not want it weighing on my
conscience that i gave the green light
to release this information
so that it might endanger the lives of
innocent victims i'm sorry that's a
bridge too far for me
i think the issue before us on
sentencing you each had a chance to hear
plenty of testimony on it
and i believe this should be taken up
with the individual caucuses on both
sides if you wish but
that to me is it's gone way too far
way too far
i don't want it on my conscience mr mr
chairman if i might
say like when i agree with you i've
prosecuted
literally thousands of people
i
would have to go back and see over eight
years i can't
i can't remember the hundreds of
sentencings
i was at we had
pre-sentence reports
over and over again
there were things in there that were
sensitive
sometimes
reflecting somebody who were putting
their lives on the line
to even give a report
uh
neither the defense counsel
nor i as a prosecutor
ever thought those would be made
public
and we assumed the judges
we had judges across the political
uh stripes who
read them
kept the confidence of that
as a result we knew that the reports
were
thorough
and a judge has the final
say but as a prosecutor i might have a
recommendation
but i never questioned
a judge who might give a different
um
sentence because my
my responsibility was prosecute theirs
was the sentence
senator lee yep might just weigh in here
i i totally understand the concern that
you're describing relative to the
confidential nature of pre-sentence
reports as a prosecutor and as a law
clerk i
reviewed those with some regularity i
understand the sensitivity of them
let me suggest a couple of things first
of all it's not unusual for us as a
committee and as members of the united
states senate to review materials that
would be inappropriate for public
release i don't think one of us is
suggesting that
um the there are means by which we can
review things in a classified
environment and treat them as classified
we've done that with
with with significant success in this
hearing secondly
to the extent that wouldn't provide the
level of comfort necessary we'd also be
happy to review them on a redacted basis
um
these are things that have become
relevant in our conversations we want to
make sure that we we have the facts but
not one of us wants to endanger anyone
or to to
render public information
that is sensitive in nature there are
abundant ways around that
i would suggest that the information
contained in these reports is dangerous
dangerous to the victims and to the
innocent people who were mentioned in
these reports and unnecessary at this
point
it's never been requested by this
committee
and it's merely a fishing expedition in
dangerous territory
classified settings redacted versions of
the reports
this has never happened in the history
of this committee and i would say
senator senator i will just tell you
i am not going to be party to turning
over this information and endangering
the life of an innocent person
for a political quest to find more
information we have exhausted this topic
and we've gone to it over and over again
and i think that this is a bridge too
far for this committee that's my
personal feeling i take it to senator
leahy may agree with me and that reward
this uh nominee has been before this
committee for 18 hours
i don't believe that this information is
going to change anyone's vote
uh you can decide in your caucus what
you want to do to go forward i've told
you my position i want to proceed if i
can i thank the senator the nominee for
waiting for this
colloquy and i turn it over to senator
cotton
judge i want to return to the question
of crime and specifically sentencing
what a shock any of the cases where
you've sentenced an offender below the
guidelines has that offender gone on to
commit another crime
after getting released from prison
thank you senator um
when judge's
sentence they
often impose terms of supervised release
and there are times in which when a
person is on supervised release
they
re-offend are also times when
um when they don't but even after the
period after the period of supervised
release the court doesn't continue to
have any way of
uh tracking or knowing what happens
um because if they were to reoffend it
wouldn't necessarily come back to the
same
court or the same judge
so you don't have a factual basis to
know whether or not anyone you've
sentenced below the guidelines has
reoffended in the future well a fair
question would be do the people sentence
below guidelines re-offend at a greater
rate and they don't want to touch that
question people who have reoffended
while unsupervised release i can't
remember whether any of them were
guideline sentences below guidelines or
above guideline sentences okay
um i know you've answered a lot of
questions
the last two days about sentences and
sex crimes
i just want to be exact about this in
these cases have you ever sentenced an
offender above the guidelines
recommendation
um
i'd have to take a look at i know that i
have sentenced
offenders to the guidelines if in the
category of sex crimes in general i know
that i've given 30-year sentences for um
at least one offender almost 30 years
29.5 i've given
um i believe a 12-year sentence for
someone at the agreement of all of the
parties
which was
a sentence that
was
a part of his plea agreement obviously
the reason this is such a big topic is
these types of cases
sex crimes come before the supreme court
all the time right
oh wait hold on a second
wesley hawkins as a reminder was
convicted of child a child pornography
offense in 2013. the sentencing
guidelines for this offense called for a
sentence of 97 to 121 months
or 8-10 years
the prosecutors asked for 24 months you
sentenced him
to three months
we've heard a lot about
this case and your three-month sentence
of wesley hawkins
but you got another crack at him
in 2019 judge
in 2019 you sent wesley hawkins
back under conditions of confinement
with the bureau of prisons for six
months
with additional restrictions on his
computer usage
that's twice the amount of time in
custody that you sent us into in 2013.
what did wesley hawkins do in 2019 judge
oh i don't remember
senator i have a lot of
defendants who i've
sentenced
who are on supervision who violate
conditions of supervision
if in our system um
someone like mr hawkins especially given
the crime the egregious crime that he
committed was likely on a very long
period of supervision
and during that time he
would likely be
under computer restrictions for 10 20
years or something where he's not
allowed to do
certain things with a computer
and
a probation officer is monitoring they
put software on the computers of
individuals who are
who have these kinds of conditions
imposed
and
that restricts their ability to access
certain information on the internet and
so
it's not uncommon for a probation
officer to
report
violations of supervised release not
just in this area but across
all crimes and then the court um has to
determine
how to handle that and you could in fact
send someone back to jail for
violating conditions of supervised
release that are not themselves criminal
behavior it's just you know the court
says in their supervision
order
um i'm imposing a 20-year whatever it is
uh sentence of supervision and during
this time you're not allowed to
access your computer etc etc so if he
were to do that it wouldn't be
additional criminal behavior but it
would be a violation of my order
and when he comes back
to the court on violation the court has
factors that we look at to determine
whether or not to treat that uh
essentially tom cotton have two black
eyes of violation that would require him
to go back to jail okay judge yesterday
we had an extended conversation of your
sentencing of a man named keith hodges a
fentanyl kingpin that sentencing
occurred in 2018 you had
very
detailed recall of that sentence
to my knowledge that's the only time
anyone's asked you about mr hodges
sentence you've been asked repeatedly
over the last two days about the hawkins
case it's been in the news as senator
durbin decided for
days on end
this sentencing happened re-sentencing
happened in 2019
and now you're saying you don't have any
recollection of it let me see if i can
refresh your recollection
okay
this is the order you signed
judge on
april 17 2019 kinko's owners making a
killing during these years
to return him to residential reentry
facility for 180 days
and to engage in various kinds of commun
computer monitoring
and computer computer monitoring and
search there's your signature over there
judge you really don't you really don't
remember
senator that is a very very common thing
that judges do i've sentenced over 100
people
and supervised release which is the kind
of post-incarceration
condition that judges
ordinarily impose
is something that's done on a standard
form which is what that is i understand
you've done a lot judge but none of them
have been the centerpiece
of your hearing for the last two days do
you really do you really expect this
committee to believe that you don't
remember
what happened
in this hawkins case when it came back
before you yes are you accusing me of
lying senator do you believe that's my
testimony i don't find it credible judge
it's been in the news for days senator
durbin decided it being in the news for
days
you've been asked about it probably more
than any other case you've ever had
and the centerpiece of their case
against her is a guy who had what what
was it two kilos of drugs prepared
for that
matter in 2019 you know i think
i think he got caught with child
pornography again and he wouldn't have
if he had been in prison for the eight
to ten years the guidelines called for
in 2013 when he first sentenced him
that's not a question let's turn though
to your work for detainees at yeah smart
not to even say a word
first off let me just ask
do you think most detainees at
guantanamo bay were mostly terrorists
she's not reviewed those cases no
innocent goat farmers can't can't say
senator it's impossible for me to answer
that question the people at guantanamo
bay had been
accused by the government of engaging in
terrorist activities and therefore
classified
by the executive branch as
um enemy combatants okay do you think it
would america would be
safer or less safe if we released all
the detainees what could she say without
reviewing the cases
senator
i'm i'm
trying to figure out how to answer that
question um because it's absurd
9 11 was a terrible attack on our
country and the
executive branch
pursuant to authority that the supreme
court said it had
designated people as enemy combatants
and
um
sent them to guantanamo bay the supreme
court also
said that anybody who was so detained
could seek
review of their detention and as a
federal public defender
my
role and responsibility
was to
um make arguments
in defense of the constitution and
in service to the court that was trying
to assess
based on the authority given to it by
the supreme court whether or not
people were
adequately classified what the legal
circumstances were how these habeas
petitions were going to be
processed this was a series of um
a series of legal
challenges in a novel environment that
federal public defenders and lawyers
across the country
were engaged in
helping the court to evaluate so that we
can understand
what the constitution required in this
time of emergency judge does it matter
how many sexual images of goats the
guantanamo detainees have the detainees
from guantanamo bay senator america
would be less safe if we don't have
terrorists
out
running around
attacking this country absolutely
america would also
be
more safe
in a situation in which
all of our constitutional rights are
protected this is the way our scheme
works this is how
the constitution
that we all love
um operates it's it's about making sure
that the government is
doing what it's supposed to do
in a time of crisis you've got to charge
them at some point
the constitution is not suspended in
times of crisis the government still has
to follow the rules and so
criminal defense lawyers make sure
that in times of crisis the government
is following the rules okay let's turn
to the actual cases um how many of these
terrorists at guantanamo bay
did you represent
when i was a defender um
what happened to alleged right i mean
guys are they
do we have due process i thought
republicans were for it
but um she personally had four
i was assigned to them along with
another
defender who worked on the same cases
she was more senior she did a lot of she
did all of the sort of fact
uh gathering related to the cases and as
an appellate defender i worked on the
legal argument okay did you ever
represent uh any of the detainees at
guantanamo bay when you were not a
public defender
one of the people who i'd represented
while i was in a federal defender
his case
got
spun off and taken up by
a law firm law firms around the country
were also engaged in this work i'm well
aware of my law firms were doing at the
time
and
i left the federal public defender's
office i joined a law firm
and
the one of the people that i had
represented
was now at that law firm they had him as
a client that's mr al salwan
coincidentally both he and you went to
morrison and forrester yes senator okay
what about mr al salwan
i don't know what happened to mr al
salam you were listed as counsel for two
years during your time at morrison in
forester
what happens is when you leave um
when you leave
from
any place firms or government service
you have to let the court know or their
records
their records reflect where you are in
the system and not so much the case in
terms of your address so
to go back to mr alcatani's yes he so he
just coincidentally to small world
went to morrison and forrester same time
you did and then you represented him and
you did file multiple motions on his
behalf
so i don't know if it was at the same
time i'm not sure what you did follow
multiple motions for him
2008 2009.
i don't recall whether it was multiple
but he was still at the habeas stage of
the process
and i don't know when he came because
the partners who picked up the case were
in los angeles i was in washington d.c
they contacted me to say
oh we see on the docket that you had
previously represented him and now
you're with our firm will you
assist us um with
um looking at these briefs working on
these briefs there were many lawyers who
were working on uh the filings that
you're talking about
after you left the public defender's
office
did you continue in your representation
of any other client you had had at the
public defender's office
i didn't continue my representation of
any client i left the federal public
defender's office and then picked up mr
alcatani
through the circumstances that i talked
about and there were no other clients
that um i represented in that way i have
to say that sounds like continuation you
represented him at the public defender's
office and then you represented him in
private practice as well who cares and
you're telling us that's the only person
you represented at both the public
defender's office
and in private practice um yes
so you didn't continue to provide any
kind of pro bono work for
murderers or rapists or anyone else but
you did continue to represent this
terrorist at guantanamo bay alleged
right when i got to the firm and they
told me that the case was there and they
recognized that i was at the firm and
had previously worked on the case and by
they i mean the partners in the firm
they asked me um as a member of the
supreme court appellate group of the
firm which is where
what was my practice
if i
would help review and work on some of
the briefing that they were submitting
so for people for normal people in the
chat who are like what difference does
it make
what tom cotton is trying to suggest is
that she has a soft spot for gitmo
terrorists and she went out of her way
to continue representing one when she
went into private practice that's the
point he wants to make
briefs uh you had two briefs in
guantanamo cases one for a think tank
one on behalf of a group of former
judges
i think as anyone who's done amicus
worse work no sometimes the client seek
out the lawyer sometimes the lawyer seek
out the client um
for either of those amicus briefs were
you involved in any way in seeking or
recruiting those clients or suggesting
the idea for an amicus brief in the
first place
no senator
were both of those briefs done on a pro
bono basis
um
yes because the supreme court and
appellate group in a law firm
has paid clients and also has pro bono
clients
the briefs that i worked on um were
on the one brief was
20 former federal judges who wanted to
make an argument in the bhumidian case
that was in the supreme court and one of
them
was a partner at my law firm she was a
former federal judge whose idea it was
and she knew the other judges and wanted
our group to work on the brief the other
was um not just one think tank it was
the cato institute the rutherford
institute and
the constitution project i don't even
think we know whether she likes beer at
this point who wanted to make
arguments in
another case that the supreme court had
taken up related to these issues because
all of this was novel
and a lot of issues were being
evaluated by the supreme court regarding
the scope of executive authority during
this time of crisis okay so you've done
pro bono work for on behalf of detainees
at guantanamo bay have you ever done pro
bono work for the victims of terrorism
senator i'm not
aware of any such
cases in um
in my law firm i was
in a group
of lawyers
that was often approached to ask
would you file a brief
for some group and i'm not aware that
any victims of terrorism
uh asked our firm to participate so
we've talked a lot about the people you
represent let's talk a little bit about
the defendants in those cases and how
you characterize them
i'll remind you those were the president
the secretary of defense and active duty
army officers senator graham and senator
cornyn said that you called them war
criminals you disputed that and senator
durbin is repeatedly denied it as well
now guys fact check she wrote a brief
that had i think it was a dozen
arguments on behalf of her client one of
which said that he had been the victim
of war crime so that's a little bit
different than saying george w bush is a
war criminal although it would have been
accurate it's just not what she did and
saying they've committed acts that
constitute war crimes so right can you
explain that difference to me yes
thank you for the opportunity um
so when you file a habeas petition under
our law
um you can't
file it
um against the united states because of
of sovereign immunity the way our law
works you have to file it against
individual officers in their official
capacity that's
the
way in which you're able to file a
habeas petition so whoever
is the executive at the time becomes the
named party in the brief and a habeas
petition is like a complaint in a civil
case it's making allegations
um to begin
the litigation about the person's
detention tom cotton's really getting
schooled here huh capacity personal
capacity all that is just a bunch of
procedural gobbledygook these are the
people that you said committed acts that
constitute war crimes with respect i
just don't understand the difference
between calling someone a war criminal
and saying they committed acts that
constitute war crimes with respect
senator
they were not sued in their individual
capacity we weren't making allegations
about those individuals and in fact over
the course of the case
the names changed so
later on the habeas petition became
against
president obama because he then became
oh the executive for the purpose of the
habeas petition i'm well aware that the
name
probably changed from bob gates or from
don rumsfeld to bob gates as well but
they were not the ones in office they
were not the ones who are overseeing
the government he's not this stupid he
understands this there's no way
i just don't i don't understand how you
oh he says he does he to believe there's
a difference between saying someone's a
war criminal and saying they committed
war crimes thank you for the opportunity
to explain senator one of the
allegations that
[Music]
had been publicly reported with respect
to the group of people who were in
guantanamo bay was an allegation
concerning the use of torture
how can you not understand there's a
difference between
uh attorney
kitanji brown jackson saying here are my
clients 12 claims one of which is that
he was tortured which is a war crime and
i attorney katanji brown jackson say
bush is a war criminal
how does anyone not understand that in
belief
mr alcatani was tortured
allegation is made under a law that
says that
there was a war crime that occurred as a
result of that torture and anyone
and you're making that allegation
against the united states but because
you can't sue the united states the
actual petition
is named in the name of whoever's
leading the united states at the time so
later in this the course of this it
moved from
president bush donald rumsfeld to
president obama it didn't it's not about
the individual it's about the allegation
that um
that mr alcatani yeah the u.s military
and intelligent whoever did the torture
right
while bush was president tortured me
that's the allegation from her client
dance on the head of the pen to me
thank you senator cotton's a [ __ ] ask
unanimous consent to enter a letter in
the record from nine former national
security officials uh defending judge
jackson's guantanamo representation the
signatories include
former attorney general loretta lynch
department of homeland security
secretary jay johnson and the former
judge advocate general of the united
states navy
senator booker uh thank you very much
judge
after me only five to go
but sit back for a second because uh i
don't have questions right away i
actually have a number of things i just
want to say because
this has been uh not a surprise
given the history that we all know not a
surprise but
uh perhaps a little bit of a
disappointment uh some of the things
have been said in in this hearing
uh the way you have dealt with some of
these things
um that's why you are a judge and i am a
politician because you have sat with
grit and grace
and have shown us
just extraordinary uh demeanor
uh during the times where people were
saying things to you that are actually
out of the norm i had to go up dice uh
to ask them of my more senior colleagues
about that what i feel like is a
dangerous precedent
people are taking uh a thousand cases
you've been over is that right i'm sorry
i said you wouldn't ask you questions
but just give me a s something like that
something like that and from what i
understand is that these cases are often
takes take days weeks sometimes months
right to
to decide
yeah yeah yes there's a trial sometimes
and that folks are taking any of those
cases and just trying to pick pieces out
and so uh my my colleague senator hawley
has been doing this all into the lead-up
and saying things tweeting things that i
think that a lot of us when i was just
trying to get some advice here is this
is what the new standard is gonna be
that any judge coming before us
that has ever chosen outside of the
sentencing guidelines below the
sentencing guidelines we're creating
this environment now where i could make
myself the hero
of people who have been victims of some
horrible crime and suddenly put whatever
judge i want on the defensive by trying
to drag out little bits when they have
no context to the case right
none of the facts
they're seeking to exploit
the complexities
of a criminal justice system the reason
why we have a third branch of government
i i feel bad that there was a judge
mentioned by name in this hearing that's
from senator hawley's state
what is that judge gonna think next time
they they have a complicated sexual
abuse case that comes before them
and they know that they could possibly
be called out if they go below the
sentencing guidelines which i showed you
yesterday in my lack of chart if you
remember i was uncharted
um
but that you are deciding completely in
the norm
70 plus percent in many states or people
are doing just like you did
but i'm i'm a democratic senator i i i
i've never quoted from this
very well-respected conservative
a periodical this is the national review
very well respected they're not not
necessarily something i agree with all
the time
but here's what the national review this
is the title senator hawley's
disingenuous attack against judge
jackson's record on child pornography
i'll just read the first paragraph
i would oppose
judge kachan
brown jackson because of her judicial
philosophy for the reasons i outlined
last week
i addressed that in a separate post for
now i want to just discuss the claim
by senator josh hawley
that judge jackson is appallingly soft
on child pornography offenders this is
the kicker here the allegations appear
meritless to the point of demagoguery
i i
i got letters from
leaders
of victims rights groups
survivors
of assault
all
saying sort of the same thing with the
national review feel proud about
yourself you brought together right and
left in this
in this in this
calling out
of people that will sit up here
and try to pull out from cases
and try to put themselves in a position
where they're the defenders
of our children
to a person who has children
to a person whose family
goes out in streets and defends children
i i mean this is a new new low and
what's especially surprising about this
is it didn't happen last year
you were put on a court that i'm told is
that
considered like the second most powerful
court in our land and you were passed
with bipartisan support
nobody brought it up then
did they not do their homework
were they lax did they make a mistake i
wonder as they ask you the question do
you regret i wonder if they regret that
that they didn't bring that out no why
because it was an allegation that is
meritless to the point
of demagoguery
you are i don't mean this in any way
because if anybody called me average i
would
i would be upset but you are
a mainstream judge
your sentencing i've looked at the data
falls in the mainstream on everything
from child sexual assault to all the
other issues that people are trying to
bring up
some of these things are being cast at
you that you call george bush a war
criminal come on that is painful
especially because as you said the brief
change these are names that you have to
put in and we were talking about a real
issue that goes to the core of our
values torture
barack obama was named once he was bush
left office
there is an absurdity to this that is
it it is almost comical if it was not so
dangerous
right
because the next time a judge comes
before us on the right or the left that
has a body of work like you do gosh one
of the uh some performance artists on
our side
could pull out
one of the cases where they were below
the sentencing guidelines say for
example it was on something like as
horrific as rape that we all agree is
horrific
and they can suddenly put themselves as
the how dare we put someone who's soft
on crime well are you soft on crime god
bless america
i got this great text i've become really
good friends with the folks at the fop
for my negotiations and this was my
favorite text you all got to get this i
think my brother kennedy might get a
kick out of this he goes things that are
uncountable stars in the sky
grains of sand on the beach
and the number of times democrats will
mention that the fop endorsed judge
jackson in this hearing
[Laughter]
but let me mention it again
just in case my people say you're rough
on crime folks really want to try to
make that stick
you were endorsed by the largest
organization of rank-and-file police
officers
you were endorsed by the bosses the
largest organization of chiefs of police
and and you were endorsed by noble who i
hope people find out more about that
organization
you got uncles that are officers you got
a brother not just an officer who went
to serve
after 9 11
your family's not soft on terrorism he
went out there to capture
and kill and defend this country from
terrorists
i i i actually sitting back here and
finding this astonishing but then
i i do my homework
i i love that my colleague brought up
constance baker motley
do you know when when when she was
getting to the floor of the senate
they were trying to stop her with
outrageous accusations you know what the
accusation was back then she was a
communist
dragging up stories trying to throw
anything that they might stick but this
is what you and i know
any one of us senators could yell as
loud as we want that venus
can't return a serve we can yell as loud
as we want that beyonce
can't sing
we could yell as much as we want that
astronaut mae jameson didn't go all that
high
but you know what
they got nothing to prove
as it says in the bible let the work
i've done speak for me
well you have spoken
you started speaking as a little girl
watching that man right there
try to raise a family and study law
while your mama
supported everybody you may cry again
you spoke in high school when you
started distinguishing yourself and you
know what you said when they told you
you couldn't go to harvard
watch me
i went to law school i didn't serve on
the law review you did
i didn't clerk at every level of the
federal court you clerked for a supreme
court justice one widely respected on
both sides which really shaped you
you left there and and and you went to
private practice and you know what you
found this is what you told me
that you had those tough choices that
working moms have to make the demands of
a private law firm raising your kids it
just didn't add up
you went before the senate three
times in a bipartisan manner god bless
america we don't do that much stuff
bipartisan round here
you went to became a public defender
because you wanted to understand all
aspects of the law who does that
we live in a society that's very
materialistic sometimes very very
consumeristic you went to do people
become public defenders for the money
no
your family and you speak to service
service service
and i'm telling you right now i'm not
letting anybody in the senate steal my
joy
i told you this at the beginning
i i have i i'm embarrassed
it happened earlier today i just look at
you and i i start getting full of
emotion
i'm jogging this morning
and i'm at the end of the block i live
on
and i get because i put my music on loud
when i'm jogging trying to block out the
noise of the of the heart attack i'm
having
and this woman comes up on me
practically tackles me an
african-american woman
and the look on her eyes she just wanted
to touch me because i think because i'm
sitting so close to you
and tell me what it meant to her to
watch you sitting where you're sitting
i don't think this is cringy at all guys
i i i genuinely don't he's very very
good here agenda
he didn't get here because of some dark
money groups
you got here how every black woman in
america has gotten anywhere has done
by being
like ginger roger said
i did everything fred astaire did but
backwards in heels
and and so i i'm just sitting here
saying nobody's stealing my droid
nobody's gonna make me angry especially
not people that are called in a
conservative magazine
demagogic
for what they're bringing up that just
doesn't hold water i'm not gonna let my
joy be stolen because i know you and i
we appreciate something that we get that
a lot of my colleagues don't i know tim
scott does
when i first came to this place i was
the fourth black person ever popularly
elected to the united states senate i
still remember
a lot of mixed people white folks black
folks work here but at night when people
are in line to come in to clean this
place
the the percentage of minorities shift a
lot and so i'm walking here first week
i'm here and somebody who's been here
for decades doing the
urgent work of the senate but the
unglamorous work that goes on no matter
who's in offices the guy comes up to me
and all he wants to say i can tell is
i'm so happy you're here but he comes up
and he can't get the words out and this
man
my elder starts crying
and i just hugged him and he just kept
telling me it is so good to see you here
it's so good to see you here thank you
thank you thank you
i i love my brother tim scott we could
write a dissertation on our
disagreements he gave the best speech on
race i wish i could have given his
speech good of a speech
but talking to the challenges and
indignities that are still faced
and you're here
i was in the white house with my
democratic colleagues and i'm again i'm
in my joy i can't help it
and and the president's asking our
advice who should we nominate or
whatever
and
i look at kamala and we have a knowing
glance which we've had for years when
she and i used to sit on this end of
this committee at times
and then i try to get out to the
president what it means
what it means
and i want to tell you when i look at
you this is why i get emotional
i'm sorry you're you're you're a person
that is so much more than your race and
gender you're a christian you're a mom
you're you're you're an intellect you're
loved books but for me i'm sorry i i
it's hard for me not to look at you and
not see my mom
not to see my
my cousins one of them who had to come
here and sit behind you
she had to be she had to have your back
i see my ancestors and yours
nobody's gonna steal the joy of that
woman in the street or the calls that
i'm getting or the texts nobody's gonna
steal that joy
you have earned this spot you are worthy
you are a great american
your hero is constance baker motley mine
she has sat on my desk
for my offices that i've held she's my
icon of america her name is harriet
tubman
there is a love in this country that is
extraordinary
you admitted it about your parents
they loved this nation even though there
were laws preventing them
from getting together when they were
loving there were laws in this country
that would have prevented you from
marrying your husband it wasn't that
long ago it was last generation true
but they didn't stop loving this country
even though this country
didn't love them back
and what were the words of your heroes
in mind what did constance baker motley
do
did she this country that she saw
insults and injuries when she came out
of law school law firms wouldn't even
hire her because she was a woman
did she become bitter
did she try to create a revolution no
she used the very constitution of this
nation
she loved it so much she wanted america
to be
america as langston hughes wrote oh let
america be america again
the land that never has been yet but yet
must be the land where everyone is free
oh yes i say it plain america never was
america to me but i swear this oath
america will be
that is the story of how you got to this
desk
you and i and everyone here generations
of folk who came here
and said america i'm irish you may say
no irish or dogs need to apply but i'm
going to show this country
that i can be free here i can make this
country love me as much as i love it
chinese americans first forced into mere
slave labor building our railroads
connecting our country
saw the ugliest of america but they were
going to build their home here and say
america you may not love me yet but i'm
going to make this nation live up to its
promise and hope
lgbtq americans
from stonewall women to seneca
hidden figures who didn't even get their
play until some hollywood movie finally
talked about them and how they were
critical for us defying gravity all of
these people loved america and so you
faced insults here that were shocking to
me well actually not shocking
but you are here because of that kind of
love
and nobody's taken this away from me
so you got five more folk to go through
five more of us
and then you can sit back and let us
have all the debates and i'm gonna tell
you it's gonna be a well-charted senate
floor because it's not gonna stop
they're gonna accuse you of this and
that heck in honor of your
person who shares your birthday you
might be called a communist
but don't worry
my sister
don't worry
god has got you
and how do i know that
because you're here
and i know what it's taken for you to
sit in that seat
harry tubman
is one of my heroes because
the more i read about this person the
more
i mean she was viciously beaten
her whole life she used to fall into
spells cracked skull
she faced starvation chased by dogs
and when she got to freedom what did she
do did she rest know she went back
again and again and again
the star was the sky was full of stars
but she found one that was a harbinger
of hope
for better days not just for her
and those people that were enslaved but
a harbinger of hope for this country and
she never gave up on america she fought
in the
led troops in the civil war
she was involved in the suffrage
movement
and as i came back from my run
after being near assaulted by a
by someone on the street
i thought about her
and how she looked up she kept looking
up no matter what they did to her she
never stopped looking up
and that star
it was a harbinger of hope
today you're my star
you are my harbinger of hope
this country is getting better and
better and better
and when that final vote
happens
and you ascend onto the
under the highest court in the land
i'm gonna rejoice
and i'm gonna tell you right now
the greatest country in the world the
united states of america
will be better
because of you
thank you
wow thank you senator booker we're going
to take a 10-minute break wow cory
booker i have the last five senators ask
their questions
so five times 20 about a hundred minutes
to go that's an hour and 40 minutes if
they take a 10-minute break six i mean
it looks like about 7 40 to 8 o'clock
roughly
is uh when they will be done a very very
interesting day i liked cory booker's uh
speech
um
i uh i thought i thought it was good
yeah i liked it
thank you to queen janey for the raid
earlier
very much uh appreciate that there is
uh
a break in the chamber
cory booker
hugging someone i don't i can't tell who
it is
oh this is just judge jackson's parents
it looks like yeah
very very interesting day
thanks to mac lubber for the twitch
prime subscription i appreciate that
this is the so my understanding is this
is the last day of questions tomorrow
there's going to be a i think it's a
couple witnesses who will just be sort
of singing the praises of judge jackson
i don't plan to cover that we have a lot
going on tomorrow a lot to film a lot of
different things
ethan said about the cory booker speech
he gives me vibes like he belongs on the
cast of saturday night live in a good
way with his energy or like a
motivational speaker he's very smart and
seems genuine he seems very very genuine
my brother actually ran into cory booker
at an airport once and chatted with him
a little and that was his reaction
extremely genuine like him hate him
whatever just um
just genuine it is what it is he just he
is he's not pretending to be something
else
uh other than other than what he is so
very very interesting
um
approach i believe that that's senator
alex padilla that he's hugging is that
right can people confirm i think that
that's who it is
anybody know anybody remember
yes it is okay
good a lot of people really liking it
okay
um
there's dick durbin and uh it's just a
brief 10-minute break and man people
just really seem to like that let's get
to a few voicemails that have come in i
will continue to thank uh people who
sign up and support the stream we are
now into hour five
of today's stream and overall i believe
we are into hour 24
of streams just since monday since all
of this
started um just a few voicemails that
came in here in the last few minutes hey
david this is nick brengel
really really enjoy your stuff been
following you for a couple years i guess
now um anyway i just wanted to throw out
a term that i use on a regular basis
it's called america on its knees and in
situations like this as we watch
uh perfectly um you know just an
individual like judge jackson who has
been an upright citizen and and just has
been
uh
stood by all the you know principles and
and her work ethic but yet people like
ted cruz who unfortunately i've met
before as slimy and gross as he is it's
just another instance of america on his
knees thank you david well said very
nice voicemail i mean that that's sort
of the perfect voicemail i mean you've
got 46 seconds
nick
introduces himself
gets right to the topic concise pithy i
mean a very very solid voicemail just
really doing all the things a good
voicemail will do
um here's another voicemail that just
came in
sir my apologies for my
abhorrent
phone connection yesterday i think my
pillow is sitting my phone so
may i ask if you please play some of 80
bryant from snl as ted cruz after this
because
this is snl is very very aggressive with
copyright so i don't know that i want to
do that right now
um our friend juan has called in again
he's the one who called earlier about
trans bathrooms and made no sense
hey david swann
i'm going to try to be critical thinking
okay
so republicans
are against immigrants from the southern
border
because they believe that
the democrats
are
for them
immigrating
in order to gain votes correct
uh listen um
we're already struggling here juan um
i don't know about those so according to
them the only reason democrats are
letting
uh immigrants come and seek asylum and
all that and are so pro-immigrant
is for votes
okay well
here's my critical
thinking being anti-immigrant
would not help republicans get both
either
maybe if republicans were pro-immigrant
they would shift the balance of the boat
in favor of republicans
their logic doesn't seem to make sense
if you want
immigrants to vote republican you need
to be pro-immigrant
stop the replacement theory
stop this
with some call
uh inhumane
uh
practices of the southern border et
cetera
i'd like to hear your thoughts
anybody know what juan is talking about
what is he saying
he's saying the republican party should
welcome immigrants to try to win by
convincing them to vote for republicans
is that i guess what he's saying i don't
know
jay bundy says after my internship with
cory booker he threw a pizza party for
me pizza is here got me personalized
gift
and always provides letters of support
100 genuine guy yeah that's what i hear
from everybody who knows cory booker
couple others
it's been suggested that trump might try
to flee the country like to russia to
avoid prosecution i don't think he'd be
able to with the secret service
following him around plus he wouldn't be
very close to any of his golf courses to
play golf
right no i think that that's an
absolutely fair point he would have to i
don't know how much golf there is in in
russia
whitney also called in while we were
listening to cory booker
so
um
[Music]
what i don't understand is like
uh
just exactly
what america is doing over there because
i'm like where
i don't like understand like why
it's our problem same with like latvia
it's like yeah sure like i'll send like
you know some veterans out there
like we're gonna kill themselves anyways
so
that's cool that's the people i train
and it's like well
you know you're like
about to die so
you know there's definitely some a
little bit of longevity there you know
where you can
have some fun before
you have to go
but um as far as our troops and stuff
i'm just like why do you like wasting
people
when it's like
they're gonna have people like me
have to join the army so some [ __ ]
white trash can get like
a [ __ ] promotion when it's like they
don't usually use people like me because
i'm just like flying right underneath
the radar anybody know what whitney's
talking about does anybody have any idea
what she's talking about
like i don't even know this general is
the subject the military is it russia
i don't know
like
you know making myself look like just a
little bit more attractive
just like
a little bit smaller but they were like
well it doesn't matter you know like
i'll just fudge it you know just to
get the numbers up i want to get a
promotion when it's like i have had a
daughter
and it's like
oh
like why you just want to get white
trash promotion so it's like well we're
trying to do justice to listening to an
entire voicemail to see if we know
anything about what it's about
you know
handle from one [ __ ] people that look
sort of kind of like asian
when it's like oh boy
well those people aren't going to be
around very much anymore to uh
help some [ __ ] white trash get
promoted into
whatever
because he's like a [ __ ] obviously
you know
a white supremacist or whatever
but
it seems to be winding down i saw him
talking to people you know like why
don't you get some of your friends on
board
you know have them go fight
but it's like this lazy [ __ ] trash
for nothing gets to just like sit around
and loaf and watch [ __ ] tv all day
like
what the [ __ ]
would
does any of this [ __ ] make sense like
why why would i want white trash to get
promoted when they obviously like
you know don't want me to have a [ __ ]
life
that's a full whitney voicemail and i
have to tell you i don't know what she's
talking about i i genuinely don't know
what that was about we we sometimes
people say david the reason it's unclear
is you don't listen to the whole thing
if you listen to all of it then you'll
understand it but i don't understand it
i don't
dereten says you could fill a book with
what whitney doesn't know they're called
encyclopedias okay well said
um also thanks to makalani kenyatta for
the
youtube
membership
i very much appreciate that all right
we'll be we're back momentarily with
with uh senator kennedy which i don't
want to miss i'm going to refill my
water and we will be back very very soon
all right welcome back everybody i don't
want to be alarmist and i don't want to
be insensitive
but i think it should be mentioned that
justice clarence thomas
is still gone from the court and as you
know he was hospitalized last week with
something we were told
um
is not covered
and i believe it i mean he's been given
antibiotics and you don't give
antibiotics for covet unless you know
yeah i mean some people were like take a
zythromycin but you know we don't in
general doctors are not giving
antibiotics for covid
and justice clarence thomas is still
gone from the court today now initially
the whole attitude was he's fine he's
expected to be released within one or
two days that was what we heard on
friday i believe it was
it's now wednesday
and so we
hope that he recovers and you know all
of it
i think we also have to mention that um
you know five days in the hospital six
days and it's it starts to become
significant and uh clara how old is
clarence thomas he is
73 oh i for some reason i thought he was
older um
so
it's i mean i don't know what we're to
make of it but it's just there's a
there's a there's a supreme court
justice that
has been in the hospital for five going
on six days
okay i mean i don't that's that's it
that's all we know that's the that's the
whole story i want to say thank you to
alex neat alex neat just made a pledge
on patreon or patreon
and we are counting patreon pledges
double today so that puts us at 35
i would encourage you i would encourage
you
consider making a patreon pledge i also
have some really exciting news one of
the things i take very seriously on this
show is when people in the audience make
good faith bona fide suggestions
i investigate them i take them seriously
earlier the suggestion was made you've
really got to set up a way to gift
subscriptions on your website i reached
out
to um the
company that makes the system we use for
managing memberships they wrote me back
and they said hi david we have a gifting
add-on that is new
or new as some people say i say new some
people say new
i like the liquid you
we have a gifting add-on that's new that
you can install to allow for gifting it
is usually only available with the pro
plan but since you have been a loyal
customer for years i will send you a
copy
um
beautiful so let's see gifting add-on
let's see how it all works
okay set up a membership for gifting
once you have a membership created you
can go in
and check the box check the box allow
this membership to be gifted beautiful
then update the settings and you will
now have the option to offer it as a
gift
you can check is this oh it adds a
little is this a gift button beautiful
you fill out the info and you check the
box and then it'll send an email to the
recipient
it will then create a coupon
for the form oh that's brilliant
oh wow this is great you know what we
will be able to do
wow this is beautiful so there will be
two things that can be done
one thing is we'll be able to set it up
where if you want to gift a membership
to a specific person
you can type in the recipient right so
like say you know remember my fake
character
uh diego sala bumbersmith from the front
calls anyway it doesn't matter so like
if you know my friend diego wants a
membership you can type in their email
address but
i see people saying you've got to allow
it to be random we can do that we can do
that
we can set it up so that you can go in
and if you want to gift it to someone
random we can set up like random at
davidpakman.com
it'll generate the code and then we'll
fulfill it on the back end we can just
say do you does anybody want a
membership
fill out this form request a membership
this way
we'll generate the codes when people say
i want to gift it to random
and then we'll just send people here's a
code here's a code here's a code here's
the code i love it
i love it uh people are asking for the
gifts right now okay it's not set up yet
we're gonna set it up okay we're gonna
set it up i love this this is fantastic
this is absolutely fantastic
what a gift
what a gift
um
okay all right while we wait a couple
more voicemails have come in
david pakman sir i've been a long time
listener huge fan
i love your live streams this week
we need to get a
compilation
or an interview between whitney
and mike pillow
that would be groundbreaking i agree
thank you sir that would be great we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines
okay here's another one that came in
so i was just watching this video about
like donald trump using the n-word and
stuff
about how he's saying putin's this
horrible person you know killing
thousands of people every day
now we should be stopped i like that
like i remember like a week ago a week
or two ago donald trump was saying that
putin was like military masterminds yeah
like
you know just like praising the dude now
he's saying oh
you know
it was an awful person just killing
millions of people this is
and people are still like
praising this man like saying he's oh
he's like the new the next coming of
jesus christ he's going to save our
country but like really he's gonna tell
our country those [ __ ] russians you
know right
okay very good i'm being asked about
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii being
banned from twitch is that is that true
was stephen banned from twitch
can anybody weigh in on that
sometimes people just trigger me about
things that didn't really happen but
it's not that funny
dylan burns tweeted that destiny was
banned
can confirm does anybody know why he was
banned from twitch
something happened to his twitter oh
well that's a different story
i don't i don't know anything about it
i'm asking you guys
destiny banned from twitch let's see
one hour ago oh there's articles about
it
twitch streamer destiny banned from
tvich
let's take a look
uh twitch streamer steven destiny
bonnell the second they've misspelled
benel
and i think he spells it with a v this
seems to be completely misspelled is
that right isn't it steven with a v and
bennell with two ends
and they don't even have his middle name
what what great journalism huh
uh twitch streamer steven destiny
bonnell ii
was banned from the platform wednesday
the reason for the ban as of this
writing
remains unknown
while the official reason is not known
and a twitter account he's associated
with use the n word
oh boy
yeah no no
i i'm not even not even going to get
involved there not even going to get
involved more interested in what senator
kennedy is going to say
and ask
we're down to five
if they started right now and had no
breaks in between senators we would be
done at 7 42 by my calculation
um but of course they haven't started
yet i'm guessing that it'll probably be
done closer to 8p east 5p west
8p east 5p west
would be my guess
[Music]
we are standing by here
let me see what else we've got
it has been it has been quite a few days
yeah it's it's been hectic very very
hectic the last few days
david
that voicemail guy that you and at the
end of your show the old white guy
his
he's got a chip on his shoulder it's not
about
what he feels you don't or do know about
government or democracy or whatever
his smug arrogance tells me everything i
need to know about where he's coming
from
and that he opened up his call calling
you a book voice trying to be derogatory
towards you yeah i consider book boy a
compliment quite frankly it's like what
reading's bad now what are you stupid
give me a break guys
hey dave it's adam from boise hey do you
think that
america
will
have a harder time
reacting to these rises of coven 19
cases around the world if it ends up
happening here and say you know god
forbid we have the worst
caseload we've ever had in the pandemic
given that it's a
election year
do you think it's a possibility that the
democrats are too afraid to enact even
math policies yeah i i do think that
there is a good point there which is i
believe in the eight months seven and a
half months that are left until the
election
i think democrats even if it is
warranted
by the science and the numbers i think
democrats will be very hesitant to
really enact any kind of serious
guidelines because i don't i think they
know it won't help them win i think that
that's
absolutely fair point
absolutely fair point very well said i
appreciate that
hi david
my question is about russia and ukraine
um as expected the failed one-term
president trump has been making his
rounds on right-wing media talking about
how things would be so much different if
he was president and recently he said
the reason for that is because nobody in
biden's administration knows how to talk
to putin because you know meaning that
he can talk to him when he knows how to
do it
so my question is i mean if he said a
direct line
you know to putin
and he's always said that he's the one
that can fix things
why isn't he fixing it i mean why isn't
he making gas prices better
you know why isn't he doing all these
things that he says he can do
fair yeah of course beautiful question
absolutely beautiful question
um
see what else i have for you guys
there's all these hidden you know sort
of diamonds in the rough
hey david i got into a car accident last
night i got t-boned at about 35 miles
per hour and my car's totaled and it's
all because of a damn nissan sentra
i think uh the united states senate
needs to pass a bill standing nissan
centres on the road
what do you think about that
um yeah i don't think that makes any
sense i don't know if the idea is to
make an analogy to guns but like the
point of cars and the point of guns is
very different
it's not a particularly uh
interesting
voicemail to me
uh maybe maybe he was hitting the head
in the accident i don't know it's not
making a lot of sense here all right
they are continuing here and we will
hear from senator kennedy which is going
to be pretty wild
committee will resume with senator
kennedy of louisiana
thank you mr chairman judge
judge i want to continue
where we left off yesterday
oh
and try to get if i can get to the
essence
of this tension between judicial
power and judicial restraint
um you have testified
and stopped me if i get this wrong that
judges
should stay in their lane
and i think it's fair to say that one of
your definitions of
staying in your lane is that judges
don't make policy
am i right so far yes that is correct
senator
then how do you explain
or help me understand
the following
we have a judicially created doctrine
with no textual basis either in the
constitution or a
statute call substantive due process
and through substantive due process
our federal courts
let's just
it down the united states supreme court
has given itself the authority
to read into the constitution
unenumerated
unmentioned
rights
not read the constitution and say well
there it is freedom of speech
but these are unmentioned
unenumerated
isn't that ex making policy
senator the supreme court interprets
provisions of the constitution
and
there are provisions of the constitution
if you believe that they're there
then by definition you're not making
policy the argument or the disagreement
would be are those unenumerated rights
really there
answer the question before the court so
due process
what what does that mean
and the supreme court has the words due
process do
um appear in the text of the
constitution and the question is
what what is covered by that provision
the supreme court oh sorry i'm just
gonna
but when they do it
aren't they making policy
well
senator um
the role of the judiciary is to
interpret the law
to the extent that somebody argues to
the court
um
that there's been a violation of the due
process clause of the constitution
it is within the role of the court
to determine
what that means whether the person is
correct that
what
happened with respect to their case
violated the due process clause and so
there's
an interpretive function
um that is a part of the judicial
function
here
let me see if i can put a finer point on
this um
senator could you speak more slowly i'm
having a hard time keeping up
it's it's how the right is created
so i asked you yesterday whether you
think that unenumerated
these unenumerated unmentioned rights
ought to be decided by the people
through their elected representatives
versus the the federal judiciary
let's take two rights that i talked
about yesterday the right to assisted
suicide
the right of a transgender woman to
participate in women's sports
um
i can see
how i'm not predicting that that it will
but i could see how the court
either through
the due process clause
or the ninth amendment
could
find those rights in the constitution
um as we talked about yesterday
uh the supreme court has looks to me
like they've adopted
the the the
the policy of there is no test for a
fundamental right
there are several tests
and in
obergefell
justice kennedy cited with approval
justice harlan's dissent in uh in po v
oldman which says
there's no test we go case by case
please proceed
but but i know there are tests like i'll
get the language here somewhere i've got
it i don't want to look it up but
implicit in the concept of ordered
liberty and you've talked about that
here's a new one that justice kennedy
talked about
in obergefell he said
inherit in the concept of individual
autonomy
well i can see how if the court with
five votes wanted to say
even though the right to assisted
suicide
or the right of a transgender woman to
participate in women's sports
i can see how somebody
you're smart you could write an opinion
and say that's
that's inherent in the concept of
individual autonomy
and and maybe
again it's not the right it's who's
supposed to decide
and that's where the judicial restraint
comes
in i mean don't you think
that the values of ordinary americans
and their ability to side these issues
are just as good as
those of
five members of the supreme court
thank you senator
there are
policy determinations that
are made by vote and
absolutely in the democratic process
people
get to decide things
the question and the difficulty
is when you have a constitutional
scheme of government and you have a
constitution that
um right does if the court believes
something is a right you don't put
rights up to popular vote
in
a circumstance in which th those rights
whatever they are enumerated or or not
are
um
might be things that the people
have disagreed with that's the tension
right that um
that although we have democracy as we do
and people vote
um and and should absolutely
um
we also have a constitution that
protects certain rights against the sort
of majority will about those things
but the rub of course is i agree with
everything you said but the rub is these
are unannounced uh unenumerated rights
they're
yes
um
and what troubles me
i'm not saying i disagree with all the
rights that the supreme court has
created
but i don't think we talk honestly
enough about how those rights
should be adjudicated for example i i'm
not asking you to comment on this i
think you already have but but when
president biden announced your
appointment
or at least shortly before he talked
about i want a judge that's
going to read new rights into the
constitution through the ninth amendment
um
and i'm sure some americans are saying
that's a good thing but you got a lot of
americans going hey wait a minute
the supreme court isn't elected
i uh
a couple years ago
chief of staff ron claim wrote an
opinion piece
and he said he hopes and i'm going to
quote
um
that quote the supreme i hope the
supreme court will intervene whenever
the nation's conscience
and laws need a jolt in a progressive
direction
that's policy nathan do you agree with
that statement
do do i agree with the statement that
that's policy making or i'm sorry with
what the chief said
senator that's a political statement
made by someone in the executive branch
um
i'm
i'm not going to push it on pushing that
i get it
it's not a good time to make the chief
of staff mad
i mean you know she's not going to
decide cases based on what the chief of
staff wants confirmed
i mean this is what judicial strength
australia is all about and i think part
of the division in our country
um
america's a big wide open diverse
sometimes dysfunctional but
sometimes imperfect but basically good
country but we we
we have different values that's part of
our diversity
and i think our country works because of
our system of federalism
um
the values in louisiana may be different
from the values in maine
and if you don't like what's going on in
maine and you don't you like what's
going on in louisiana you can move
but
as our federal government has gotten
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
um what what what we had is what has
developed at least here in washington is
this managerial elite
and i'm when i say the manager of lead i
mean i mean the entrenched politicians i
guess i shouldn't say entrenched because
that's pejorative
but we do have a lot of politicians that
have been here a long time
um
they're members of the media that are
part of the managerial elite they're
members of the administrative state
they're academics that are part of it
uh there are a lot of corporate phonies
that are part of it
and many people in this this cable think
they are smarter and more virtuous than
the american people
and that they ought to
set forth
how people should live their lives
people should shut up
and just do what they're told and if
they behave maybe the manager of elite
won't let them eat meat occasionally
and i think that's part of the vision in
our country
and i think to some extent
the supreme court
i don't want to say contributes to it
but it needs to be mindful of this
i'll give you another example
oh my god and this case bothers me i
want you to explain it
um i think
lindsay talked to you about it but
lindsay i want to hear you explain it
it's make the road new york versus
mclean you remember that one i do yeah
here's the way i read it congress
we
in a
rare moment of consensus
gave ds dhs the sole and unreviewable
those like my words are in the statute
the sole and unreviewable right to
determine when illegal immigrants
should be removed on an expedited basis
the department of health of uh
homeland security taking the statute
decided to use its soul and unreviewable
authority or discretion
to state that we're going to have
expedited removal of all illegal
immigrants who've been in the u.s less
than two years
and you said no
and not only that you issued
a universal injunction
and i don't understand why
you talked about judicial activism
and i don't see how clear or congress
could have been
now the dc circuit reversed you but i
want to hear your reasons
for for issuing that nationwide
injunction
thank you senator for allowing me to uh
address
that decision in that case
the statute at issue
gave
discretion to dhs
to determine
the amount of time that a person needed
to have been in the country
between zero and 24 months
in order to be subject to expedited
removal as opposed to
the normal removal process in the
immigration system
the statute said the dhs had
sole discretion meaning no
i interpreted meaning no other
agency
was to have the authority to make that
determination
and the statute said that dhs's
determination in that regard
was unreviewable meaning
it was final once this is how i'm
interpreting um
meaning that once the decision was made
it was over
nobody else gets to review the court
doesn't get to say
um
no you're wrong if you pick
12 months for example or 16 months or 24
months as they did in this case
the statute did not
speak to whether congress intended with
that grant of
very
broad discretion
to exclude another statute that congress
has passed
that directs agencies when congress
gives them discretion it the other
statute the apa directs agencies as to
how
they go about making decisions that
congress has given them the authority to
make the apa is a procedural statute it
says to agencies when congress gives you
discretion to make a determination
you have to do so in a way that's not
arbitrary and capricious you have to use
your expertise right in certain kinds of
decisions you have to use notice and
comment in order to get information it's
procedural
the claim that was being made in this
case as i read it and understood it
was not that the agency couldn't
pick 24 months
because obviously congress had said in
the statute you can pick between 0 and
24 months the claim that was being made
is that the agency picked 24 months
arbitrarily in violation of congress's
direction about how you go about the
accident was violated yes the claim was
an apa violation so no one was saying
that the statute was violated in the
sense that the agency did something that
it couldn't have done per the statute
picking 24 months they said the apa was
violated because this is the claim that
they were making sure because
the agency did no analysis the agency
did no expertise the agency did not
evaluate
okay if you've been here six months
these are the kinds of ties that you
have if you've been here 18 months right
the agency didn't do anything
essentially according to the claimants
the agency heard the president say
we're going to now do 24 months when
everybody else all of the other
administrations are at this point
because i've only got two yes i'm sorry
all right is that no what i hear you
saying is tell me if i'm wrong yes
they they didn't follow the apa in your
opinion which you have to do even though
congress passed the statute well no
because
two things one is the apa under dc
long-standing dc circuit case law is
presumptively
applicable to every situation in which
an agency is exercising its discretion
so that's the first thing it's always
there as a background rule so the dc
circuit has said congress has to be
pretty clear
when
it decides to exclude the apa when it's
saying i'm giving you discretion but you
can do this arbitrarily you can do it
however you want
and in other places in the immigration
statute that sets up expedited removal
congress says we are excluding the apa
we're telling you that with respect to
this kind of discretion the apa doesn't
apply okay so here i had these two
statutes and there are canons of
statutory interpretation that says that
you should try to give effect to all of
the will of congress you should try to
read statutes so that they go together
in a way if you have these two
directives and there's also dc circuit
case law judge i got a copy all right
cause i'm i got it
and and and let me just say i agree that
the dc circuit reversed me they
disagreed with my interpretation and
that's the way
that our system works
let me ask this last question
this is this is a question about based
on your experience
can we
agree that if
i want to emphasize if
cocaine is cocaine
that
crack cocaine
is equal in
in its its danger
to pattern cocaine
you with me
i think so one is not more dangerous
than the other if that's true
then
the sentencing rules ought to be the
same
okay i don't know it's a policy matter
for congress you could make them
differently if you wanted
this one i want to ask you yeah based on
your experience you've been on the bench
a decade yes
is crack more cocaine
more dangerous than powdered or less of
the same
senator that's a policy determination
that's what policymakers do they look at
the evidence related to these things and
they decide what's more dangerous what
have you seen what should
i have seen evidence
um through the sentencing commission
that the two compositions are chemically
uh similar
so similar as to be indistinguishable
and the commission for very
many years
as a policy-making body
indicated its view that they should be
equivalent and lobbied congress
concerning that and congress made a
determination about in the policy realm
um making it 18 to one instead of a
hundred to one which is what it had
previously meant okay thanks mr chairman
thank you senator very interesting
very very interesting all right we're
going to keep going there's four to go
guys i will be back i know you're being
very mindful of the clock so i just want
to say i have two initial more
substantive questions and then i think
two very brief
questions but are uh
very important
uh so i'll get right to it
judge jackson i am
so
glad that you take some pride
in sharing your family's story
as you should
i know i take pride in sharing mine my
colleagues have heard it but i never get
tired of uh reminding folks that i am
the proud son of immigrants my parents
came to united states from mexico
decades ago
and through their hard work and
determination
they raised three of us my sister my
brother and i we all attended and
graduated from college and we've all
found
successful careers in public service
now it's a story
that is shared by hard-working immigrant
families across the country
and over the course of generations
families who work diligently each day
to create a better life and to
contribute to the country
whether it's as farm workers short order
cooks celebrity chefs
software engineers or tech ceos as
school custodians teachers
principals
whether they're documented or
undocumented
people who migrate to this country
seeking asylum
seeking refuge
or a shot at the american dream
all deserve to be treated
with dignity
and
humanity now unfortunately our laws and
our courts
don't always do that
beyond our often cruel and
counterproductive choices that we've
made over the years when it comes to
immigration policy
the language that we use to speak about
immigrants
can
often have dehumanizing effects
for example
in the immigration and nationality act
it's replete with references to quote
unquote aliens
and court opinions written by federal
judges across the country can be found
referring to undocumented persons as
quote illegal
aliens
now i know nasa has put a man on the
moon and there are billionaires
increasingly exploring space
but let's be clear no person
is an alien
and no human being can be illegal
so with that context
i read your immigration related
decisions
on the district court with great
interest
now beyond the substance of your
opinions
which what stood out to me
is that you seem to have tried to avoid
making the same choice
as many of your predecessors and many of
your colleagues
when not quoting
statutes or precedent
your appearance your opinions appear not
to refer to immigrants as
alien or illegal
instead use
terms such as undocumented
and non-citizen
i imagine
i hope that was a conscious choice
the language we use
and the language our courts use to
describe people
whether immigrants
the formerly incarcerated
individuals who identify as
lgbtq
or other historically marginalized
people really matters a great deal our
language matters
it's exactly for that reason that six
years ago
congress passed a bill to remove
derogatory and offensive references to
black americans asian americans and
native americans from the u.s code
and it's why last year president biden
ordered the customs and border
protection agency and ice to stop
referring to migrants as illegal
immigrants
with all that said
judge jackson do you agree that the
language we use to describe one another
and the language used by the bench
matters
thank you senator
um
as i mentioned uh earlier in this
hearing
judges um are
the only branch of government who are
required to
write our opinions to explain
our decisions and
i have
long believed in that capacity that our
clarity
and language matters we're explaining
the law to people
and
people
read and understand what the law is what
the rule of law is in this country
through the opinions of
judges
so they do matter language
thank you
now i want to discuss with you an issue
of uh law and technology an issue
previously raised by senator ossoff
earlier today and
i'm excited to talk to you
about this topic just as an aside
any day that an mit engineer gets to
question a harvard lawyer it's a good
day
so thank you for indulging
but as you know the supreme court only
hears a tiny fraction of all federal
appeals
that means that the cases that get to
the supreme court are typically either
new questions of law or very difficult
questions of law and i think the
intersection of law and technology is
one where many cases are both
new and difficult
over the cent over the course of human
history innovation has constantly
disrupted our culture
and our norms
and for the most part with good
intentions
but societal benefits have not always
been the result of innovation
innovations have challenged us to
respond with new means
of safeguarding basic rights
whether in the context of privacy
security
competition
employment just to name a few
and i appreciate that the speed of
innovation will always challenge
our ability to keep the law up to date
with new technologies and their impact
i've grappled with this question as a
city council member as a state senator
as a secretary of state and now as
united states senator
but clearly it's also a challenge for
the courts which often have to decide
cases during that period between
technological progress and the enactment
of new laws that seek to account
for that progress
now new technology
alone has given
rise to
a number of fundamental questions of law
as you mentioned yesterday and earlier
including how the fourth amendment
applies to new context that no founder
could have ever contemplated
and likewise the court has to grapple
with questions like how copyright law
applies to computer code
and in the coming years new technologies
will present new questions
not just in the context of the fourth
amendment
but in areas of communications
energy
transportation
health care
and many others
so if you can take just a minute judge
to
discuss the challenges that courts at
every level
face in addressing cases involving new
and emerging technologies and how you
as a supreme court justice would begin
to prepare for these types of cases
thank you senator
um
the court does
get cases that involve disputes
that touch on technological innovation
whether it is something like a copyright
a kind of case or a patent kind of case
or
the fourth amendment search and seizure
new technologies do
intersect with what
what the law says
in the constitution and in statutes and
at least as far as statutes are
concerned
it's certainly much easier for judges
who are
doing their duty to interpret the law
if congress makes changes that update
the statutes to track
um the modern innovations
what happens with
constitutional interpretation
is
similar to what
i described earlier about cases in which
the court
analogizes back to the time of the
founding concerning the principles
in something like search and seizure
what qualified as a search
that violated the constitution
when those words were written
and then
determines whether that same kind of
violation is at issue with respect to
the technology today
and the court has done that
with respect to
searches regarding cell phones
police access to gps data
tracking technology that is put on
vehicles
because these disputes do
come up
and so
so i'll take this opportunity to
encourage congress to help us
um
by
um
ensuring that new technologies are
addressed in statutes
that we interpret you're absolutely
right both judges and
members of congress are never done doing
more homework
and learning hopefully
uh
judge on on monday which at this point
feels like so long ago
i suggested in my opening statement that
uh by the end of these hearings
america would know just how qualified
you are
to serve on the supreme court
and over the course of this hearing
i think the american people have seen
that
and
have gotten to know you as a person
they have heard your family's journey
and
everything that your nomination
represents
now i also said on monday that your
qualifications bear repeating over and
over again and so judge with your help
i'd like to
remind the committee and the american
people once again
just some
of your incredible credentials
yes or no
after law school did you serve as a law
clerk for a district court
judge a court of appeals judge and a
supreme court justice
i did senator
yes or no did you practice law for more
than 10 years before becoming a judge
yes senator
and did that
include time in private practice and
time as a federal public defender
it did
how many years have you served as a
federal district court judge
i served as a federal district court
judge for i believe eight and a half
years
and circuit since then circuit since
last june and as a district court judge
approximately how many
opinions did you write i think we've
covered this before
as a district court judge i believe i
wrote somewhere in the neighborhood of
560.
with a very low rate of uh
having been reversed uh if i've done my
homework correctly look i can go on and
on and don't worry mr chairman i won't
but
judge jackson for two days
here's what i've seen
i've seen a number of my colleagues
trying to engage with you in good faith
on questions about the law
and you've answered them fully
fairly and thoughtfully in every
instance
you've shown yourself
to have
the keem intellect and legal acumen
to serve on the supreme court
now you've also sat here and politely
listened
as some of my colleagues have attempted
to disparage your judgment and character
based on allegations that even
as
senator booker pointed out
conservative commentators have called
meritless to the point of demagoguery
and through that you've shown clearly
that you have the temperament to serve
on the supreme court
now this confirmation hearing has been a
reminder
and
in some ways a new exhibit a
that
for people of color
particularly those who have the audacity
to try to be the first
often have to work twice as hard
to get half the respect
judge jackson i offer that with your
talent and exemplary qualifications on
full display if my colleagues truly
believe in maintaining the legitimacy of
the supreme court
if they really care about americans
faith in the judicial system
they will see that even if they may
disagree with you
on a particular area of the law
that you're exactly the type of judge
that should serve on the supreme court
you're exactly the type of judge that
should receive bipartisan support not
just from this committee but from the
full senate
and if any senator doesn't
then i hope
they'll think long and hard about what
it says to the country
about the politicians the politicization
of the supreme court
that if someone is emily qualified as
judge jackson in all the ways that we've
been discussing cannot receive
bipartisan support
judge and there's just a couple minutes
left
and i'd like to ask you just one last
question
last friday
in my preparation for these hearings
i took the opportunity to spend some
time
with
a group of students at south san
francisco high school
i went there to speak with them about
this historic supreme court nomination
and to speak
with them about you
we had a great conversation about how
the court's decisions affect the
everyday lives of americans
and about the past and the future of the
supreme court
but as i was speaking with the students
i couldn't help
but be reminded
of my own high school experience
when one of my teachers
discouraged me
from applying to mit
because they didn't want me to be
disappointed
i turned that discouragement into
motivation
judge jackson i know that you too
have been doubted on your way
to the seat that you find yourself in
today
even over the last three days of this
hearing your experience and
qualifications have been called into
question by some
despite your clear
lengthy record of talent
achievement and accomplishment
so i want to end my time today by asking
you this question
on behalf of the young people i visited
with last friday
in south san francisco
and for the many others across the
country
who are watching
this confirmation hearing today
what would you say judge jackson to all
those young americans the most diverse
generation in our nation's history what
do you say to
some of them who may doubt that they can
one day achieve the same great heights
that you have
thank you senator um
that was very moving
and i appreciate
the opportunity to uh
speak to young people
i appreciate it very much i do it a lot
for the reasons that you have
articulated
i
i hope to inspire people
to try to follow
this path because i love this country
because i love the law
because i think it is important
that we all invest
in our future
and
the young people are the future and so i
want them to know that they can
do and be
anything
and i'll just say that um
i will tell them
what
uh an anonymous person said to me once i
was walking through
harvard yard my freshman year
as i mentioned i went to
public school and
i didn't know anything about harvard
until
my debate coach took me there to enter a
speech competition and i thought this is
a great university it was basically one
of the only ones i'd seen and i
said maybe i'll apply when i'm a senior
but i get there and whoa
so different
i'm from miami florida boston is very
cold
it was
um
it was rough it was different from
anything i'd known there were lots of
students there who were
prep school kids like my husband
who knew all about
knew all about harvard and that was not
not me
and
i think the first semester i was really
homesick i was really questioning
um
do i belong here can i
can i make it in this
environment and i was walking through
the yard in the evening
and a black woman i did not know
was passing me
on the sidewalk and she looked at me and
i guess she knew
how i was feeling
and she leaned over as we crossed and
said
persevere
i would tell them to persevere
thank you judge jackson you don't have
to hope
i'll tell you right now you do
inspire
you
are
an inspiration
and i will associate
myself
with the
closing words of my colleague and my
brother senator booker
that i too refuse to let anyone
steal my joy
thank you mr chair
thank you senator padilla senator tillis
thank you mr chair
judge jackson as senator booker was
providing his closing comments i could
only think
and they were very powerful that if you
like tez how much you're going to like
mine on the subject of intellectual
property
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but before i do that i know you've
you've been spending a lot of time here
do you have much experience in matters
of copyright protection patent
protection
senator i um mentioned earlier that i
did a trademark case yep um not that way
i looked up the menu uh it looks like a
really good menu i think it's a good
restaurant they they they had a lot of
evidence to that effect i haven't done a
lot of uh food or restaurant uh
trademark work but uh when i
came to judiciary uh fortunately the
the former chair and the current chair
indulged us in reinstituting the
intellectual property subcommittee and i
love that committee
because you really have to work hard to
be partisan in it and in fact it's not
partisan i worked very well with as the
chair with
senator coons and done very well with
with
senator leahy and senator rono and
working together on things that i think
are really important because i think one
of the things that make the our country
great is the founding fathers got it
right on understanding the value of
intellectual property and how
it could catapult us into the innovation
powerhouse that we are today
um so i may ask you a few questions
about it but i'm not going to dig
too deeply i do want to go back
to
maybe getting a suggestion from you i
thought
i told you i don't even pretend to be an
attorney but i am
about 30 years into technology as a
matter of fact i spent two years in
boston at wang laboratories
and it was no coincidence having been
born and raised in florida that i moved
one september because i couldn't bear
another winner
um
but uh but i may i bet in the uh
technical field i i was working on in on
ip or internet protocol before anybody
knew what internet protocol was back in
the early 90s and
i do think that we should go away and
understand the threat if you've seen the
multiple
of
illicit activities and and for the
purposes of this discussion
um
child pornography now
imagine what it's going to be like
five years from now
um
i was talking with someone in the
hallway
they're taking a playbook from drug
kingpins
the the the creators
and the the aggregators and the
distributors
are using technology i think in some
cases to reach out to people and incent
them
to go to these websites
to infect their computers
to download thousands potentially from a
single click
i think that we have to examine these
criminal enterprises
and put law enforcement resources into
cutting the heads off of these people
figuratively speaking
and one of the ways you do that is to
provide
i think more ways to go about prosecute
more technology
that we need
to cut down the supply but we still have
to deal with the demand and that's
another area where these
uh criminal organizations and others are
taking advantage
and
you know today if you think about
technology 10 years ago it was a little
odd at least 15 years ago
to see a child i've got two
granddaughters uh one is four years old
one is two years old they're technical
technologically savvy as a matter of
fact i love talking to them on the phone
but even my two-year-old knows how to
deal with the filters to make me look
like i've got the rabbit ears and
everything they're technologically savvy
there's a real danger there that these
uh horrible people and i genuinely
believe that you think
there are horrible people
are going
excuse me they're going to infect
and destroy a lot of lives
and so i don't know is it what the
sentencing commission
how would you
how
and and incidentally this is a toxic
subject
uh in congress because if you start
talking about better understanding those
most people are going to run away from
it but we do it at the expense
of destroying a lot of victims lights
so i don't
unless you have ideas off the top of
your head i'm trying to get an idea of
how we can make people understand we
maybe we could even have a discussion to
say that the penalties today are the
floor
to to begin the discussion just to
simply
eliminate people from making this so
toxic that we don't better understand it
and get ahead of it
but
how can we even start having an
intelligent discussion
and a productive discussion
where congress is clearly going to need
to act to do what i think everybody in
this room wants to do
is just erase it from the planet of the
earth or at least make a lot of progress
because quite honestly
it has exponentially grown and there are
exponentially more victims today than
there were even 10 years ago
any ideas
thank you senator i actually don't i
haven't been um
working on or looking at or dealing with
sentencing policy for a long time now
um
in my work as a judge we're looking at
individual cases not systems or
crime organizations and
policies related to them yeah well i do
i think it's something that that we
should take seriously and after we cool
the temperatures and and have people
have legitimate concerns about
some of the rulings i think that we have
to clear up some of the complexity and
recognize that congress is a part of the
solution
okay now on the weighty subject of
intellectual property are you familiar
with the copyright preemption uh under
section 301a
um no i haven't worked with it okay
i wouldn't have expected you to
necessarily but
uh and i won't get into a patent
questions we've got a lot of work that i
think ultimately is going to require us
getting rid of the shambles of
jurisprudence that we have it's a very
complicated field we've got a lot of
mixed signals and
current jurisprudence and my committee's
working on that so it may be something
that ultimately works its way up to you
all
if you're confirmed but i'm not going to
take a lot of time particularly because
the hour is late and i intend to yield
back some of my time i do want to go
back because i felt like this morning
when i went through
some of my comments i mentioned law
enforcement i talked about
a couple of your decisions that gave me
pause mainly
excuse me because
you know law enforcement's under attack
law enforcement needs to be held to a
high standard i've been involved in this
for
nearly 22 years making sure that when i
was a town councilman
that we did something audacious and
spend a lot of money and getting our law
enforcement officers in a small town of
only 20 000 people kalia certified
that's a national certification to make
sure that they understand how to
de-escalate
get engaged in the community and
and reduce crime
and and it worked
but now we've you know there are some
people that think it's fashionable to
attack the police
and to defund the police and quite
honestly there's increasing data
that suggests the communities that are
loudest about that are becoming the
least safe so i want to ask you
mentioned several times
i think yesterday and and more today
about your methodology
so if uh is the united states versus
jenkins fresh in your mind or roughly
fresh in your mind
um
uh criminal pleaded guilty to assault
and law assaulting a law officer
it was his third conviction
in assaulting a law enforcement officer
the government ran recommended 30 months
the defense
recommended 21 months and you decided to
go with an 18-month sentence so i was
trying to does it do you recall
i don't recall i would want to look at
the records and see the probation
office's recommendation as well okay and
that again is something i wouldn't have
access to so i'm just trying to figure
out what the mitigating
circumstances were and there were other
ones and unless you immediately recall
it i'm not going to ask you to go into
details the other one was united states
versus weeks
there was a 24-month request from the
government
uh
uh for the conviction on assaulting an
officer and you gave him 12 months and
uh are you from does that ring a bell
united states versus weeks
i think weeks had a number of different
appearances and there were different
aspects to his case but i'd have to look
at the whole
file to recall
that uh i just feel like the um
again because i know that you've uh
rendered some 100 sentences over
uh a period of time i wouldn't expect
you but it but it does it is an area
that uh we'll submit it as a question
for the record so that maybe you can
refresh your memory and try to get back
on that because it's something that i
for one think that we need to
place a priority on we've got so many
law enforcement agencies across the
country now excuse me that um
we're having a hard time recruiting
people and having a hard time retaining
people a lot of people are retiring
and
um you know i know not every police
officer is an angel i was talking with
somebody in my office in my office who
was talking about her brother she had a
lot of confidence in them she was here
to talk to me about police reforms and
i actually believed that the vast
majority of police officers like your
brother and your family members were
good people and a part of what we have
to do is just make sure that
when we have these assaults which are
increasing
that we have just punishment because we
need to do that for the protection not
only the law enforcement officers but
the communities they serve
so you know and and i'm going to yield
back time because i know we've got two
other uh people
talking and you know i thought you've
done a great job over the last two days
i've tried to be here i had an emergency
in italy for about an hour and a half
but i tried to be here for a business
emergency emergency
but i thought that you presented
yourself well and there was a lot of
pressure
and uh
that demonstrates uh a certain
temperament or poise i can't imagine
what's going on inside your head but at
least overtly
you did very well and you should be
proud of that it's not an easy thing
it's it's very easy up here
to feel comfortable right because
there's 22 of us and it's not like you
can
really come at us
so you have an arm
tied behind your back and i'm sure that
there were a number of things you'd like
to say but time didn't allow but
um you know i just want to commend you
your family
your daughter who has been glowing
every time you
talk and i appreciate your service thank
you i yield back mr chair thanks senator
tillis senator
senator ossoff you started the day for
us
judge good evening we've come full
circle to the end of the dais
um
likewise i don't intend to use all of my
time
i do want to echo
the sentiments expressed by
senator tillis
you have
conducted these hearings with
extraordinary
poise
strength
grace under pressure
you've had a lot of poison thrown at you
and you've responded
with substance and truth
and it's
shown through
not just in this room but
across the country and around the world
so i have
two
substantive questions regarding the
first amendment
one question
as i noted
that i wanted to
address regarding war powers and then
i'll be yielding the remainder of my
time
to the chair and onto senator blackburn
to close
we discussed
earlier this morning judge
the
constituent elements of the first
amendment with respect to speech
expression
and assembly
i just briefly want to touch on the free
exercise of religion
my great-grandparents
came to this country fleeing
anti-semitism in eastern europe many
american stories
including many of the very first
american stories
involve flight from religious
persecution
just briefly would ask you to
touch upon
the constitutional roots
and significance in our system of
government
of the first amendment protection of the
free exercise of religion
thank you senator
as you mentioned
free exercise of religion and
the establishment clause which
prevents the state the government from
preferring
religion over another
is
foundational it is
the principle
that many people
originally
came to this country when it was founded
in order to
support it was
people who
fled from religious persecution and
wanted to found a country in which
everyone could
believe what they wanted to believe and
not have the government
encroach
impinge on
uh burden
that right and so it is it is a core
foundational right it's in the first
uh amendment
and your family story um
is very similar to many
families who
moved to this country for for that
reason
thank you judge jackson um we discussed
in brief
earlier today
the sullivan
decision new york times v sullivan
um
in which the court established a
standard by which
libel and defamation claims by public
figures
would be judged and
my understanding correct me if i'm wrong
is that the standard is
that
false statements
must be made
knowingly
that the party making the false
statement must know but it is false
and
must make such knowingly false
statements with malice am i correct that
that's the standard in the case i
believe it's knowingly or
with reckless disregard for the truth
um and that that standard is
termed or thought of as actual malice
yes
is there any
generalized obligation in law that
you're aware of to
accurate
reporting
or accurate publication
where there is not
malice or where there is not one of the
components established in the sullivan
case
if i if i understand your question um i
know that the standard related to the
sullivan case
um
does pertain to public figures and so if
a public figure is not
involved
there may there's a different standard
in terms of liability for inaccurate
or defamatory
statements
thank you judge and i want to note that
the chairman
earlier
remarked upon the
disruptions in the the market in
publishing and the dissemination of
information that that technology has
caused in recent years
and i was reflecting as the chairman
spoke that
at the time of the
invention of the printing press
many of those who previously had
centralized control of the production
and dissemination of information
recognized that it was disruptive and
threatening and that it disrupted
power dynamics and it empowered new
participants in public discourse to
participate
and i just want to express to you this
is not a question but express to you
my view that it is vital that we in
congress
and the judiciary
relentlessly defend the principles of
the first amendment and the free
expression of ideas even as new
technologies emerge which disrupt these
markets and um
and present challenging new particular
circumstances to the court
uh
a very brief question
on the
not
light-hearted but important subject of
war powers um
i reviewed
some of the comments that prior nominees
have made when asked about questions
with respect to the allocation of
war powers between the legislative and
executive branches
and something that i've seen in in some
of those transcripts has been a tendency
to say well these are disputes between
the political branches and questions
about those authorities should be
resolved between the political branches
i noted in
the mccann opinion that you issued
you noted in that case that one of the
reasons it was
appropriate for the judiciary to
consider
the claim made by the u.s house
in that case was that where there is a
dispute between the legislative and the
executive in that case and perhaps in
many cases the judiciary is precisely
the appropriate forum for the resolution
of that dispute
and so it it seems to me that
the court and and you should be
confirmed
may very well have to entertain
cases and controversies pertaining to
disputes between the legislative and the
executive respect to war powers because
there is in my opinion unsettled law
there's some ambiguity
in statute the constitution alligates
allocates various authorities to the two
branches
so
not asking you to
posit a
thesis on this point but just want to
ask you
how you will approach such cases i
assume applying the methodology
that you have laid out for us
consistently
throughout these hearings where war
powers may come before the court
thank you senator um in in every case
um i applied the methodology that i
have laid out
in order to ensure that i'm ruling
impartially
and
consistent with my judicial authority
in the
part of my methodology that
addresses my judicial authority one of
the things that
i do as judges do is decide
whether i have jurisdiction
to hear a particular issue
the mcgann case was not a war powers
case
the mcgann case
i determined in that opinion and
judge bates had determined in the prior
opinion
raised a question of law
the question
essentially was
whether the subpoena that had been
issued by the house
had to be responded to
by
the person who received it or whether
that person had absolute immunity and
did not have to respond that's a
question of law that courts answer all
the time with respect to the
enforceability of subpoenas
in the war powers
realm
there may be questions of law that are
appropriate for courts to decide
um but there may also be political
questions
and so it would depend a political
question if if there was a dispute
between the legislature and the
executive branch over some
exercise of authority that was not
governed by law
but was in the discretion of either of
those branches under the constitution
where they got to make determination
something say for example like the
exercise of executive authority in war
to move troops or do that kind of thing
that would not
present a question of law that the court
could decide
so it would depend on
exactly what the court was being asked
to do as to whether or not it had
jurisdiction and under my methodology
that would be the kind of thing that i
would have to carefully
examine in order to determine whether i
could
uh rule
thank you judge let me close with this
comment
as i said you have conducted yourself
with extraordinary skill and grace
throughout these proceedings
and
it's uh in in some ways a lonely place
for you to sit there under the lights uh
facing questions many of them
substantive
some of them less so
um
many of them constructive
some of them mean-spirited and
distracting you've handled it all
extraordinarily well
it's been a very long two days
i know you know this
but i just want to make sure you do
that throughout
this process and right now
there are millions and millions of
people
who are watching
and cheering you on
right at this very moment
in homes across this country
there are millions and millions of
people inspired by you and your example
who are cheering you on
and not just that
there are people all over the world
all over the world
who are watching these proceedings
and seeing
what is possible in america
after some years when there's been some
doubt
about what this country stands for
that's my opinion not yours
but people all over the world
are watching this and seeing what is
possible in america
what is possible in the system of
government that we have what values this
country stands for and i thank you
profoundly
for the service you've rendered
throughout your life
and in this hearing
and with seven minutes remaining mr
chairman
i know you'll remain focused right
through the end i have no doubt that
senator blackburn has some provocative
questions for you i yield the remainder
of my time
thank you very much senator ossoff and
senator blackburn senator blackburn will
be last thanks to be kind nike potato m
boss lizard stan and uh straw carpenter
for the twitch prime subscriptions king
notes because he's a new daddy and if
you have time he'll show you pictures
but uh indeed we have all
enjoyed hearing about your family and
your parents and how hard they worked to
open doors of opportunity for you
and look at how you went through those
doors
and really created such a wonderful life
and i mentioned yesterday that i would
hear from friends in tennessee and so
many of them talk about they like how
you have pushed those barriers aside
because a lot of them have had to do the
same thing to kind of make their way
into careers and so they've appreciated
that very much about you and i'll have
to tell
uh senator booker
now i i like the fact that he talked
about fred astaire and ginger rogers
and
when my daughter was in high school i
actually bought that poster and i've
probably told senator klobuchar this
before but i bought that poster of fred
astaire and ginger rogers and they're
dancing and it says i took every step he
took but in high heels and backward
just to make the point with her
that she was going to have to work hard
and indeed she accepted that challenge
and i'm really proud of her like i know
all all parents are proud of their uh
children
i do want to get to a couple of things
and we do have the vote on the board uh
yesterday during our discussion you had
mentioned that you were unfamiliar with
some of the statements that i had read
back to you your previous statements and
writings including the statements on
child pornography and critical race
theory i was a little surprised by that
because i know the white house has
worked really hard
to prepare you for
the hearing so i wanted to introduce
documents just so that we have those in
the record mr chairman the first
document is an article it's funny
because there are there are documents
she's not familiar with in which she
will be asked no more questions about so
like imagine being like well i'm just
going to look at what documents are here
oh all right team 2020 edition
of georgetown days magazine you stated
and i quote since becoming a part of the
gds community seven years ago i've
witnessed the transformative power of a
rigorous progressive education end quote
second document
is a transcript of a you really have to
think through the motivation for
introducing these because it's like okay
she's done
sorry judge jackson is done answering
questions today
so putting these documents in it would
be for someone to go later and be like
okay let's see here's the document judge
jackson didn't know anything about i
guess i shouldn't vote for her on the
basis i mean put in books she hasn't
read also right i mean it's crazy i went
back and pulled
that
to show that it was a statement and not
a question so mr chairman i asked
permission to enter those without
objection thank you mr chairman um
we talked about abortion yesterday and i
want to go back to that um
on abortion i had another question there
some
have argued that bills seeking to
protect children who survive
abortions are unconstitutional
they say that the right to an abortion
includes the right to an effective
abortion so in other words
does the constitutional right to an
abortion include the right
to let a baby die if that baby
unintentionally survives an abortion i'd
like to know if you agree
with that
thank you senator um
issues like the one that you have raised
are in the court system now and as a
result
um as a nominee to the supreme court i'm
not able to
opine
about the constitutionality or not of
the kinds of legislation that you
mentioned
well
i
you know
one of the main factors the supreme
court is considering
is deciding whether to uphold roe in in
all of this and with precedent
um
is if all of this is a settled issue or
not
and some of those that are
on this about whether it is to an
abortion or an effective abortion
and if that constitutional right
includes the right to terminate the life
of a baby that survives that abortion so
that is an issue you will
that will be decided before you go to
the court but i think it's important
to have that
discussion i do want to go back to
the
the issue about the child predators and
as you've heard senator blumenthal and i
are working on legislation senator
klobuchar's got some legislation that
deals with technology but i want to ask
you this because of some of the
questioning and it's just a yes or no do
you believe child predators are
misunderstood
senator i don't i don't have a context
for that i believe well we're going back
to the comment on the sentencing
commission
as you said sandbag questions not all
child predators were pedophiles
senator i believe that all child
predators are dangerous
um that the behavior that they engage in
is
horrible okay that
it needs to be taken seriously by the
court yeah you could be a child predator
who wants to hurt kids but not sexually
assault them right i mean you could be a
predator without being a pedophile i
think your position that child
pornography offenders are not pedophiles
senator i believe that the statement
that you referenced was a part of a
hearing
before the sentencing commission in 2012
it was a meeting yes it was a meeting
and and what the sentencing commission
does is it right
reviews evidence about various things
and i believe i was right and as i said
yesterday
um
i the children that are victimized they
don't understand the difference between
an offender and a pedophile
or a pornographer and i do think it's a
distinction without a difference let me
ask you about gun rights oh boy um
violent crime is rampant
we have seen that during the last year
it's making people really nervous
i pulled some stats in 2021 27 major u.s
cities experienced a 44
increase in homicides since 2019 over a
dozen cities set new homicide records in
21. and a lot of families no longer feel
safe so they're buying guns they're
buying ammo
and trying to make certain that they can
protect themselves and in times like
this i think we're really fortunate
that the founders afforded
such
constitutional protection as the second
amendment so very quickly walk me
through
what um
current supreme court
president says about the second
amendment
thank you senator current supreme court
president
says that um
under the second amendment there is an
individual
fundamental right to keep and bear arms
um
in the home and the
opinion focuses on
those
and so you agree it is an individual
right
and not only reserved to militias
because there are some that keep trying
to say it's the only reserved to
militias
but
if my memory is correct
you base this on uh district of columbia
versus heller that it is an independent
yes ma'am that the supreme court has
established it's an individual right i
wanted to get that on the record because
i don't think anybody had asked you that
this entire time what a clever question
huh
here's another question i've asked other
judicial nominees that are coming to us
for the district court and the appellate
court and i've really not gotten a
satisfactory answer from anybody
so why is it
constitutionally permissible
for the right to keep and bear arms
which the supreme court has recognized
as a fundamental right and you agree
with that
why is it constitutionally permissible
for this right to be subject to the
discretionary issuance of a license by a
local official
thank you senator
the supreme court is
looking at that very issue
in a case
before it right now and
as a nominee for the supreme court it's
important
that i not speak to it
uh because the court is is deciding this
question
um
it has a pending case i believe
arguments that even have even occurred
related to it
so should other unenumerated rights be
subject to the same
type forbearance having to get a local
license should someone that wants an
abortion
have to go before a government
bureaucrat
because
the second amendment whoa that's very
stupid bear arms
is oh my god that's shockingly stupid of
the constitution
so the question would be why should it
have to have
an extra burden
i understand the question it's one that
the supreme court is looking at
and
consistent with that might be the record
for the dumbest question so far and
there's been some dumb questions like
are babies racist issues that are that
are alive all right then let me
move move on i want to turn to some of
the sentencing decisions like an
abortion isn't something you can put in
your pocket and then and then used to
shoot mass numbers of people it just
it's bizarre question
have an unmistakable pattern
of releasing criminals with dangerous
backgrounds into the community and the
coveted 19 pandemic seemed to exacerbate
the trend
to name just a few examples you use the
covid19 pandemic as justification
to release a fentanyl drug dealer a bank
robber addicted to heroin a convict who
murdered a u.s marshal back on the
streets
and at a time when violent crimes
including homicide are spiking all
across the country
and we're facing an opioid epidemic
driven in large part
by the trafficking of fentanyl
across our border how can you isn't it
pronounced fentanyl
these offenders do not pose a danger
to the community
thank you senator for allowing me to
answer this
question
the statutes that govern judges and that
allow for
compassionate release are
policy determinations that congress has
made
to
permit
individuals who
are in various circumstances in various
stages in the system
to seek
release
people who are detained after their
final sentencing
um can seek something called
compassionate release people who are
detained between
when they've been convicted and when
they're sentenced
not to cut you off but time's going to
run out we do have
you know
she has many other dumb questions
that i have been asked so much
people here's a stack
these are the ones that you sought
for compassionate
release
there were 1561
that were detained
in d.c
department of corrections
and you're st
that number's supposed to shock you but
we imprisoned and attained so many
people in this country that it's not
really that many
you stated and i'm going to quote you
each and every criminal defendant in the
d.c department of corrections
custody should be released because of
the covet 19 pandemic and in that same
opinion you lamented
the fact that you as a federal judge
were limited in your ability
to order the universal release of
criminals back onto the streets and i am
shocked
that that would have been
your position because people are so
they are
just
really
concerned about crime
in the streets so do you stand by your
position that it would have been the
right thing to do to release all of
those prisoners back onto the streets
senator that was not my position in that
opinion united states versus wiggins
i
started off by explaining that given the
compassionate release
system
and the kovid 19 pandemic
it would seem as though that was
an extraordinary and compelling
circumstance but two sentences later
i say
oh that's brilliant we can't release
everyone there are people who are too
dangerous oh that's genius so even in
wiggins i decided that he had to remain
incarcerated wow notwithstanding his
compassionate release motion wow so the
point this
the sentence that i have there i did say
but i set it
to lead up to
my statement which was the actual ruling
in which i said we are not releasing
everybody we're not opening the tales
and
judge you know
to lament that
you
were limited in your ability so now it's
not that oh wow wow of all unbelievable
that is what causes
that is a judgment issue
and that is what causes
the the concern with that she would love
to release them if they weren't all
dangerous criminals who shouldn't be
released and that's what
yesterday about a speech you gave in
april 2015. wow when you had stated and
i'm going to quote you again that it
mails to when you were talking about
sentencing it melts together myriad
types of law
including critical race theory
and you told senator cruz i think it was
that when you made that statement you
were talking about decisions regarding
sentencing policy
you said and again i'm going to quote i
was talking about policy determinations
none of that relates to what i do as a
judge
i take that to mean that you
don't
make policy determinations
when you're making sentencing decisions
as a judge
so today in response to a question from
senator grassley you said the exact
opposite
you said and i'm going to quote you
again i have at times identified
various enhancement enhancements that i
have disagreed with as a policy matter
he's got to be out of time because the
supreme court has said that that's the
authority of a sentencing judge in our
system
so given that you admitted you made
policy determinations in sentencing and
you stated that you consider critical
race theory in sentencing policy let me
ask you again do you consider
critical race theory in your sentencing
decisions as a judge
thank you senator critical race theory
any academic theory is not considered in
my sentencings it never comes up in
sentencing it was not what i was talking
about in the speech
in 2015.
okay
i appreciate that i do have one
intellectual property question i'm going
to submit to you for writing you've had
a very important very important you've
been very gracious
and i i think that these are tough
questions but this is part of our doing
our due diligence and meeting our
responsibility
to the people that we represent and they
expect this of us and as i mentioned
they've been very engaged
in this
as some have said you know i think i
would like her i don't agree with her or
i agree on some things but not on
everything
but they want to know what you're going
to do do when you get on the court well
she can't say that their kids and their
grandkids are not going to have the
opportunities that you have had
unless we keep this nation free
so it demands your best and it demands
that you go to the constitution first in
your opening statement
i pulled this and this is where i'll end
with you you say i've been a judge for
nearly a decade now and i take that
responsibility and my duty to be
independent very seriously i decide
cases from a neutral posture i evaluate
the facts and i interpret and apply the
law to the facts of the case before me
without fear or favor consistent with my
judicial oath
i wish you had said consistent with the
constitution of the united states thank
you so much judge for being with us
thank you mr chairman
thank you senator blackburn this
concludes our rounds of questioning and
before we recess a few observations
first judge jackson
you are extraordinary
your story is a great american story and
i think we've all benefited by getting
to know you a little better during the
last two days
you are exceptionally qualified for this
position i won't read through your
resume it's been read many times
but i think there's no one in the room
who in the two-day period of time has
questioned your qualifications
there have been some dissenters
my colleagues promised a fair and
respectful hearing
most including my republican colleague
senator grassley
followed that admonition he always does
but there were a few obvious glaring
exceptions sorry for that
but your patience dignity and grace and
in the face of what was frankly some
offensive treatment is a real testament
to your judicial temperament to your mom
and dad
and the brown family and your chicago
lawyer brother
uh i thank you for being with us and
being part of this historic occasion
uh dr patrick
i don't know if surgery's any easier
than this but
i imagine that she
want to get back to it and i just want
to say a word to layla and talia if
she's here or she can hear us
you got a great mom
you really do
and what she's been through in the last
couple days most people would not even
consider going through one minute
but she is strong she's caring she's
kind
and you're lucky to have her and we're
going to be lucky to have her on the
supreme court so we've got a little bit
of work to do i incidentally i could go
through the list of all the invitees
that have been filing in and out of the
room behind you
wanting to be here for a moment to share
this history with you
i will let you in on something which you
may know tomorrow we're going to
announce that you've been rated
unanimously well qualified by the
american bar association that's the
highest possible rating
we're going to conclude the public
portion of this hearing
in dirksen 226 for closed session for
discussing the background investigation
that should only take a minute or so
and
i have discussed this with the ranking
member senator grassley and for the
information of all members the committee
will meet an executive session to
consider judge jackson's nomination to
the supreme court on this monday march
the 28th at 3 00 p.m
and with that the committee stands in
recess thank you thank you
meeting is right now that is the
conclusion to the question and answer
period
uh
wow what a couple of days it has been i
want to say thank you to qt jelly for
gifting 10 subscriptions at the end
there as well as to god kong tv
all of that puts us at 52
and it has been quite a trip here
something's going on here
john senator kennedy saying something
there
to katanji brown jackson uh by every
stretch of the imagination she should be
um
uh she should be unanimously confirmed
and of course it will not be unanimous i
do want to let you guys know tomorrow
morning i will be on
the uh i guess it's a daily wire thing
michael knowles show
talking about um
judge jackson's
answers to
what is a woman
and our babies racist they've invited me
to discuss that and i will be on
tomorrow at 9 30
eastern
time
i expect it will be an unmitigated [ __ ]
show
so that will be tomorrow thank you
everybody for joining me we will see you
then